Welcome to our digital marketing full
course you passort to Conquering the
digital landscape in this immersive
experience we will be your Guides
Through the Realms of SEO Affiliates
backlinks and social media marketing
first up SEO Mastery uncover the art of
making search engines fall in love with
your content through keyword sorcery
optimization spells and algorithmic
insights it's time to ascend the ranks
and dominate the digital realm next
let's Venture into the world of
Affiliates discover the magic of turning
collaborations into profits learn the
Strategic dance of Partnerships leverage
and turning clicks into a revenue
Powerhouse no digital Conquest is
complete without the secret source of
backlinks domestify the process of
building a robust network of connections
that not only boost your online
visibility but also establish your
digital Authority finally buckle up for
the dynamic journey of social media
marketing from crafting thumb stopping
content to navigating the ever evolving
algorithms we will equip you with the
skills to make an impact across
platforms this course isn't just a
learning experience it's a
transformation are you ready to elevate
your digital presence and emerge as a
true marketing mro then get certified
with postgraduate program in digital
marketing by simply learn which will be
your all over companion with this
program you will as in keyword research
search engine optimization behavioral
marketing campaign management social
media marketing and much more
with this technical expertise you'll
also gain complete Hands-On learning
with the tools like Google Keyword
Planner chat JP Google ads Google
analytics and there are more than 30
tools in the list reserve your seats
fast enroll now from the link in the
description box and the pin command
moving ahead before start with the Core
Concepts let's go through the industry
demands in digital marketing we'll start
with knowing reasons to learn digital
marketing followed by tips on how to
become digital marketing expert how to
set up a digital marketing agency making
digital marketing specialist resume post
which we will start with digital
marketing Core Concepts and before we
begin consider subscribing to Simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from us so let's get
started digital marketing plays an
essential role in most businesses today
this has led to an increase in the
demand for digital marketing
professionals because of this many
people are interested in learning about
digital marketing it is becoming one of
the essential skills that you can have
if you learn how to use it you can make
a difference in your marketing
capabilities hey everyone I'm Tushar Bal
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this video we will discuss the top 10
reasons to learn digital marketing but
before we begin if you enjoy watching
Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay
tuned so without any further delay let's
get
started easy to start a career a career
in digital marketing is an easy one to
start the field is growing rapidly and
there is a demand for professionals who
can care the digital assets of a company
with this in mind it is easy to find a
position even with no specific degree it
is also easy to find further training in
digital marketing as a lot of free and
paid resources are
available a technical and creative field
both Technical and creative skills are
necessary for digital marketing it has a
lot of subfield hence it requires a
unique skill set and knowledge of the
latest technology for example a social
media marketing professional should know
how to run a successful campaign digital
marketing is a perfect career option for
those who are interested in both the
creative and Technical
Fields highly paid digital marketing is
one of the most popular and trending
Industries there is a v demand for
digital marketing professionals as a
result digital marketing roles are also
very well play your expertise could help
you gain better roles within your
organization which could improve your
salary according to Goldman sex report
digital marketing scope in the Indian
internet industry alone is expected to
reach us 160 billion by 2025 which shows
the extent of digital marketing in India
and the job demand for digital marketing
according to Glass do a digital
marketing manager earns around 7 lakh in
India and HEI can earn roughly
$123,000 in the
US become an entrepreneur as a digital
marketer you will be familiar with wide
range of online tools and platforms you
can start a blog or website where you
can list your products or if you have
expertise in some field you can also
create your own digital products and
sell them online also you can start your
own freelancing business where you can
offer various services to the clients
all aspiring entrepreneurs need to
embrace digital marketing and even the
old ones need to adapt in order to
grow career growth there are a lot of
digital marketing professionals around
but very few are skilled the demand for
digital marketing skills will increase
in the near future due to digital
economy's rapid growth many individuals
are starting their online businesses and
almost every new company starts with an
online presence hence it's a perfect
chance for individuals who are looking
to make a career in digital
marketing the next reason is
versatility digital marketing offers a
variety of career options and a lifetime
learning since there are so many aspects
to it for example suppose you worked in
content marketing for 2 years years and
now you want to work in SEO in that case
there is relatively little training you
need so it won't be that difficult to
switch over if you want to enter into
some other domain your digital marketing
experience will always be valuable
therefore it is said that digital
marketers can easily change
jobs the next major reason is more
number of jobs several new jobs were
created in the digital marketing field
after covid as most businesses came
online you will find many digital
marketing job opportunities on lingen
every single day Grand View research
reports that the global digital
marketing software Market size was USD
56 billion in 2021 and is expected to
grow at a compound annual growth rate
cagr of
19.1% from 2022 to
2030 the field of digital marketing is
vast however digital marketing is also
used in other areas such as blockchain
blockchain provides trust worthy metrics
for monitoring marketing campaigns in
real time it's also a good chance for
digital marketers to discover other
fields like blockchain time and cost
effective in the long term digital
marketing will save you a lot of time
effort and money traditional marketing
is expensive and the cost keep Rising
there are cost of printing ads
television ads radio ads and billboards
digital marketing will give you more
profits than traditional marketing if
you know how to use it effectively
furthermore digital marketing requires
less efforts for example you can reach
Global audience using your laptop
sitting at home while traditional
marketing involves a lot of
efforts the next important reason is
Recession Proof job lending your dream
job is a rarity for many in this job
market with the economy still struggling
businesses are cutting jobs left and
right so how you can make yourself
lession proof If you are creative and
willing to learn it can happen there are
many ways to make yourself more
desirable to businesses and get job
offers however one way is to become an
expert in digital marketing digital
marketing is the internet-based
marketing of product and services using
digital Technologies mainly on the
internet marketing is an integral part
of any business with the ever growing
number of Internet users it is expected
that more companies will use digital
marketing extensively in the
future so now let's discuss the last and
interesting reason specialization the
field of digital marketing has a wide
range of
specializations SEO content marketing
influencer marketing sem and many other
fall under digital marketing an
individual has a lot to explore and once
you explode you can pick a digital
marketing specialization according to
your interest additionally there is a
wide variety of skills that you need to
master under each of these categories
digital marketing has become an absolute
game changer for businesses all around
the globe turning it into a skill that
every everyone wants to get their hands
on it is like having a superpower that
allows you to reach and engage with
customers on a whole new level if you
have ever dreamed of becoming a digital
marketing expert then you are in for a
treat we will be your digital marketing
Mentor guiding you through each step
with Clarity and enthusiasm from
mastering the fundamental marketing
principles to unlocking the secrets of
advanced strategies we have got you
covered learning marketing fundamentals
so learning marketing fundamentals is
like building the solid groundwork for
your digital marketing Empire it's all
about understanding the inner workings
of consumer Behavior unraveling the
mysteries of market research and
uncovering the secrets of effective
marketing strategies think of it as the
key that unlocks the door to success in
the digital realm to get started immerse
yourself in the world of marketing
through online courses insightful books
and Industry blogs these Treasure troves
of knowledge will equip you with
essential tools and insights needed to
navigate the everchanging landscape of
digital marketing once you have gained
the Basic Marketing knowledge then the
next thing you can do is create a web
page so imagine having your very own
Digital Playground a place where you can
Unleash Your creativity and showcase
your digital marketing skills to the
world that's exactly what creating a web
page is all about it is like having a
blank canvas where you can paint your
unique Brand Story and Captivate your
audience audence thanks to userfriendly
platforms like WordPress and vix
building a professional looking web page
has never been easier you don't need to
be a coding visard or a design Guru to
get started so once you have created a
web page you can start with learning
local SEO local Su is vital for
businesses targeting a specific
geographic area optimizing websites for
local search results is key techniques
like optimizing Google my business
listings and obtaining online reviews
and targeting locations specific
keywords are crucial by creating
accurate and comprehensive profiles on
Google my business businesses increase
their visibility positive reviews build
trust and credibility while location
specific keywords help businesses appear
in relevant local searches embracing
local SEO techniques and showes
businesses connect with the potential
customers in their area gaining a
Competitive Edge and driving group so
learning local SEO is also important the
next step is SEO on page off page to
become a digital marketing expert you
must Master both on page and off-page SE
techniques on page SE involves
optimizing elements within your website
such as metat Texs headings and content
off-page SEO on the other hand focuses
on building high quality backlinks and
increase website Authority through
strategies like guest blogging social
media promotion and influencer Outreach
by understanding and implementing these
techniques effectively you can boost
your website's visibility and rankings
in search engine results ultimately
driving more organic traffic and
achieving digital marketing success now
the next step is one of the most
important step that is PPC advertising
So Paid media marketing like PPC
advertising is a GameChanger for driving
targeted traffic to websites pick a
platform like Google ads or Facebook ads
and become a master in it learn the art
of crafting compelling ad campaigns
conducting uh keyword research and
optimizing ad performance by focusing on
one paid media platform you will gain
the expertise needed to maximize your
marketing efforts and Achieve
outstanding results so dive in and
master your chosen platform and watch
your website traffic s after this you
can go ahead and learn the analytical
tools so analyzing data is like having a
superpower in the world of digital
marketing it's like a secret source that
helps you understand what's working and
what's not working to become a digital
Market expert you need to get cozy with
analytical tools like Google analytics
these tools are like Treasure Chest
filled with valuable insights about your
website traffic user behavior and
campaign performance so start by
learning how to set up tracking codes
which act as a digital breadcrumbs
guiding you through the vast online
landscape then dive into creating custom
reports that give you a personalized
view of your data but don't stop there
the real magic happens when you
interpret the data and use it to make
informed marketing decisions so learning
analytical tools is also important if we
want to become a digital marketing
expert so now next is learning marketing
stack so learning about the marketing
stack is like unlocking a treasure Trove
of tools and software that can
supercharge your digital marketing
efforts picture it as a collection of
powerful weapons in Your Arsenal youve
got an email marketing platform like
MailChimp which help you craft
captivating campaigns that land right in
your audien's inbox
then there are social media management
tools and let's not forget about
marketing automation software like
hubsoft which takes care of repetitive
tasks by ging hands-on experience with
these tools you will become master of
efficiency streamlining your marketing
efforts and unleashing your full
potential after learning all of these
skills and tools you can go ahead and
learn Advanced topics first programmatic
advertising delve into programmatic
advertising which uses AI and automation
to purchase and optimize digital ads in
real time understand how it works and
its application in various marketing
campaigns next is affiliate marketing
learn the inos of affiliate marketing
where you promote other Company products
or services and earn a commission
discover how to find and manage
affiliate Partnerships
effectively all right now the third one
on the list is app marketing so in the
age of mobile apps knowing how to Market
them is crucial explore strategies for
App Store optimization inapp advertising
and user acquisition techniques so these
three are the advanced topics that you
can Master if you want to become a
digital marketing expert all right so
becoming a digital marketing expert
requires continuous learning practical
experience and a passion for staying
updated with industry Trends by
following this step-by-step guide you
can develop a strong foundation in
marketing Master essential digital
marketing techniques and gain experience
in advanced topics so have you ever
thought about starting your own digital
marketing agency but don't have a big
budget well you are in the right place
today we are going to talk about how you
can set up a digital marketing agency
with $0 in 20124 that's right you don't
need a big investment to get started
we'll explore some creative and
practical ways to Kickstart your agency
without breaking the bank so if you are
ready to learn how to turn your passion
for digital marketing into thriving
business keep watching so in this video
we will cover what is the role of
digital marketing agency services
offered by digital marketing agencies
after that we will discuss how to set up
a digital marketing agency with $0 so
without further Ado let's start with the
first topic which is what is the role of
digital marketing agency so a digital
marketing agency is like a friendly
guide for businesses navigating the
online world picture them as your trusty
companions in promoting your products or
services on the internet their job is to
make your business Shine by creating
catchy ads making sure your website pops
up when people search for things and
keeping the social media Vibes Lively
they also analyze data to see what's
working and what's not so they can make
changes to improve the results digital
marketing agencies help business connect
with customers in the digital world
where many people spend a lot of their
time they can also help with things like
search engine optimization and email
marketing and creating content like
videos or blog post overall the agency's
job is to help businesses get notice and
grow their customer base using the
internet all right so this was about
what is the role of digital marketing
agency now let's understand the services
offered by digital marketing agencies so
a digital marketing agency provide a
range of essential services to boost
your online presence and connect with
customers effectively so let's start
with the first one which is web design
or webs website design so digital
marketing agencies can help create a
good-look and easy to use website for
your business now at number two we have
search engine optimization so they can
make sure your website shows up higher
in Google search results so more people
can find it at number three we have web
development so this means they can build
new features for your website or make it
work better so next service is email
marketing so these agencies help you
send out emails to your customers to let
them know about your products and
special offers the next agency would be
social media marketing so these agencies
can manage your business social media
accounts and create post to get more
people interested in what you are
selling the next is content marketing
this means they can help you create
articles videos or other content to
share online and attract more customers
then at number seven we have payperclick
management so they can help you set up
ads online so that you only pay when
someone clicks on them which can help
bring more people to your website these
are the main services that digital
marketing agencies offered to help
businesses promote themselves online and
reach more customers all right so these
were the services that were offered and
now let's move on to the interesting
part of this video which is how to set
up a digital marketing agency with $0 so
the first step here would be start with
market research so market research is
crucial first step for any business
including a digital marketing agency by
understanding your target audience their
needs and the demand for your services
you can tailor your offerings to meet
those needs effectively analyzing your
competitors helps you identify what
makes your agency unique and where you
can stand out in the market to analyze
your existing customer base to
understand their demographics
preferences and needs start with looking
for industry Trends to identify popular
services and emerging demands in the
market the next you you can do is
conduct surveys to gather direct
feedback from potential customers about
their pain points and preferences after
that you can develop bias Persona which
are fictional representation of Ideal
customers to better understand and cater
to the needs of your target audience
next you can do is undertake
comprehensive market research to
comprehend your target audience their
pain points and the demand for your
chosen Services next is analyze
competitors to identify Market gaps and
opportunities that can set your agency
apart in the digital marketing landscape
all right so these were the things that
you can do in market research so this
was about doing the market research Next
Step would be address legal requirements
yes making sure your digital marketing
agency follows the rules is super
important when getting started this
means officially setting up your
business by registering it and picking a
good name you have got to do things by
the book to make sure your agency stays
on the right side of the law it's smart
to get advice from legal experts to make
sure you're following all the local
rules and also to create the contracts
with your clients taking care of these
legal things from the beginning helps
build a strong foundation for your
agency makes clients trust you and
avoids problems down the road all right
so once you're done with this then you
can go forward and building a social
media presence so yeah building a social
media presence on platforms like
Facebook and Instagram is really
important for businesses these platforms
have lots of people using them every day
so it's good way to reach potential
customers by postponing interesting and
engaging content business can get people
interested in what they have to offer
they can also use paid advertising on
these platforms to reach even more
people this can help generate leads
which means finding the potential
customers who are interested in what the
business is selling by being active on
Facebook and Instagram a business can
build community of people who like and
follow them which can lead to more sales
and stronger connection with customers
so paying attention to these platforms
and building a strong presence there can
really help the business to grow all
right so once you have started building
a social media presence then you can
start with finding a niche when you're
starting in digital marketing it's good
idea to find a specific area that you're
really good at this would be things like
social media marketing making websites
or helping business to show up in higher
Google searches by focusing on one of
these things you can become an expert in
that area and stand out from other
digital marketers for example if you're
really good at making websites you can
focus on that and become known for it
when businesses need a new website
they'll come to you because they know
you are the best at it the same goes for
the other areas like social media
marketing or helping businesses with
their Google ads all right right so this
was about finding a niche now next you
can do is create a website all right so
first you can start by creating a
website for your business this is like
having an online store or office where
people can come and learn about what you
do it's a bit of having a shop on the
internet next you can create a logo of
your business a logo is like a special
picture that represents your business
you can use a free tool called canva to
make a logo that looks nice and shows
what your business is about after that
you can use a free website builder
called vix to actually make your website
vix is like a tool that helps you put
together all the parts of your website
like pictures text and buttons without
needing to know how to code by doing
these things you can have a nice looking
website with a logo that represents your
business and you can do it all for free
this can help your business look more
professional and make it easier for
people to find you online so once you
are done with creating the website side
then you can attract leads with Organic
advertising so attracting leads with
Organic advertising means promoting your
business without paying for ads instead
you use things like social media making
helpful content and improving your
website so that it shows up higher in
the Google searches for example on
social media you can post interesting
things about business that people will
want to share with their friends with
content marketing you can create useful
articles or videos that people will find
they search for things related to your
business
and with SEO you can make sure your
website is set up in a way that makes it
more likely to show up when people
search for things you offer by using
these methods you can attract people to
your business without having to spend
money on ads all right so this is how
you can attract leads with Organic
advertising now next step would be
building networks so building networks
means going to events seminars and
workshops where you can meet people who
who might want to use your service or
who work in the same industry as you by
doing this you can make friends with
other businesses and learn about the
newest trends in digital marketing this
can help you find new clients and also
get tips from others in the same line of
work so building network is a good way
to make connections and stay up to dat
with what's happening in the digital
marketing world all right so next step
is content marketing so content
marketing is like telling a good story
to people who might be interested in
what you are selling so instead of just
saying buy this you create helpful or
interesting things like articles videos
or pictures that help people want to see
this can make people trust you more and
see you as an expert in what you do it's
like building a strong wall around your
business to protect it and make it all
stand out when you do content marketing
you're not just trying to sell something
right away you're trying to make people
interested in what you do by giving them
something valuable this can bring more
people to your business without you
having to chase after them it's like
making a magnet that pulls customers to
you instead of having to push hard to
get their attention so content marketing
is a smart way to show people that you
know your stuff and to bring more
customers to your business without being
too pushy all right now the next step is
gather feedback so Gathering feedback is
an important part of running a business
it means collecting comments reviews
from your customers to understand what
they like like and what could be
improved good firms Yelp and Google my
business are all places where customers
can leave feedback about their
experience with the business good firms
is a platform where business can be
reviewed and red by their customers
helping other people decide if they want
to use that business too Yelp is a
website where people can find a review
find and review local businesses like
restaurants or shops Google my business
is a tool that lets business manage
their online presence including customer
reviews by gathering feedback on these
platforms business can learn what they
are doing and where they can make
changes to better serve their customers
it's a way for business to listen to
their customers and improve their
products or Services based on what
people are saying these are the steps to
make a digital marketing agency are you
ready to take your digital marketing
career to the next level crafting a
compelling digital marketing resume is
your ticket to Landing that dream job in
the dynamic world of online marketing
your resume is your digital billboard
showcasing your skills experience and
achievements to potential employeers in
a world where attention is scarce and
competition is fierce your resume needs
to stand out like a viral social media
post let's dive into the art of creating
digital marketing resume that not only
captures attention but also compels
employers to hit the apply button so now
let's have a look at what we are
covering in this video
so we'll start with looking at examples
of resume professional experience
education skills certifications then we
will cover some useful tips to create an
awesome resume and at last we will
understand how to make a digital
marketing resume for freshers and
experienced but before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and press the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn so let's start
with the first step which is looking for
examples of resume so before you start
making your digital marketing resume
it's good idea to look at some examples
of a well-crafted ones in the same field
this can help you understand how to
format your resume what kind of
languages to use and what content is
most effective for digital marketing
jobs keep an eye out for resumes that
have a strong personal brand clear
communication and relevant work by
deciding out of these examples you'll
get better idea what works well and be
better prepared to create a result
resume that catches the attention of
potential Employers in the competitive
world of digital marketing reviewing
examples of digital marketing resume can
provide valuable insights into the
industry's best practices look for
resumés that effectively showcase the
candidates unique value proposition such
as their expertise in SEO social media
management content creation or data
analysis all right once you're done with
this now the next step would be
professional experience so when
describing your work history spot like
your achievements and influence you had
in your past positions make your impact
clear by using action words and
measurable outcomes to Showcase your
contributions rather than just outlining
job responsibilities emphasize
accomplishments like boosting website
traffic enhancing conversion rates or
successfully executing marketing
campaigns this approach provides a
dynamic view of your capabilities and
highlights the tangible results of your
efforts by focusing on these
achievements you not only pay paint a
vivid picture of your skills but also
demonstrates your ability to drive
positive outcomes in the professional
realm so if you are interested in
advancing your career consider puru
University post-graduate program in
digital marketing this comprehensive
program offers certification as digital
marketer through live Interactive
Learning dive deep into fundamental and
advanced digital marketing strategies
utilizing Hardware business school
publishing cases and student simulations
and Hands-On participation in 20 plus
project projects access the full
spectrum of digital marketing tools with
chat gbt and AI tools complemented by 35
Plus dedicated resources all right so
this was about the professional
experience now if we talk about the next
step which is education so education in
the education section of your resume
showcase your academic qualifications
relevant coursework and any honors or
Awards you have received if your degrees
aligns with the field like marketing or
communication
emphasize it this highlights your
foundational knowledge don't forget to
mention any specific courses or
workshops you have completed especially
if they include valuable certifications
in digital marketing this signals to
employers that you actively pursued
additional skills and knowledge in the
ever evolving digital landscape remember
this section is not just about degrees
it's about snapshot of your educational
journey and commitment to staying
current in your field so make it sh with
their achievements and relevant
educational experiences all right so
this was about education now coming to
the next step which is skills so skills
in the skills section of your digital
marketing resume highlight your
expertise in essential tools and
platforms this includes a range of
skills such as Google analytics where
you demonstrate your ability to analyze
website data SEO proficiency showcases
your knowledge of optimizing content for
search engines ensuring maximum
visibility social media management
skills indicate your capability to
strategize and execute impactful
campaigns across platforms then email
marketing expertise email marketing
expertise emphasizes your ability to
create and manage effective email
campaigns additionally your aptitude for
Content creation highlights your
creative and communication skills it's
crucial to tailor these skills to match
the specific requirements of the job
you're applying for showcasing your
versatility and alignment with the
employees needs by doing so you present
a well-rounded skill set that enhances
your appeal as a digital marketing
professional so this was about the
skills of a digital marketing
professional that you can include in
your resume after that there are
certifications so certifications if you
have learned certifications in digital
marketing like Google ads hubsoft
inbound marketing or Facebook blueprint
make sure to Showcase them in the
special section of your resume
certifications such as these highlight
your dedication to professional growth
and can make you stand out among other
applicants including these qualification
not only proves your expertise in
specific areas of digital marketing but
also signals to employers that you stay
updated with industry standards this can
be crucial factor in setting you apart
and demonstrating your commitment to
ongoing learning in a competitive job
market certification act as a tangible
proof of your skills and can
significantly enhance your chances of
securing that dream digital marketing
position all right so this was about the
certification section of your resume now
coming to the interesting part of this
video which is useful tips to create an
awesome resume so now we will be heading
to the useful tips so crafting a
standout digital marketing resume is
like creating your professional Story
start by tailoring it to the job you
want highlight skills like email
marketing social media marketing content
marketing and Su expertise that match
the roles requirements imagine your
resume as a visually appealing and well
organized document using a clean and
modern format to Showcase your
creativity to make your impact even
stronger don't forget to add some
numbers quantify your achievements with
Statistics it's like adding a splash of
color to your story if you increase
social media engagement or boosted
website traffic let the numbers do that
talking now here's the Finishing Touch
proof reading just like when you are
sharing a post on social media check
whether your resume for any typos or
errors attention to detail is crucial in
the digital marketing world so there you
have it tailor your story highlight your
digital marketing skills and add some
numbers to impact and polish it off with
a metalicious proof read this way your
resume will stand out in digital
landscape ready to catch the eye of your
future employer so this was about useful
tips to create an awesome resume now
coming to the next very interesting part
which is how to make a digital marketing
resume for freshers and experience all
right so let's move on to that so when
creating a resume whether you're a
fresher or an experienced professional
it's important to pay attention to the
layout and content a well-crafted resume
can significantly impact your job
prospects for freshers a good resume can
help you stand out despite limited work
experience while for experience
professional it can showcase your skills
and accomplishments effectively when
creating your resume it's important to
include action items and action verbs to
Showcase your skills and accomplishments
effectively for example increase organic
views by 20% reduce bounce rate improve
ranking Etc instead of saying
responsible for managing a team you
could use Le a team which sounds more
active and engaging this applies for
both freshers and experienced
professionals by incorporating action
items and action verbs as well as
highlighting questionable achievements
you can make your resume more Dynamic
and impactful this approach can help you
stand out to potential employers and
increase your chances of securing the
job you desire the layout of your resume
is crucial it should be clean organized
and easy to read use Clear headings and
bullet points to make it visually
appealing for freshers the layout should
emphasize education and any relevant
internships or projects for experienced
professionals the layout should
highlight work experience and key
achievements all right now for both
freshers and experienced professionals
it's important to include your contact
information educational background and
any relevant certification or training
fresher should also include sections on
skills and projects while experienced
professional should focus on vog
experience and accomplishments when it
comes to what to avoid steer a clear
understanding of including irrelevant
personal information such as your
hobbies or martial status additionally
avoid using generic one size fits all
resume for every job application tailor
your resume to specific job you're
applying for yes this is very important
after that the order in which you
present information is also important
for freshers it's best to start with
your education followed by any
internships or projects and then skills
now for experienced professional begin
with your work experience followed by
the key achievements and then your
education and skills so these all things
you can do in your resume for an
experienced professionals so crafting
your digital marketing resume is not
just about listing experiences it's
about telling a compelling story of your
skills and achievements tailor your
resume to the specific job you desire
showcasing your expertise in email
marketing social media marketing content
marketing and SE a clean and modern
formats adds a touch of professionalisms
making your resume visually appealing
don't forget to sprinkle in some numbers
quantify your achievements to make a
lasting impact lastly proof read your
resume with with metalicious attention
to detail a Flawless document not only
reflects your commitment but also
ensures you make a memorable first
impression in the competitive digital
marketing landscape you must have heard
the term digital marketing online
marketing and have always been curious
about how individuals and businesses use
it to increase brand awareness the
growth of digital marketing is fast and
it will continue to grow in the coming
years don't worry if you have no idea
what digital marketing is this video
will explain everything you need to
know hey everyone I am Tushar Bal
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
in this video we will understand digital
marketing from scratch but before we
begin if you enjoy watching Tech related
content consider subscribing to our
YouTube channel and hitting that Bell
icon to stay
tuned so without any further delay let's
get started with the agenda for today's
session first we will look at what
digital marketing is next we will
understand the different component of
digital marketing moving forward we will
understand the difference between
traditional and digital marketing and
why it is preferable to go digital after
that we will dive into the challenges
for digital marketers in
2022 next we will look at the top skills
required to become a digital marketer
after that we will discuss the average
salary of a digital marketing manager
and finally we will wind up the session
by discussing the future of digital
marketing hopefully now you have a
better idea of what we have in store for
you now let's see what digital marketing
is in simple words digital marketing is
the promotion of a product or a brand
through one or more forms of electronic
media such as Internet mobile phones
Google search engine marketing Etc it's
a way to reach client on time and retain
them with interactive marketing using
digital Technologies also it is the most
accessible easy to use and contemporary
me method of promotion which is also
known as online
marketing so now we have a clear
understanding of what digital marketing
is we also need to acknowledge that it
has several components and understanding
each is essential so let's jump into the
different components of digital
marketing seo seo stands for search
engine optimization SEO is the act of
taking steps to help a website or a
piece of content get higher ranking on
Google moreover SE includes organic
rankings which means you do not have to
pay to appear
there up next we have PPC PPC stands for
paperclick it includes paid
advertisements and promoted search
engine results it does the same thing as
se but the key difference is that it's
in organic so you have to pay to be in
that space the next component is social
media marketing social media marketing
is a form of internet marketing that
uses social media apps as a marketing
tool tool Brands can communicate with
their audience using social media
platforms whether they are building a
brand increasing sales driving traffic
to a website or building followers to
share and engage with the content next
we have content marketing content
marketing aims to increase brand
awareness by telling stories and sharing
information ultimately the goal is to
encourage readers to become customers by
signing up for an email list asking for
more information or making a purchase
email marketing involves sending
promotional messages to many people at
once in most cases it's used to generate
lead for sales but it can also include
advertising the next component that we
will be discussing is affiliate
marketing affiliate marketing is a
component of marketing in which one
person promotes another company's or
person's product a person who promotes a
product or service is called an
affiliate and the affiliate also gets a
certain amount of commission
up next we have mobile marketing with
this type of digital marketing you will
reach your target audience on the
smartphones mobile marketing reaches
people through text messages social
media websites emails and mobile
applications now we are on to our last
component which is influencer marketing
influencer marketing involves promoting
your product through mentions and
endorsement from influencers individuals
who have a dedicated following on social
media are seen as industry experts
now let's have a look at the business
models in digital marketing B2B which
means business to business B2B refers to
business transaction between two
companies in the world of B2B digital
marketing is a crucial element through a
digital markeet campaign we can reach
another company's decision maker one of
the best example is LinkedIn advertising
which many B2B company use to Target
their potential
customers next we have B b2c which is
business to Consumer b2c refers to
business transactions between business
to Consumer b2c digital marketing allows
you to reach out directly to your
potential customers using digital
channels as we know millions of people
are using internet and are active on
digital channels for example using
Facebook ads and Google ads you can
directly Target consumers by their age
group interest location
Etc and the final one is C2C which is
consumer to Consumer C2C refers to a
business transaction between consumers
nowadays consumers are using social
media platforms and intermediaries to
Market their products and services as a
result they can reach a wider audience
for example OLX serves as an
intermediary by allowing individuals to
list their products and services for
sale and other individual can purchase
them now let's look into digital
marketing versus traditional marketing
several new and old businesses are
harnessing digital marketing and
rethinking their marketing funnels in
the age of digital marketing a digital
revolution has reshaped how we live
interact and conduct businesses
traditional marketing seems to be losing
its relevance in today's era of
Technology knowing which marketing
method will work best for your business
is essential traditional marketing
methods such as printing material radio
and television are quickly becoming
outdated they are too expensive
ineffective and time consuming however
digital marketing is the future of
advertising now let's talk about a few
reasons why digital marketing is a
better choice than traditional marketing
firstly there is a global reach a
website that allows you to find a new
market and trade globally for only a
small investment lower cost a properly
plant and well targeted digital
marketing campaign can reach the right
customers at a much lower cost than
traditional marketing method meths the
next benefit is analytics several tools
are available to analyze and report on
marketing data collected through digital
channels and the data is precious to any
business now we are on to our last
benefit which is retargeting suppose we
have a website that sells shoes and 100
people visit our website but only two
purchase the item with the help of
digital marketing we can still Target
those 98 visitors and display our ads to
them
people used to rely on traditional
marketing before digital marketing
traditional marketing is nothing new as
we have all seen and heard of it at some
point it is an effective way to reach a
particular audience via offline methods
such as magines newspaper Billboards Etc
traditional marketing has its challenges
such as time consuming a limited number
of customers served in one go and a high
cost similarly digital marketing has its
own challenges now now let's look into
the challenges in digital marketing
learning about your customers the
internet has lot of users with lot of
different interest which makes
identifying the right sort of audience
for your product and service challenging
at times the next challenge is the
generation of qualified leads in a
competitive market the digital
revolution has resulted in businesses
using digital marketing but sometimes it
becomes challenging to compete against
your competitors next is compliance with
privacy and data sharing
regulations most people have their own
website which can attract visitors from
anywhere in the world ensure that you
are complant with any laws that apply to
your target audience up next we have
developing an omni Channel marketing
strategy Multi-Device and multiplatform
use are increasing among customers the
days of relying solely on a single
strategy like email or Facebook are over
your strategy must be based on multiple
platforms staying up to date with
Google's algorithm
the digital Empire of Google continues
to grow to compete you need to stay up
to date with the latest features rules
and algorithms released by the giant
search
engine now we are on to our last
challenge developing a mobile first
strategy the number of people browsing
and shopping from smartphones and tablet
has increased if somebody wants to
capture a share of ever spending mobile
market they must ensure that their
website is mobile friendly
now that we have a better sense of
challenges faced in digital marketing
it's essential to be equipped with the
right skills to handle them now let's
look at what top skills a digital
marketer needs it is crucial for anyone
planning a career in digital marketing
to understand what are the top skills
required it takes a wide range of soft
and hard skills for digital marketers to
succeed as a digital marketer you will
need a different set of skills depending
on where where you work and what you do
data analysis data analytics uses
functional procedures and modern
software programs to gather and analyze
information from various online
interaction with your target market
content creation creating content that
appeals to a Brands target audience is
crucial for digital marketing SE and sem
it is important to utilize relevant and
specific keywords as Google's algorithm
constantly updates both SEO and SE M
help you reach your target audience and
narrow down your customer
base basic designing skill digital
marketers should be familiar with
software such as Adobe Creative suit
Photoshop after effect illustrator in
design Etc and canva as these would
enhance their ability to create visual
content social media businesses use
social media platforms to Target their
content to specific audience and get
accurate data for this reason a digital
marketers needs to be very familiar with
social media platforms communication
skill an influential digital marketer
should look at things from a different
perspective convey information in an
easy to understand Manner and figure out
what audience find entertaining and
valuable let's look at an example to
understand digital marketing better Raj
owns a bakery shop in Bangalore but he
does not know how to Market it he called
his best friend Rahul and he suggested
trying out digital marketing here are
few examples Raj can try create a
business plan for Bakery develop a
business website with SEO and include
online ordering add a blog post for
Effective content
marketing use social media effectively
get his Google M business listing and
optimize it for SE Market his shops
through Facebook and Google
ads hopefully now you you have a better
understanding of the top skills which is
required to become a digital marketer if
you are interested in learning these
skills and are looking for a resource to
learn digital marketing from scratch
then simply learn has postgraduate
program in digital marketing it is the
world's number one digital marketing
course by marketing land and search
engine Journal program duration is 6
months 5 to 10 hours per week is
required for the program and the best
part is you will get job assistance from
our end and when it comes to to content
then it is created by the industry
experts here are the key features of our
program you will get pgp in digital
marketing certificate and py University
Aly membership P University faculty
Master Class free Facebook blueprint
voucher what $99 Harvard Business case
study of Yahoo eor Trip Advisor Etc
industry projects and cour and projects
you can get noticed by top hiring
companies with simply larns job
assist now we have reached the most
exciting and essential part of the video
average salary of a digital marketing
manager in the digital marketing
industry there is a huge demand for
digital marketing managers and their
salaries reflect that several factors
determine the income a person can expect
including experience the size of your
company your location and your industry
digital advertising has proven to be
more convenient and effective than
traditional advertising since most of
your audience is online as a result
digital marketing is growing and
becoming more popular a digital
marketing manager plays a significant
role in drawing Revenue into the
business and due to their highly
result-driven nature their salaries are
high a digital marketing manager earns
approximately 6 lakh 72,000 per year in
India and in the US he or she can earn
roughly
$75,000 per
[Music]
year lastly let's discuss the future of
digital markeet marketing Grand View
research reports that the global digital
marketing software Market size was USD
56.52% from 2022 to
2030 you have looked into the new
digital marketing trends at some point
if you are aspiring or experienc digital
marketer the best way to succeed in
digital marketing is to keep up with
current trends in the field
now we will look at the two trending
technologies that use digital marketing
and are on the rise blockchain the data
from digital advertising campaign can
sometimes be inaccurate so Improvement
can be difficult monitoring marketing
campaigns in real time is achievable
with blockchain for obtaining
trustworthy metrics top brands such as
unil are applying blockchain for
improving digital advertising efficiency
successfully augmented and virtual
reality stock Works Nivea and Volkswagen
all launch successfully AR and VR
campaigns to better connect their brands
and products to their customer it is
undeniable that these two technologies
are booming and expected to grow
massively in the next few years the use
of digital marketing in these
Technologies makes us aware the bright
future of digital marketing so when we
want to go and promote our product or
service using a campaign we have
different options so there are different
types of digital marketing channels that
we can choose from and let's just go
through that list of digital marketing
channels and the first one is what I
consider the king of them all and that's
SEO so SEO stands for search engine
optimization there's search engine
marketing there's email marketing
affiliate marketing social content
mobile and then we can get into subsets
of each of these digital marketing
channels but really we'll start with SEO
because that's the king and to me that's
basically increasing the quality and
quantity of relevant organic traffic on
the search engines including Google so
depending on where you're located in the
US market Google tends or has a large
market share so you want your pages on
your website to be found and clicked on
organically and so that means if
somebody types in a keyword you want
that relevant page to show up first on
Google so somebody can click on that
link
okay and we know that millions of people
specifically in the US but worldwide you
search on a daily basis so if you're
ranking for those relevant key wordss
you can imagine how much traffic you can
get okay so that's SEO okay and here's
an example so you type in online
shopping well you can see the first
listing here is a paid search ad we're
going to get to that in a minute the
second organically is Amazon okay so
online shopping you think maybe Walmart
you think maybe Alibaba or you're
thinking probably Amazon okay so no
surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or pay per click or cost per
click or PPC or CPC or sponsored search
or Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different names to onymous with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw the previous example if you want
to be found for keyword you don't have
to worry about organic if you're willing
to pay for it you just bid on that
keyword and voila you have the
opportunity to appear number one in the
search results at the top of the page
for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay Google if
it's Google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well my
us.com is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above Amazon's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happen to clicked on that listing then
my us.com is going to pay Google
something depending on what the cost per
click is and so that could be anywhere
from one penny to $100 it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location depends on the time of
day depends on quality score there a lot
of factors involved and regarding what
you pay however
the benefit of sem is visibility and
getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem such a popular choice for a lot
of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis just an effective way to capture
leads and convert them to customers
because with email you can personalize
your emails and you can send your emails
to a segmented audience okay so if you
have emails from females who are 35
years of age to 44 that live in say this
southern part of the United States you
can segment that send them an email and
cater that email directly to that
audience and of course you can put some
nice call to action in there you can
design it really snazzy and you could
track it just like you can any other
digital marketing channel so email is a
very effective way to really reach a
target audience because everybody for
the most part has a functioning email
account so basically here's an example
of an email that could go out if you're
selling a product and the product's
promotion is about to end well you know
get that email out to your target
audience let them know hey you have
until tonight to purch product and if
you purchase it you're going to get 30%
off and you can put the coupon code
right in there with a nice call to
action and you can measure how many
people click on that email go to that
web page and purchase the product using
that coupon code so that's an example of
email marketing okay we have affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a Salesforce of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting Merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
Commission Junction or cj.com as an
example to introduce you the the person
selling the product the merchant with
the affiliate so that affiliate could
likely be a merchant him or himself and
they can basically be a good partner of
yours by publishing your product or
service on their website so that they
can sell in order to get commissions so
it's all based on a commission so you
basically are going to use a third-
party affiliate like CJ get all these
Affiliates to work for you they're going
to promote your product or service if
they do sell your product or service
you're going to pay them a commission
that's more or less how it works with
affiliate marketing and you know with
affiliate marketing to me it's a good
way to you know really promote your
product or service and you can pick and
choose the affiliates or the Publishers
of whom you want to work with so here's
an example of affiliate marketing at
work okay you basically see a banner
basically you could see earn up to 12%
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that purchased for example or
joined you could pay out that commission
okay let's turn our attention to social
media marketing so social media
marketing you know I wouldn't say it's
fairly new I mean if I think about it
we're in
2019 and I remember talking about
Facebook back in 2006 so you're talking
about 13 14 15 years of social media
it's definitely evolved over the years
and but the concept Remains the Same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on Pinterest or
Instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on Twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social social
media platform uh that really drives the
type of content you're going to promote
but we know social media can be
effective because people use social
media I mean Facebook is one of the more
popular platforms and if you want to get
your product or service out there you
could certainly pay to have an ad on
Facebook or you could just post your
content organically okay that's the
beauty of social most of your Social
platforms like LinkedIn and Twitter and
Facebook and Pinterest and Instagram
they all have a paid form of advertising
that you can use to promote your product
or service or you can go the organic
route and you know post content
organically in hopes of driving traffic
back to your website so with social you
do have two options here but social is
interesting because there are a lot of
different social media platforms out
there really depends on your product or
service okay so an example of social
media Market marketing especially on
Facebook with Facebook you got mobile
and desktop and you obviously have the
opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you can post
an ad and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really effective
way of really Distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create content these days especially
in digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so if you're trying to Target an
audience on say Instagram then you know
who your audience is and you know what
the type of content you're going to post
on there so it could be in the form of a
video or infographic or just a graphic
and so that's the beauty of content
marketing really putting yourself out
there um and depending on the platform
putting yourself out there with various
types of content so for example we look
at YouTube you can see this video here
about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on YouTube this is a form of
content marketing so that's content
marketing and then let's talk about
mobile marketing so content marketing
again different types but if we go now
to mobile marketing you can kind of
segue from content to mobile because the
only difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps you the
company promoting your product or
service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you can do that
is via messaging you could do it via
email or you could be do it via an app
okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically SMS or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example of a
mobile marketing via app install and so
you can even compound that by running a
say Google ad as an example and running
your Google ad on say just mobile you
could do a bit adjustment just for
mobile and the goal could be app
installs okay so and you can even do a
mobile or app extension so there's lots
of ways to really promote your app or
your product or your service Via mobile
marketing so we're going to use a basic
example and let's just say you have a
Blog you're a food blogger you're
passionate about food and your Niche is
ice cream and let's just say you have a
lot of ice cream recipes you want to get
traffic to your blog you want people to
read your blog and and you're curious
why am I not ranking for my blog why
when people type in ice cream recipes
and say Google my blog posts don't
appear at the top of organic rankings
and there's a number of reasons why you
wouldn't be ranked for your blog post or
your ice cream recipes and the main
reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging along longer than
you and they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for Google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or it's actually a lot
more about you know keyword usage in
your content so what kind of keywords do
you want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords in into the content
another reason is poort link building
practices and really that means our
other blog posts or other websites
linking to you also are you linking to
other pages on your website and so it's
all about link building and with link
building it's internal linking so are we
linking from one blog post to another
and it's external linking are other
websites of high quality linking to us
and so that's what we talk about when we
talk about link building and then
another reason is web page load time so
you could be running your blog post on
say WordPress for example and your blog
post isn't loading fast enough well if
you look at it this way think about it
if you're Google would you really want
to rank a website or blog post in this
example number one on Google rankings if
that particular page loaded very slow no
you wouldn't because when somebody
clicked on that link in organic search
and went to your website they're going
to have a bad experience because the
page is going to load slow so Google
doesn't want their users to have a bad
experience you don't want your users to
have a bad experience and so that's why
web page low time is a critical factor
for ranking so we need to make sure that
our web pages load fast and then your
user experience is not good enough so
Google again based on my example about
the web page load time Google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page low time but also
you know Google doesn't want any spam
content Google doesn't want any popups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what Google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is De indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is De indexed is
Google needs to be able to index all the
pages on your website so if you have a
Blog with 100 recipes you want Google to
have access to all 100 recipes so we're
going to talk a little bit later about
how to get your pages ranked or indexed
on Google organic search so let's move
on to what is SE SEO so sticking with
our ice cleam Blog theme really SEO
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
Google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result is we want all our pages
to be ranked number one for particular
keywords so if you want to be ranked for
ice cream recipes well there's certain
things you need to do so that's
generally how it works we need to apply
search engine optimization to increase a
page for keyword we want to be found for
so let me give you an example so let's
just say there's 100 students that
participated in an essay competition and
so the competition in this particular
case is evaluated on the basis of is the
content relevant are they using suitable
titles for their essay do they have
structure when they're participating in
this essay or talking about the essay
and do they have a suitable synopsis and
is the content neat and readable these
seem all logical for an essay compet
comptition well guess what they seem
logical for SEO because that's exactly
how SEO works it's exactly all those
points I just made mentioned about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in SEO and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our Pages
Google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called a meta
description and then again the the
content needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
sight speed because site speed is
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when I say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
Google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two two number
three Etc on Google Search and then link
building remember I mentioned link
building a moment ago well link building
internally and externally also plays a
vital role and so we're going to talk
about that a little bit later in the
class when we talk about off-page SEO
how does Google rank website and
basically Google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they crawl back to their servers
and when they take it back to their
servers your your web pages they need to
you have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then Google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank th those pages that they've indexed
from number one to Infinity depending on
how many pages are relevant to that
search query so really it's about
crawling indexing and ranking so pring
is simply a process done by which Google
has Bots and what these Bots do is they
go to your web server and they're going
to crawl every page that they can find
and how did they find these Pages well
they basically follow links you might
have heard the term spidering but that's
what they call search engine spidering
so basically what Google's doing is
they're building a web so to speak all
the links that they're following and so
when they can follow all these links on
your website they're going to be able to
crawl them and when they crawl them
basically they're going to take that
content and store it on their servers so
it's available in their index So based
on this method Google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into Google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found then you're not going to show up
for Relevant keyword so we need to make
sure your sit's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to Google Search and if
I type in the keyword simply learn okay
I can see I have 1,10,000 results okay
and that's how many results are showing
up for simply learn okay now they may
not all be simply learned pages but
nonetheless simply learned is rank
number one here organically and there
are
1,10,000 Pages related to the keyword
simply learn now when it comes to
organic search uh we don't want to get
it confused with paid search so anytime
you see paid search you're going to see
something that says add next to it okay
so we could see that there are paid ads
here but when it comes to organic search
those are generally below paid ads and
so that's where Google counts the
1,10,000 results and so that's the whole
idea behind crawling and indexing
Google's able to crawl simply learns
website and based on all the pages that
they gather they're going to make those
pages available in organic search so if
you type in a keyword and your web page
is not available for indexing then
you're never going to show up for that
keyword so that's why it's important to
make sure your website is available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search Google search
the most relevant websites that are in
Google's index are going to appear in
the search results so in the example I
gave uh with simply learn we simply
learn is the brand name of the company
simply learn so there's a lot of
relevancy there so that's why you see
simply learn show up here organically
number one like we mentioned about what
is SEO and why SEO we talked about that
user experience so there's a lot of
factors that go into ranking relevancy
being one of them so in the simply learn
example simply learn is relevant to a
lot of the simply learn Pages because
that's who they are simply learn however
simply learn also needs to make sure
that you know for their Pages the page
low time is fast meaning these Pages
load very fast for the end user and
Google also takes into account other
factors like how long someone is staying
on a website or are they bouncing
meaning are they going to one page that
they land on and then leaving the
website okay and so the user experience
is very very important there are other
factors also like language and location
and so for example location if you do a
search say in India the results are
going to be a little bit different than
say the results in the United States why
because Google is indexing as many web
pages as they can find so if somebody's
doing a search in India their results
may be a little bit different than the
results show up in the US because Google
has different Bots and these Bots are
crawling different pages at different
times and so Google's index is updating
continuously
but it's not real time syncing so if you
do a search in India you may not see
exactly the same thing because both
search engines the Google in India and
the Google in the US are may not be
exactly synced up so an example would be
you know if you're looking for Cafe so
if you search a cafe in say San
Francisco you're going to see different
results now if you do I search for cafes
in Mumbai you're going to see different
results there's going to be local search
here at the top there may be some paid
search but again you may see different
results because one location but two
Google search engines in India and
United States google.com aren't exactly
synced up exactly at the same exact time
you do that search so location is
important language is important and
relevancy is important along with user
experience so all those are important
factors in how Google ranks websites
okay so we're going to talk about the
types of SEO now so if we want to rank
for a particular keyword on Google we're
going to have to apply search engine
optimization and so there's two
strategies to search engine optimization
on page SEO and off-page SEO so first
we're going to talk about onpage SEO so
onpage SEO is nothing more than
optimizing your own website and so when
we say optimizing your own website
there's certain elements on your website
and on your web pages that we need to
take into account and so some of those
elements are headers meta descriptions
title tags linking so all of those
elements are something we can control as
an end user who wants to rank our web
page and our website on Google and
before we do anything with our website
the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for SEO and
why do I say it's the most important
because you need to understand if you
choose a keyword that you want to rank
for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if rank number one on
Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a key word and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keyword you want and then once you
choose the keyword you want then you can
go and apply on page SEO you can change
the title tag the metad descriptions the
headers all those elements can be
changed but first you need to choose
your keywords and so again the primary
components we're looking for are how
much traffic you can get or the search
volume how much competition is for that
keyword and of course relevancy okay you
need to be able to choose a keyword
that's relevant to the web page you're
trying to rank for and so let me show
you example how to go through this so
the first thing we want to do is we want
to use a tool and the tool I would
recommend is Google Keyword Planner and
why do I choose Google Keyword Planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or Google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so Google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if I want to use Google's
Keyword Planner and I want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then I'm going to
type that keyword into Google's Keyword
Planner and what Google's going to do is
they're going to give me some Trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword I can
see that there are trends that that
appear for both desktop and mobile so
mobile is important because people start
their search process a lot of times on
their mobile device so we want to be
able to get data from mobile as well as
desktop and so we could see a trend here
that for each particular month over the
last 12 months we can see how much
volume this particular keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
get gets per month and so on average on
average over the past 12 months I could
see how to become a digital marketing
specialist is averages 30 searches a
month and this is on google.com and so
Google gives us the volume what they
also give us is the competition and so
here I can see Google says for that
particular keyword the competition is
medium and so in the Google's Keyword
Planner what they also do is give me
other relevant keywords that I might
think about optimizing for because you
don't want to optimize for just one key
word so how to become a digital
marketing specialist they're going to
also offer up other types of keywords
that are relevant so just digital
marketing specialist social media
marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is 1,000 per
month on average of the last 12 months I
can also see the competition is medium
but but for some other keywords I can
see the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what I would recommend as a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keywords in a spreadsheet and when you
put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data I'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from Google planner Google's
Keyword Planner and I competition from
Google's Keyword Planner and so if I go
into a spreadsheet and I put all that
information in here I'm going to be able
to see the volume and competition and so
that's important however one thing to
note here is that Google's Keyword
Planner if I go back just gives us low
medium and high and if I want to compare
numbers to numbers maybe I want to be
able to get exactly the competition
number for the the keyword how to become
a digital marketing specialist what I
can do is go into Google and I can type
in that keyword so if I type in the
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist I can see there's
76 Million results so I can see 76
Million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 uh per month on average and so
what I want to do is get a more clear
picture of the competition and so what
you could actually do is type in the
syntax all en tile and then colon and
then your keyw how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when I do that
I get a different result here I can see
only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular key
word that we want to rank for
in the title tag okay so the title tag
is what you see when you type in a
keyword or search query in Google search
and the title tag is what you see at the
top of every search result and so now I
can see I typed in how to become a
digital marketing specialist with the
all entitle syntax and now I can see
every listing every one of these
136 results have that particular keyword
in it so I could see every one of them
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and why is that important
because now that tells me I only need to
climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from Google's
Keyword Planner but you want to get your
competition from Google search and again
that's simply typing in the the syntax
all in title and then your keyword and
this example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for a number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
then you can go in and pick the keywords
you want to optimize for and that's
important because again if you're not
sure about a keyword then you want to do
the keyword research so you can be sure
of how much traffic you can get and how
much competition there is those are two
important three important factors in
starting the process for onpage SEO okay
you want to create content for say a
keyword like digital
marketing but digital marketing may seem
a little bit broad so you want to
probably stay away from broader keywords
because broader keywords tend to have a
lot of volume which is great but they
may also tend to have a lot of
competition but that's the whole point
of doing the keyword research maybe it
doesn't maybe there's more volume than
competition that's what you need to find
out when you do the keyword research you
need to find those keywords that are
relevant to your content that have a lot
of volume and low competition and then
once we identify those keywords then we
are free to go in and start optimizing
our web pages for those keywords and the
first place we want to start is the
title tag so if you're remember my
example going back here to our search
how to become a digital marketing
specialist we saw that every one of
these listings had that keyword in the
title tag and the title tag is important
because that's what users who use Google
search see first when they type in a
query and get results so they're going
to see the title tag so the title tag is
the most important element for on page
SEO it's the most important factor CU
that's what people see and so ideally
when we choose our keyword we want to
make sure that keyword is in the title
tag because that's what shows up in
Google search and that's what makes that
particular web page relevant for that
keyword query so the idea behind a title
tag it's between 50 and 60 characters
and so we want to make sure we stay
within that limit no more than 60
characters because what happens if it's
beyond that then Google will truncate
the title tag so if I go back to my
search you could see here on this
particular title tag Google truncated it
meaning they added the ellipses after
the title tag because it exceeded the 60
character limit so you want to stay
within those character counts and so the
title tag is the first place you should
start when optimizing your website
because when we have the right keyword
in the title tag and somebody types in
that keyword then chances are it's going
to be relevant they're going to see it
and they're going to click through to
your website and that's the whole idea
behind ranking we want to get clicks so
that's how the title tag appears so when
you optimize it you're going to update
the title tag and this is how it shows
up it's going to show up at the top of
your listing okay and it's going to be
bigger and Bolder than anything else
Google displays so the second thing you
want to optimize is the metad
description and the metad description is
simply just a brief description up to
155 I would say about 155 to 60 160
characters but probably no more than
that and so the metad description is
nothing more than a summary of the web
page itself so if I go back to my Google
search results I see my title tag and I
see the page that this particular
listing belongs to and underneath that
is where I can see my meta description
so in this particular keyword query how
to become a digital marketing specialist
I see the meta description an ultimate
guide on how to build a career in
digital marketing and the skills
required to become a digital marketing
specialist note that it's a well-written
metad description with an 155 characters
and it includes the keyword digital
marketing specialist so we're trying to
rank for how to become a digital
marketing specialist and here you could
see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag in the
keyword but the metad description in the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
descript destion because if you don't
update the meta description and you
leave The Meta description blank then
you're leaving it to Google to add in
copy that they deem relevant and so for
onpage SEO we want to take control of
the copy and we want to optimize it for
the keywords we want to be found for so
the metad description is a powerful tool
at our disposal it gives us more
characters to work with it gives us more
to talk about so for that particular
page and so if the title tag is only 60
characters maximum it's not a lot of
information to try and get somebody to
click so the metad description helps us
in identifying what that page is about
in order to get the click so the two
working in tandem will hopefully
increase your click the rates so when
you're found organically we want to get
the click and then the third element
that's important is the URL and URL
stands for uniform resource locator and
why is the URL so important because
that's what people see so if I go back
to my search result how to become a
digital marketing specialist notice that
the URL also includes how to become a
digital marketing specialist article
okay so it's very relevant the URL is
very relevant one we can see it in the
search results but two you know it's
relevant to the keyword query and that's
important for the end user and Google
Google wants to know hey is this the
page that's relevant to the user's query
and if it is then this users's like
likely going to have a good user
experience after they click on the
listing so the URL is an element that
helps not only with the click through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
URL structure doesn't help at all
because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor URL structure so the rule of thumb
is this if you don't understand what the
URL is then Google is likely not going
to understand what the URL is and so we
want to try and keep our URL structures
clean and when I say clean ideally you
want to make sure that whatever keyword
you're trying to optimize that's the
keyword that's included in the URL
nothing included that is not
understandable so again going back to
our example how to become a digital
marketing specialist it's very clean the
title tag is the keyword The Meta
description is cleanly written has the
keyword and then the URL is the other
element that the end user can see and
that URL includes the keyword in it so
after we've done those three elements
the title tag The Meta description and
the URL then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organizational
structure to the content and with
headers there's a hierarchy so you have
anywhere from H1 which is the top of the
hierarchy to an H6 and so you're free to
use any one of those headers when
building out a page in order to organize
the content but ideally you probably
want to stick with an H1 or an H2
because those are at the top of the
hierarchy and what those do is they
actually stress to Google that hey this
header with this particular keyword in
it is important so if you use an H6 with
the keyword in it it's telling Google
hey this is an H6 but it's not as
important so an H1 and an H2 tag show
importance and so let's look at an
example of what that is so here you can
see an H1 is going to be at the top of
the hierarchy so that means it's going
to be bigger and Bolder then you have an
H2 which is going to be bigger and
Bolder than an H3 but not as big and
bold as an H2 so with headers not only
you organizing the content accordingly
but you're also signaling to Google how
important that particular header is and
of course the header needs to include
the key word we're trying to rank for so
let's take a look again at that examp
example so if we go to how to become a
digital marketing specialist if I click
on that page I can look at the content
and I can see that there are headers in
here so the headers are there to
organize the content and that's what we
want we want to be able to organize the
content and if you look at the other
example I'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist uh learning
paths explored you can see that's an H1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an H2 and so we're not stressing to
Google that that's more important than
an H1 but nonetheless we're stressing to
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal linking if you remember uh
earlier in the presentation is basically
links from one page on your website to
another and so here we can see on this
particular article how to become a
digital marketing specialist there's
also links to other pages on simply
learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SEO
specialist PPC specialist social media
marketing specialist and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their website that are
relevant to becoming a digital marketing
specialist and so this is a best
practice when you're optimizing a web
page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and and
the whole idea behind internal linking
is it also allows users to navigate
through the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation they
can naturally and seamlessly go from one
relevant article or page to another and
so that's the whole idea behind link
building and internal link building it
allows Google to identify you know pages
that they want to crawl in index because
they're linked to one another but it
also helps the end user because it
allows the end user to go from one page
to another and it's signaling to Google
hey this particular page is linked to
this page so we're going to also index
that page and so that's the whole
important part of internal linking it's
about the end user experience and it's
about allowing Google to find the pages
on your website so they can crawl them
and index them so you can be ranked for
them and so also in addition to internal
linking we want to be able to use
natural language and so what do I mean
by natural language or natural language
processing so what Google does is in
terms of natural language processing
they're looking for the content and the
keyword it needs to be relevant so when
your website is about digital marketing
you don't necessarily want to rank or
try to rank for the keyword digital
marketing one it's too broad two there
might be some competition but three
you're probably not going to write
something is Broad like digital
marketing so ideally what you want to do
is you want to choose other relevant
related keywords that's going to be more
natural and so that's what we mean by
natural language processing we want to
choose keywords that are more natural to
the content you're writing so instead of
the keyword digital marketing maybe we
want to talk about the types of digital
marketing or digital marketing examples
or what is a digital marketing strategy
or how to become a digital marketing
specialist so those are all relevant
keywords to digital marketing and more
relevant to the content because if you
try to rank for the keyword digital
marketing again it's probably going to
be a little bit broad probably more
competition and not as relevant to your
content and as a result probably not a
good user experience so think about some
other keywords that you could optimize
and rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other key words
and the natural language process what
key wordss are more relevant for the
content and then another element to on
page SEO is the sitemap and so with the
sitemap it's basically a list of all the
pages on your website and the whole idea
of listing all the pages on your website
in one document is it helps both users
and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there two
types of sitemaps one's an HTML site map
and that's designed for humans so if you
have a website with a lot of content at
the footer or the bottom of your web
page you probably want to have a link to
sitemap so if somebody clicks on that
sit map they're going to be able to see
all the pages on your website structured
in an organized manner well an XML
sitemap and XML is just a different
format it's designed for crawlers and so
the whole idea remember is Google likes
to crawl content when they crawl content
they bring it back to their servers and
index it and so we want to be able to
create a sitemap for Google or other
search engine cers and so XML is the
format so let me show you example of how
that looks so if I go to Simply
learn.com and simply type in say
sitemap.xml just as an example I'm going
to get this particular page and this
particular page displays two XML sit
Maps so these sit maps are there for or
Google to go ahead and crawl and nothing
more than a list of all the pages on
your website and so this is a quick and
easy way for Google to get a hold of all
those pages so that they can index them
and that's the whole idea behind SEO you
want to be able to have Google index all
the content you want to be found for for
the keyword you want to be found for so
it all starts with the sitemap so let's
go from onpage SEO which in recap is
basically op imizing certain elements on
your website so that you are relevant
for a particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag The Meta
description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking and also
updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page SEO
because without on page or off off page
you can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off-page SEO and you could do all the
off-page SEO you want but you still need
onpage so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page SEO and so off-page SEO is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember I talked
about about this earlier on there's two
types of links internal and external
linking and so for onpage SEO we used
internal linking for off-page SEO we're
going to talk about external linking and
external linking allows us to improve
our websites recognition or relevancy or
credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and Authority
because we want Google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off-page SEO methods then
Google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page SEO synonymous with
link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthy and relevant we
need to do that in order to rank but
there's some other benefits there so if
we're have a link on another credible
website then it's likely going to
increase the traffic to our own website
it also creates high domain Authority
and so when I mean by high domain
Authority is if we have basically links
to other web pages pointing back to us
then basically our domain Authority is
going to improve and when our domain
Authority improves other websites are
going to want to link to to us so the
higher authoritative we are for our
website then other web pages are going
to want to link to us and so the more
external linking we have the higher the
domain Authority so it all starts with
linking to other high domain Authority
websites so linking to a high domain
Authority website for example having a
link on Wikipedia that points back to
our web page creates high domain
Authority for us and it helps Drive
traffic so of the other benefits of
off-page SEO are in credibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build
credibility trustworthiness and it's
going to in turn help us rank for that
particular page and then certainly not
last having a good off-page SEO link
building strategy increases our our
brand awareness because if we're on
other high Authority websites Wikipedia
or say a social platform it's going to
increase our brand awareness and
increasing our brand awareness increases
our trustworthiness and so if somebody
is looking to say become a digital
marketing specialist then likely instead
of typing in digital marketing
specialist on Google they may type in
our brand name in this case simply learn
and so these are all the benefits to
off-page SEO
so it's nothing more than having links
on other websites that are pointing back
to ours and again there's lots of
benefits it's drives helps Drive traffic
and increases our Authority so those are
things that we want to take advantage of
when we want to rank and the key behind
off-page SEO or link building is always
going to be content so from an onpage
SEO perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
a relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off-page SEO strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessar have
to be a website it could be a social
platform or can be another blogging
platform or blogging website linked back
to ours why because the content is
original it's natural it's well
structured it reads well and so that's
the whole idea behind off page you can't
have links on other websites if you
don't have quality content so one of the
ideas behind off-page SEO is not only do
you want to create good content but you
probably want to spend a lot of time or
a bit of time on others websites so
remember the example I used earlier in
this presentation about having an ice
cream blog and ice cream recipes well it
probably wouldn't be a bad idea to say
spend some time on other blogs related
to desserts related to cakes related to
food in general related to vegetables or
other items that people could link from
so the whole idea is understanding who
else is out there who has relevant
content that you could share so you
could share your content with them they
can share their content with you and
generally that's how it works naturally
anyway in the web spere if somebody
likes your content they're going to link
to it they don't necessarily have to
wait for you to ask them but it might
not be a bad idea to understand who else
is out out there that has content
similar to yours so that you can you
know get a link on that particular
website or blog post and so some other
ideas behind having external links
pointing back to your website is social
media so social media is not just
Facebook or Twitter but it expands
beyond that there's there's core there's
medium there's all sorts of content
generated websites like Reddit so the
list goes on and on you just need to
find what's relevant for your cont
content if it's relevant for your
content then it's worth putting or
trying to get the external link on that
social media platform and then again
going back to my ice cream blog recipes
blog post yeah if you find a particular
blog that you want to have an external
link on there's nothing wrong with
reaching out to that particular blogger
you know in some cases very flattering
but in other cases if the content is
relevant then why not it's only going to
help your and user experience if you add
somebody who has say a Blog about cakes
having their link on your blog post so
there's nothing wrong with it because it
also adds to the user experience and if
you're going to ask somebody to put an
external link on theirs you might want
to be openminded and make sure that
you're are able and willing to put an
external link on your blog post or
website pointing to their content that's
how the web Works especially if the
content of quality relevant and of good
nature okay so let's move on and finish
up with the dos and don'ts of SEO so we
talked a lot about why SEO what is SEO
you know how do we rank for SEO you know
what is on page SEO what is off-page SEO
and so let's just wrap up with some of
the things you again want to do to rank
your page for particular keyword and
some of the things you don't want to do
so the first thing on the list is
optimize for white hat techniques and
what I mean for for opting in for white
hat techniques is basically everything I
just mentioned today you want to do
keyword research you want to choose a
natural language processing form format
so you could choose keywords that are
going to be relevant natural to the
content and you don't want to opt for
black hat techniques and black hat
techniques are probably not even worth
going into detail but one example is
choosing a keyword arbitrarily like say
digital marketing and just stuffing that
keyword into the content so so that's
probably not something you want to do
cuz again it's not going to be good for
the end user so stay away from black hat
and focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off-page
SEO again it's what I mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
Authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then Google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in the same way
as if you were on a quality website we
do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag for every web page on
your website and ideally what does that
mean that means using our keyword
research to choose one or two keywords
for page and optimizing your web page
for those one to two keywords so you
ideally what you want to do is have one
to two different keywords for every page
on your website we definitely definitely
definitely want to right engaging
content so the content should be
engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or
plagiarize or just copy content from
others websites because it's not one
probably going to be relevant to what
you're writing about two it's duplicate
content and it's somebody else's so
that's a black cat Technique we want to
stay away from I can't emphasize this
enough we need to do keyword research
first before you do anything else you
need to find relevant keywords and not
only that you need to understand the
volume and the competition for each of
those keywords okay you don't want to
choose a keyword that has low volume
High competition you want to choose a
keyword that has high volume low
competition but above all you want to
choose key words that are relevant to
your content we want to avoid keyword
stuffing so don't take a keyword and
just stuff it everywhere on the page
it's not going to be natural and
Google's going to be able to pick up on
that so we want to maintain some level
of quality with our content and quality
with the keywords that we choose so
reminder when you have quality content
it's always going to link internally to
another page on your website with
quality content but it's got to be
natural and don't just build sitewide
backlinks meaning don't just have an
internal link to the homepage or don't
have every page on your website linking
to just one page so internal linking
should be natural naturally linking from
one page to another not only does it
help Google understand and crawl all the
web pages on your website but it's good
for the end User it's good user
experience and certainly last but
something I didn't talk about does take
time to rank your content so remember
the process you're going to write your
content you're going to choose keywords
you're going to change the elements on
that page for those keywords and all the
while you're going to make sure Google
can crawl that content and when they
crawl it they're going to index it the
process takes time especially if you
choose a keyword that's competitive so
just be patient if you have quality
content and you've optimize for onpage
SEO and off-page SEO then you will rank
for that keyword and then make sure your
website's userfriendly and mobile
friendly so we talked about responsive
content earlier so remember most users
today start the process of search on
mobile so we want to make sure your
websites are mobile friendly greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders from Simply
learn and today we're going to talk
about keyword research so what are we
going to talk about when we talk about
keyword research we're going to talk
about why we would do keyword research
for SEO we're going to talk about the
types of keywords that we need to
research we're going to talk about some
methodologies best practices on how to
do keyword research some alternate
suggestions we're going to talk about
keyword clustering and then we're going
to talk about some tools that you can
use to do your keyword research so let's
start with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
pizza recipes step by step pizza recipes
with sausage homemade pizza toppings
pizza dough recipes th Crust Pizzas
she's doing a lot of different topics on
pizza recipes well what Jesse needs to
do is understand what's going to drive
traffic to these blog posts if she's
writing about you know different topics
around pizza recipes so she's Unsure how
these blogs are going to drive traffic
so she really needs to understand that
hey you need to choose the right
keywords to drive traffic so the
question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keyword to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care in
choosing the key words to align with
your content so that's really the idea
why we would do keyword research because
some of the issues with keywords that
are poorly chosen in are they could have
low search volume for example you may
choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it could be very competitive and
take you a long time to be found for
that keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
align with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can encounter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me that's the most important step with
SEO is keyword research so we're going
to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keywords and we have longtail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short tail keywords
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three keywords
in a phrase or shorter and some cases it
may be two keywords in a phrase or
shorter so short tail keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it also means it could be lower
conversions because short tail keyw like
for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short tail keute word but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short keywords may not be as relevant so
if we compare it with longtail keywords
chances are you're going to have lower
competition that's one of the benefits
but you're also going to have lower
search volume but with longer tail
keywords the keyword is probably going
to be more relevant with the content
you're writing about so therefore the
conversion rates likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short-tail keywords and longtail
keywords if you want to look it
simplistically short-tail keywords are
Broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs may
look at your content as not Rel
versus longtail keywords that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes could take you a while to rank
for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the
keyword is Broad in nature so pizza
recipes is a short tail key word that
may not be exact exactly what you're
writing about in your blog post so it
may draw a lot of traffic but the
traffic may not do anything so the
longer tail keywords are very specific
they consist of more than three words in
the search query they have relatively
low search volume competition so the
chance of you ranking higher faster for
that long TI word is probably going to
be greater because not many other
websites are trying to rank for that
same key word and so the benefit of that
is if you have let's just say homemade
pizza recipes with mushrooms that's a
long tiky word but if somebody's looking
for that type of pizza recipe then you
know you're going to track the right
traffic and chances are that traffic is
going to engage or convert based on the
type of conversion you have in place so
example would be homemade pizza dough
recipes that'd be another example more
than th key words in the phrase very
specific we're talking about homemade
pizza dough recipe so we're not talking
about just pizza recipes so it's a
little bit more uh specific in nature
longer tail so these keywords are used
for targeted Pages including blog post
if you're writing a blog post
specifically about pizza recipes with
homemade dough then this is the keyword
you likely would want to use versus just
pizza recipes so let's look at an
example between a short tail keyword and
a longtail keyword and to accentuate the
differences we're going to use Google
Keyword Planner tool so Google's Keyword
Planner tool is located in Google ads
the Google ads platform and when you're
in the Google ads platform you can
simply click on tools and then Keyword
Planner and so what Keyword Planner
allows us to do is get a sense of the
type of volume that a particular keyword
has so what Google's Keyword Planner
does is they show you the average
monthly searches this is the average
monthly search volume of a keyword over
the past 12 months and so in this
example we're going to choose pizza
recipes and homemade pizza dough recipes
so one short tail and one long tail so
we enter those keywords in we're going
to click get results and what Google's
going to do is it's going to show us the
volume of those keywords so for pizza
recipe we could see the average monthly
search volume is
33,100 for pizza recipe so note that
pizza recipe and pizza recipes are
closely related keywords and so what
Google does is they consider that a
close variance so meaning if somebody
ties a pizza of recipe then they're also
in Google's eyes looking for pizza
recipes so it's a close variance and so
for the keyword pizza recipe which is
short tail we could see on average over
the past 12 months this keyword received
33,100 queries and so if we hover over
the graph we could see basically the
volume the average volume per month so
here I could see for this particular
keyword here the volume per month is 33
1,000 and then I could see the actual
volume over the past 12 months and then
for the longtail keyword I can see
homemade pizza D recipe again close
variance homemade pizza dough recipes I
can see over the past 12 months what the
search volume is for this on average
it's 2400 but I could see here in
December the volume went up to 3600 but
for example in May it was 19900 so it's
going to fluctuate a bit over the past
12 months but on average is about 2400
so shorter tail a lot more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the differences between a short tail and
a longer tail and so what Google's
Keyword Planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here I can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranks on page one of Google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2400 search queries for that keyword now
whether you get all 2400 clicks for that
keyword remains to be seen chances are
you're not going to get all 2400 you're
going to get a lion share of those
clicks but you're going to at least get
some volume on it so even the longer T
keywords have a lot of Promise cuz there
is some search volume here for this
keyword how to do a proper keyword
research so we looked at Google's
Keyword Planner tool in Google ads and
we typed in two keywords and we were
able to get a sense of what the average
volume is so we definitely want to
choose key words based on the following
factors we want to choose it based on
search volume search volume is a good
indicator of the potential traffic we
can obtain so again for the key word
homemade pizza dough recipe we know that
it averages 2400 a month in search
volume again we may not get all 2400 but
we're going to get a line share of that
we also need to look at competition and
so Google's Keyword Planner gives us a
high medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of the
compet ition is and you should because
competition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what I want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
Google's Keyword Planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
I want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what I can do is go
into Google's search and I can type in
pizza recipes and I could see there's
about 1 billion results that's a lot of
results however that means that every
potential web page out there on the
internet that mentions pizza recipes is
going to be included in this number here
and so I want to get a better sense of
who's optimizing for pizza recipes so
I'm going to put in the all and tile
syntax and so what that is going to ask
Google to do is tell me all the web
sites that have pizza recipes the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
so if I do all in tile colon space then
Pizza recip Rees my result drops down to
336,000 so what that tells me is that
there are 336,000 results with the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
now if I want to focus in on my other
keyword if I choose uh my other keyword
was a longer tail keyword homemade pizza
dough recipe so if I type that keyword
in the homemade pizza dough recipe or
recipes remember close variants and I
just click and enter or type the keyword
in hit my Enter key I'm going to get 35
Million results but again is that really
an indicator of the type of competition
I have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
en title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2,000
160 different results so here I can see
the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza dough recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites or web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the the spreadsheet is going
to contain keywords that we can
potentially want to optimize for choose
as keywords to optimize for SEO and so
my recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33,100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 th000 so I'm going to
type in
683 th000 what was our next keyword well
it was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is400 so I'm going to
put 2400 in under my volume column and
then what was my competition well my
competition was if I type that keyword
back in 2,160 so I'm going to put
2,160 so now I have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition I
have now you want to do this for a
number of different keywords and when
you do it for number keywords what you
do want to do is obviously choose a
relevant keyword that has high volume
and low competition so another way of
saying it is the volume or ratio of
volume to competition and so basically
what we could do is take volume divided
by competition and if I make that a
percentage I can see it's 35% is the
ratio between volume and competition if
I do the same for my longer tail keyword
2400 / 2160 I can see that 111% so this
just kind of proves the point that yeah
I'm still going to get some volume but I
have a better chance of ranking for this
longer T key word homemade pizza dough
recipes so you want to be able able to
do that for number keywords and examine
the volume the competition and the ratio
between volume and competition for your
themed keywords in this case pizza
recipes so relevancy you want to choose
keywords that are very relevant to the
content that you're writing and then
again commercial intent what keywords
are going to drive more conversions and
revenue for the business so when we talk
about commercial intent we're talking
about you know are you choosing keywords
that are going to get some to do what
you want them to do so we could say You
Know download pizza dough recipes so
somebody's typing in the keyword
download pizza dough recipes then
chances are they're going to find you
come to your site and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular key keyword
and phrase so we can get that number
using Google's Keyword Planner tool in
the Google ads platform we want to
Target keywords with high search volume
that will help bring traffic to the
website we want volume but we want to
take into account seasonality as well so
that's where the Google's Keyword
Planner tool comes in place because if
we go back again we can just hover over
we can get a sense of any particular
Trend going on or seasonality so for
example if I saw large growth in the
winter months and not much volume growth
in the summer months then that might
indicate to me that this keyword is more
popular during the winter time so pay
attention to the graphs that you know
the Keyword Planner tool gives you use
them to your advantage to take into
account seasonality so a good example
would be funny Halloween costumes well
we know that for Halloween you're going
to have a spike probably towards the end
of September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter month so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a key word that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitle syntax
to find the competition so we entered
both of those numbers in and we get our
ratio and so when you have these numbers
for a number of different keywords you
want to be able to choose that ratio of
high volume low competition but always
relevancy always trumps ratio so always
go with a keyword that is going to be
relevant to your content don't choose a
keyword that's not relevant if you
choose a keyword that's not relevant
it's not going to bode well for user
engagement so the difficulty of a
keyword ranges from 0 to 100 in Google's
keyword tool so it's going to be easy
it's going to be medium it's going to be
hard but my recommendation is also to
get the numerical factor and that's the
all and title syntax and again relevancy
is what drives the traffic to your
website and keep the traffic there on
your website and also not only will it
keep the traffic on your website but
hopefully get that traffic to engage and
convert so that's the key about
relevancy you always want want to choose
keywords that are relevant to your
content even if it's sacrificing volume
relevancy again trumps volume in
competition so always choose relevant
keywords first so when you do that
you're always almost guaranteeing that
at some point somebody's going to find
your content because somebody out there
might be looking for it and if they do
you're going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to your business and
then f focus on those key wordss that'll
help you with getting the right traffic
to your site always keep in mind the
commercial in tent so these key wordss
are more specific and result in
conversion rate for example buying is a
good commercial and tent keyword so if
you really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe it's download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples like commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't don't be
afraid to use some of these keywords as
part of your longer tail keyword phrase
again the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for SEO so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for those keywords then it's
going to lead to better engagement with
some conversions and so when we talk
about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a secondary
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose a keyword
as a primary keyword that is relevant to
the content but may not necessarily rank
very high or have a lot of volume that
secondary keyword is also relevant to
the primary keyword but also relevant to
content and you may rank for that
secondary keyword so you always want to
go with two keywords versus just one
keyword want to give your yourself a
chance to rank for at least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary key so your primary keyword is
always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if a primary keyword is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to cool Google's Keyword
Planner tool and get an idea of the
volume for healthy diet plan and then
also the volume and competition for some
of these secondary keyw like healthy
diet for weight loss healthy diet food
low carb diet healthy meal plans and
diet PL weight loss so if I go in to
Google's Keyword Planner and type those
keywords in I'm going to choose get
results and now here I can see healthy
diet plan keyword I'm focusing on as my
primary keyword has an average monthly
search volume of
99,900 and then some of my secondary
keywords healthy diet foods diet plan
weight loss low carb diet you know
Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at the search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan I go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan
99,900 what's my competition so my
competition is
74,700 and that's going to give me a
ratio of volume to competition of 13% so
that's what my content's about that's a
considered a short tail keyword because
it has a lot of competition and so my
ratio is 133% and what I want to do is I
want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key at
least two keywords I want to be able to
find my primary keyword that's relevant
to my content and then I want to be able
to find my secondary keyword which is
again related to the primary keyword
which is also related to the content and
and so I want to be able to choose two
keywords basically and I want to choose
two keywords that are relevant that have
good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again of how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like Kora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use popular platforms like
Wikipedia and we can use social media
bookmarking like Reddit so there are
lots of suggestions that we can obtain
from various sources so let's start with
LSI keywords and LSI stands for latent
semantic insect indexing and so
basically what it is it's just keywords
that are linked to your primary keyword
and so when you're choosing keywords you
always want to choose that primary
keyword and then secondary keywords that
are similar to the primary keyword and
usually those are LSI or latent semantic
indexing type keywords so they're used
to drive relevant traffic to your page
so if you're focusing on one keyword we
want to have other keywords that are
similar to increase our visibility on
the search Eng result pages so we could
find latent semantic indexing right in
search so if we use the term healthy
diet if we go to Google search for
example if I type in healthy diet in
Google search all I need to do is scroll
to the bottom of the page and I can see
searches related to healthy diet so
healthy diet menu healthy diet essay
what does a healthy diet look like
notice at the top Google's also given me
some other suggestions here so they're
saying lowfat diet veganism gluten-free
diet so there's lots of different
suggestions right in Google search bar
so all of these are LSI related keyword
so if you're optimizing a page for
healthy diet then you could choose low
fat diet as a secondary keyword you can
use gluten-free diet as a secondary
keyword it really depends on what the
content is but you always want to
support your content with as much LSI
keywords as possible so you can be found
for as many different keywords as
possible in Google search so it's
important because if you have a Blog
that you know talks about python so how
do the search engines know if the
website python is about the programming
language or the snake so Google for
example uses LSI keywords to understand
what the page is specifically focusing
on so if you're just focusing on Python
and your content you want to support
that with LSI keywords and so that will
allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
found for feature snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a keyword I may want to
use and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of questions
are being asked what Mals are good for
weight loss what is a good healthy diet
plan all of these could be keyword
phrases that you can use so the answers
are right here in Google so cor is a
great platform because cor is a platform
that people go and ask questions in a
community responds with answers or
responses to that particular question or
topic and so the great thing about core
is it's a good it's a good place for you
to go to get some ideas about a specific
topic so if we're talking about healthy
dieting so we can find keywords with
high search vol I'm writing Kora so the
whole idea is you can look at you know
the top five questions for specific
topic like healthy dieting and find
relevant keywords to healthy dieting so
if you just type in that particular
keyword in Kora you're going to probably
get some responses to questions or
responses to somebody else's question
and so if we take a look at core for
example so if I just type in healthy
dieting what I'm going to do is I'm
going to get some responses to the the
topic healthy dieting so what's what's
the best diet for Healthy Living what
are the top five tips for a healthy diet
habit so all of these could be keyword
phrases that you could take away with
for your own content and so the benefit
here is you're getting kind of an idea
of what's trending what people are
talking about and if you use tips for a
healthy diet habit for example and you
optimize for that well again that could
turn around in bode well for you because
you could be featured in Google as a
featured snippet at the top here you can
also turn around and use LSI related
keywords for healthy diet habits and you
can simply just look for those LSI
keywords wrri in Google remember at the
bottom or at the Top If I scroll down I
can see some related LSI keywords at the
bottom so writing Google as well you
could see in the Google search bar that
Google provides some LSI related
keywords to your query so if I go back
here and type in healthy diet recipes I
can see here Google suggesting some
other related keywords healthy diet menu
healthy diet for men healthy diet foods
healthy diet for women so these are all
LSI related keywords that you can use to
support your primary keyword and the
content you're writing about so we've
talked about LSI keywords where to find
them so they're found right here they
could be found at the top of Google and
they could be found at the bottom you
can also then go to core as well and get
some ideas for the types of questions
they're being asked so if you ask a
question and use that as your keyword
phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on Coral so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for term so Google
collects all the keyword queries that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start to type in
recipes I could see some of the other
queries that somebody else has typed in
or some of the most popular queries
related to that topic so if you enter
the keyword healthy diet Google's going
to suggest multiple keyword suggestions
that users have asked in the past and
you could certainly get the search
volume of those keywords just by looking
in Google itself I could see for how
healthy diet recipes billions of pages
related to healthy diet recipes I can
also get the search volume by going into
Google's Keyword Planner so if I type in
healthy diet I'm going to be able to see
what my search volume is for that
keyword and in addition I can see the
seasonality of that particular keyword
and in addition to that Google's going
to provide some other related keywords
to my search query so if I'm looking for
healthy diet Google's going to suggest
hey maybe you should choose healthy food
or healthy eating or how to lose weight
so those are LSI related keywords that
Google provides in the keyword plan
which is built into the Google ads
platform another option for you is
Wikipedia so Wikipedia is a vast
platform of content so we could turn
Wikipedia into our own asset and use it
to our own Advantage by finding relevant
keywords in an easy fashion so with
Wikipedia we can identify list of
keywords in The Meta description itself
we could choose keywords from the first
paragraph of Wikipedia that has many
relevant keywords or we could take a
look at keywords from the Wikipedia
content section so we can also see
additional Pages like the see also
section that gives relevant keywords
that you're looking for we can also look
at the references section as they
contain relevant keywords so we go to
Wikipedia as an example and I type in
healthy diet into Wikipedia here I I can
get just in the first paragraph alone I
can see some additional keywords that I
might choose to use like micronutrients
I never knew that micronutrients was
related to healthy diet but Wikipedia is
providing some information about what
micronutrients is and maybe I can use
that as a keyword an LSI related keyword
to my content so if I scroll down I can
the see also section so it might give me
some information food information to
Consumers for for example dietary
guidelines I can look at categories like
dietetics and diets I can also look at
the references section so I can also see
what information was provided like
health effects of overweight and obesity
I can look at diet and physical activity
so all of these are related to my main
keyword healthy diet so the answers are
right in here on the platform they're
just all over the page so Wikipedia has
an abundance of information you just
need to know where to look so again with
Wikipedia you can look no further than
the first paragraph you can look no
further than the SE also section the
referencing section the category section
there's lots of information right on the
page itself to help you get ideas for
keywords so if you Google your keyword
with Wikipedia term in the search query
and get relevant keywords from the title
tags and the Ser so you can also do that
as well so if I type in healthy diet
Wikipedia and search I can also get some
information here as well so people also
search for healthy food advantages or
healthy food habits essay or information
about healthy food all of these are
related to my keyword healthy diet so
again another bit of information for you
to choose or look to choose some
additional keywords for it's a Reddit
it's a popular Community where people
post content discuss a variety of topics
so that's what Reddit is so with the
help of subreddits an individual can
find relevant keywords with with high
search volume so and Reddit there's an
easy way to find out keywords they have
a keyword tool called keyword it so
keyword it giv the average monthly
searches for a particular keyword so if
we type a Word in key rdit and choose
keywords from the autogenerator list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volumes so if we go to the keyword it
and Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get keywords I can see
what keywords are relevant and the
search volume of that keyword so if I
just type in healthy food keyword it
tool is going to tell me some relevant
keywords and what the volume is so if
you don't have the Keyword Planner tool
in Google ads available to you this is a
good alternative solution to finding
keywords so it's free you just need to
go to keyword it.com type in your
keyword click get keywords and what it's
going to do is give you some relevant
keyword words related to your primary
keyword with the search volume let's
talk about keyword clustering now so the
whole idea about keyword clustering is
to really take advantage of the keywords
that we're optimizing for to gain higher
ranking so if we can cluster keywords
together in a theme and that theme of
keywords is relevant to a specific page
of a website then we have a better
opportunity to rank so in other words
why do we have to Target just one
keyword when we can Target many so keep
in mind you know LSI keywords we want to
group a bunch of keywords together that
are similar for Content so for example
after some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is SEO how does SEO
work intro to SEO what are the basics of
SEO all of those are related to the
court theme what is SEO another cluster
keyword for example could be SEO
techniques SEO best practices tips and
tricks website optimization onpage SEO
techniques Etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found so that's the whole idea
behind clustering so some additional
steps remember stay up to date on
industry news so brainstorm your ideas
first and identify a list of keywords I
a theme of keywords that you can cluster
together and then you could determine
the keywords that your competitors are
already ranking for so for example if we
want to rank for the keyword SEO best
practices for example we can use a tool
called keyword Moz if I go toy keyword
the keyword Explorer tool in MZ and just
type in SEO best practices what it's
going to do is it's going to give me
some volume related to that particular
keyword but more importantly what it's
also going to do is going to show me
what pages are already ranked for that
particular keyword so therefore I can
get a sense of who is already ranking
for that keyword so here I can see MMOs
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of what Pages A ranked for a
particular keyword or group of keywords
I want to rank for myself ever wondered
why it's a big deal well we've got you
covered in this video we will break down
what keyword research is why it matters
and most importantly how to do it using
chgb no confusing stuff just simple
steps just easy steps to boost your
online presence subscribe smash that
like button and let's dive in into the
world of keywords together so now now
let's first understand what is keyword
research and why is it important just a
quick info for you if you want to
upscale yourself master digital
marketing skills and land your dream job
or grow in your career then you must
explore simply learn scort of various
digital marketing programs simply learn
offers various certification and
post-graduate programs in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like SP Jane Purdue and
meta through our courses you will gain
knowled and work ready expertise in
skills like search engine marketing
strategies for paid campaigns analytics
Roi and evaluation and over a dozen
others that's not all you'll also get
the opportunity to work on multiple
projects and learn from industry experts
working in top DED product companies and
academian from top universities after
completing these courses thousands of
Learners have transitioned into digital
marketing role as a fresher or moved on
to higher paying job role or profile if
you are passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pin comments
and description box to find digital
marketing programs that fits your
experience and areas of interests so
keyword research is like finding the
words people type into search engines
it's vital for online success picture it
as using the right words to get noticed
on Google by knowing that words people
use you can make your content match what
they're looking for
this is crucial because it means the
right people find your website it's not
just about being at the top of the
Google it's about talking in a way that
makes sense to your audience keyword
research is like a guide helping you
know where your audience is looking it's
the key to making sure your website is
easy to find and has what people are
searching for the significance of
research lies in its ability to line
your online presence with the actual
language your audience uses ensures that
your content resonates with their
queries attracting a relevant audience
interest in your offerings essentially
keyword research is a strategic tool
that not only boosts search engine
rankings but also establishes a
connection between your content and
specific terms your audience employees
making your online presence both
accessible and meaningful all right so
this was about what is keyword research
and why is it important now let's
understand how to do a keyword research
using chat gbt for that let's go to
google.com so as you can see we have
opened Google Now all we have to do is
to write first of all we'll write AI PRM
AI PM all right so AI PRM or AI PRM for
chat gbt you can type now let's open the
first link we'll click on the first link
so this is basically an extension it is
a Marketplace of prompts they provide
you prompts that you don't have to type
the whole prompt they have pre-made
prompt comps that you can use all right
now we can click on this add to Chrome
button over here ADD
extension
right so as you can see this is a whole
new outlook of this chat gbt this is
aipm prompt extension so basically they
give you pre-made prompts as you can see
this you used SE optimized content
writer fully SE optimized article
including so there are numerous as we
can see 4 580 prompts so you can choose
accordingly whichsoever prompt you want
and you can also search over here and
this is topic activity sort by you can
also sort and prompts SP page you can
customize it according to yourself so as
you can see here is the topic uh we can
go to topic and we can select so we want
to basically do a keyword research we'll
go to SEO we'll click on SEO after that
in activity we can select this uh
keywords all right now as we can see
there are numerous prompts according to
what we have selected that YouTube SEO
keyword generator SEO optimize your
Google business profile Etc so we can
select as per our choice so what I have
figured out which is best is this one
keyword analysis I repeat keyword
analysis so as we can see find the table
of best keywords with search volume CPC
paid difficulty Su difficulty so for
those who don't know about uh CPC so uh
CPC or cost per click is a measure in
online advertising that represents the
amount you pay when someone clicks on
your ad it's essentially the cost of
each interaction with your advertisement
higher the CPC values often indicate
more competitive keywords or advertising
spaces and as you can see PID difficulty
is also written so pay difficulty refers
to how challenging it is to compete for
a particular keyword in paid advertising
a higher paid difficulty score means
that it might be more expensive or
competitive to bid for that keyword in
paid search campaigns so now there is
SEO difficulty so SEO difficulty
basically is a measure of how hard it is
to rank organically for a specific
keyword in search engine results a
higher Su difficulty suggests that it
might be more challenging to optimize
your content to appear higher in unpaid
organic search results for that keyword
it takes into count factors like
competition and the existing strength of
other Pages ranking for the same keyword
so these are the meanings of these
things as we can see so we have already
clicked on this now as we can see seed
keyword that you search for so let's say
uh I'm searching for cloud computing
let's
say
cloud computing and let's click on
this so as we can see they are creating
all this now let's explore keywords
related to cloud computing along with
the respective search volume all right
so as you can see keyword these are the
keywords that we got and these are the
search volumes so we all know what
search volume is the number of searches
and the CPC as we already discussed what
is CPC again if somebody wants to know
about it CPC or cost by click is a
measure in online advertising that
represents the amount you pay when
someone clicks on your ad so these are
the amount you pay when someone clicks
on these ads all right so pay difficulty
again it refers to how challenging it is
to compete for a particular keyword in
paid advertising so this is paid
difficulty of each of these keywords
then SEO difficulty SEO difficulty is a
measure of how hard it is to rank
organically for a specific keyword in
search engine results so these are the
uh suq difficulty so we can select
accordingly and the table index is a mix
of 100 keywords including longtail LSI
so longtail keywords are also there as
you can see we'll discuss longtail
keywords also after this so this is how
you can do keyword research using chat
gbt we'll do one or two more demos
regarding this so let's do another
example so we are going to select
keyword analysis and then we'll have to
put seed keyword remember to select SEO
first of all here we can see SEO and
then in activity you have to select
keywords because we are doing the
keyword research all right now after
selecting this keyword analysis we want
basic we basically want all these things
like search volume CPC PID difficulty s
difficulty so that we can choose the
right keywords accordingly so let's see
here we have to put the seed keyword so
let's say the seed keyword is let's say
devops all right now let's click on
this so they are giving us the keywords
a lot of keywords they usually give
let's explore the keyword analysis for
devops so as you can see high search
volume very high search volume high so
these search volumes regarding these
keywords are shown and the CPC is also
showing and paid difficulty SEO
difficulty as well so we basically want
the SEO difficulty is to minimum like
minimum or like medium so we can search
or extract those keywords accordingly so
they have written this table includes a
mix of 100 relevant longtail keywords
LSI keywords and FAQ related to devops
it provides insights into search volume
CPC cost per click pay difficulty and
SEO difficulty to help optimize your
content and reach the target audience
effectively so through this you can
select these keywords and I think if you
click on continue it will keep on going
for more keywords so as you can see
longtail keywords now it is showing so
these are LSI keywords so we will
discuss these uh terms longtail longtail
keywords LSI keywords after some time
later in this I repeat later in this
video so this is how you can simply do a
keyword research using chat GPT again
this keyword research is completely free
you have you don't have to pay a single
Buck regarding this now let's try
another method of doing a keyword
research for that all we have to do is
to go to Google and we'll
type
keywords
everywhere all right so here's the first
link let's click on this this is another
extension install for Chrome we'll click
on install for Chrome now let it open
and now we can click on add to Chrome to
just add this extension in our Chrome
browser as you can see ADD extension so
I think it is added now now all we have
to do is to pin this one all right so
now uh let's go to to chat GPT let's
open a new
one so as you can see this is keywords
everywhere icon please continue as you
can see clarify explain rewrite so for
that to use this extensions powers or
functionality all we have to do is to
click on this template button all right
now here the thing is first of all we'll
select choose a category similarly that
we have done previously choose a
category so as you can see copyrighting
marketing SEO social media productivity
professionals we'll select SEO because
we want to do keyword research then in
subcategory we can select keyword
research and because we want to do
keyword research then there's a template
so here we can see first is keyword
strategy so you can click on keyword
strategy if you want to do basically a
strategize the keyword so basically I'll
tell you what keyword strategy is
keyword strategy involves planning like
how to use specific words or phrases in
your content to achieve specific goals
like it's about selecting and targeting
keywords that align with your overall
objectives whether it's to boost website
traffic increase conversions or enhance
your online visibility then there is get
search intent for keywords so it I
repeat so it itself tells what it is
like intent understanding search intent
for keywords means grasping the reason
behind someone online search it involves
figuring out what a person is looking
for for when they type a particular
keyword into a search engine aligning
your content with users intent ensures
that your information meets their needs
improving the relevance of your content
then here is related keyword generator
so a related keyword generator is a term
or phrase closely connected to the main
keyword your targeting including related
keywords in your content helps search
engines understand the content and
relevance of your page it's a way to
capture a broader range of search
queries related to your main topic then
there is longtail gyw word so basically
a longtail keyword is a more specific
and detailed phrase usually consisting
of three or more words while these
phrases may have lower search volumes
individually they often attract a more
targeted audience longtail keywords can
be valuable for Niche topics are
generally easier to rank for than
broader more competitive terms so these
are all these things so let's say first
of all I want to search for related key
generator and so first all as you can
see category SEO subcategory keyword
research templates select accordingly
whichever you want I've explained all
these related keyword generator I want
basically when we'll select related
keyword generator this will come up
language is English we want in English
only here is the seed keyword we'll have
to write this is total keywords how many
keywords do we want we can select
accordingly basically I want 40 itself
so this is a prompt template that
automatically gets created whenever you
select a particular template so let's
say if I want want to select keyword
strategy so it will create itself a
different kind of prompt so if I'll
select longtail then a different kind of
prompt will be generated so this is a
self-made itself it will create a prompt
all you have to do is to write a seed
keyword over here so let's say as I said
I want a related keyword generator and
let's type here
devops all right so total keywords I
want 40 itself now click on execute
template all right so these are the 40
keywords that we wanted so related
keyword generator continues integration
infrastructure as code Dockers
kubernetes shenkin and they're also
telling me the search intent
informational so all of these keywords
are informational so firstly they'll
create a table regarding these keywords
after that they will basically list of
same keywords separated by commas as you
can see same keywords are separated by
comma so that you can easily use them
wherever you want all right so this we
have selected for the what we call
Related keyword generator now let's
select another one let's click on
template again we'll go to related or
let's say longtail keyword generator now
we'll put da Ops
again
yes all right so as you can
see I think we'll have to select another
new chat we'll have to create all right
now again we'll go to template longtail
keyword generator devops and let's say
this time we want
50 all right so we'll see whenever we
are doing this editing here also it is
getting edited so let's type 60 then it
will get 60 and whenever we'll type
devops this will also get edited as you
can see so this is a prompt now we'll
click on execute template let's see see
how it
goes so these are basically a longtail
keywords as you can see not a single
keyword devops best practices kubernets
deployment genin automation site
reliability engineer Etc basically the
search intent of all these keywords is
like informational this one we can see
commercial commercial transactional
deployment so they also show the search
intent and these all are the keywords
separated with commas there are six
total keywords now let's do another one
we go to template and we'll type let's
say this time we'll type mobile itself
now let's see the keyword strategy for
mobile we have typed mobile as a seat
keyword now execute
template so as you can see category
keyword search intent title and they're
also telling us the title about as you
can see Let It complete this one then
we'll show this so it has generated the
table as you can see please please note
that this table includes 24 entries to
maintain Clarity and conciseness if you
need additional keywords or adjustments
feel free to let me know we can click on
this continue to create more but let's
first just see as we can see first of
all types here there is device types
category mobile phone search intent
navigational and we can see title is
also there if we'll click on this as you
can see title search intent title
essential guide to choosing the perfect
mobile
let's open this essential guide to
choosing the perfect mobile phone
description also is there for your
content so you don't have to do anything
regarding this as you can see explore
our comprehensive guide on selecting an
ideal mobile so description they also
provide a complete description is there
so basically you can just copy paste it
and just copy this and just put it into
an Excel sheet to to just have a look at
it clearly so in Excel sheet you can
easily uh figure out what all keywords
you want to use in your content or your
article so this these two extensions are
important for you if you want to do
keyword research using chat GPT and make
your work easy these two extensions are
completely free so feel free to use them
one is aipm and another one is keywords
everywhere greetings everyone this is
Rob Sanders and thank you for joining me
today we're going to talk about SEO
tools let's get started so if you're
doing SEO
and you're doing on page and off-page
SEO for an organization or website
you're going to need some tools to help
you so you can't go at it alone you
can't do anything manually you have to
lean on tools to help you work more
efficiently help you gain an advantage
and so if you're doing SEO you're going
to need tools for keyword research
you're going to need tools to help you
with the technical aspects related to
SEO you're going to have to use some
tools for off-page SEO including
backlink monitoring and Analysis and
then there's tools for helping you track
where your keywords and Pages rank so
there's tools for every element of SEO
and today we're going to take a look at
some of the best tools out there on the
market to help you do your job better so
let's start with the keyword research so
with keyword research tools you can do
your job a lot more efficiently finding
the right relevant keywords I mean
that's really key to SEO is finding
keywords that are relevant to your
business product or service that you
want to rank for so you want to be able
to choose keywords with high search
volume and low competition so where do
you get those numbers you get those from
certain tools you also want to get
forecast for certain targeted keywords
you want to be able to generate a list
of latent semantic indexing type
keywords keywords close to the keyword
you're trying to Target you want to be
able to select primary and secondary
keywords wisely so having a list of
keywords with certain data points will
help help you do that and you want to be
able to identify the keywords that your
competitors are also ranking for so good
keyword research tool will help you do
all of those things so what are some of
the the tools out there well look no
further than some of the free ones that
Google offers like Google Trends so
Google Trends is a good tool that you
can lean on so if we look at Google
Trends all you need to do is trends.
goole.com you can type in a keyword I
can look at the volume or interest of
that keyword over time here looking at
football versus American football and I
could see how it's trending then I could
see you know how it Trends in specific
regions of say the United States as my
market I can also look at other related
queries similar to football or American
football and so Google Trends is a good
tool helps you look at the volume helps
you look at what specific regions helps
you look at other keywords you know if
you want you can simply just do a
keyword search or you can actually just
see what TR tring just by looking at the
latest stories and insights so we could
see International women's day you know
started to pick up steam it's picking up
more steam Etc so it's certain keywords
that tend to Trend well and you can pick
up on what those keywords are using
Google Trends now you could also use
another Google tool called Google
Keyword Planner the only difference is
this one's paid you need a Google ads
account so if we go into Google ads hey
you'll need to go to tools and you'll
need to go to Keyword Planner when
you're in Keyword Planner you can find
new keywords so if I type in for example
you know online marketing and click get
started what the keyword tool is going
to do is give me the data that I need to
do appropriate keyword research it's
going to give me my keyword and similar
keywords it's going to give me the
average monthly volume and the great
thing here is I can actually see the
trend for that keyword over time just by
clicking on this little bar graph so for
digital marketing I can see what the
trend is over time I could see what the
competition is I could see you know if
I'm going to bid on this keyword I could
see what the bidding range is so more
important I can see the volume and I can
see the competition here's my volume for
this keyword over the last 12 months on
average and here's my competition so
Google's Keyword Planner gives you the
necessary information you need to choose
relevant keywords wisely now there are
other tools out there that are paid that
help you look for Relevant keywords like
SCM rush or keyword finder that's a
premium tool so there are plenty of
tools available to you you know another
tool I use that's not listed here is Moz
so if you just type a keyword let's just
type in the same keyword like online
marketing for example okay so what Moz
is going to do is going to give me some
volume it's going to give me some other
keyword suggestions okay it's going to
tell me how difficult that keyword is
and it's going to tell me who else is
ranking for that keyword so it gives me
again all the relative information I
need including competitive information
so you can use these these keyword tools
Moz is freemium some are paid some are
free there's plenty of tools out there
but these are the ones I would recommend
for keyword research now let's turn our
attention to technical SEO so for
technical SEO you're going to need to
use some tools there's no getting around
that because you want to be able to
monitor how your website's performing I
mean is it loading slow for example does
it have a lot of uh issues with the webs
side in terms of uh server side
rendering for example or server response
time what about four fours and redirects
so you want to be able to gather a lot
of the technical information that could
Aid or prohibit your site from ranking
so you want to be able to also you know
look at what the Bots are seeing and how
they're viewing your website so if
Google goes to craw your site are they
experiencing you know a slow server
response time or they experiencing Pages
not found you also want to see if you
have sitemap you know what's the s map
are these Bots crawling your site or
getting the pages from a Sit map again
you want to be able to lean on some of
these tools to help you fix errors that
you may encounter like metatags or 44s
or canonical so you need a good tool to
help you manage all that and so I'm
going to go back to M starting out so if
we go back to MZ MZ is a good tool it's
an allinone it's a great SEO platform so
if I go to MZ and I log into an account
I can just go to site crawl and so what
MZ is going to do it's going to give me
a lot of information about how moz's bot
is seeing my site okay so if I go to the
site crawl I can look at all the
particular critical uh issues that have
experienced so I can see four for erors
okay REITs related to that I can see
Meta descriptions missing meta
descriptions duplicate content so
there's a lot of different issues that
Moz is detecting for this particular
site and the great thing about Moz and
this is why I use mods as my SEO
platform I don't work for mods I've just
used them a long time is if you do have
issues then they give you ways to fix it
the how to fix it section so if I see me
missing description here if I just click
on review and get a more indepth
analysis as to what the issues are here
but I can also click on the why and how
to fix okay and they're going to give
you some information about how this is
impacting SEO and what you could do to
fix the issue they out the issues pretty
prominently here you can see for all the
metadata issues I have I have you know
142 total metadata issues I have 10
title tag to Longs I have 122 missing
meta descriptions so they lay it out
nicely here up the top so you can kind
of get a sense of what to work on and
again they prioritize it based on the
severity of the issue and then they
break it down into several categories
for example I just looked at metadata
issues you could see if I click on
content issues I have some duplicate
content that Moz is recognizing or
missing or valid H tags so Moz does a
really really great job blinging all all
the issues out for you to recognize okay
there's another tool that I like to use
called screaming frog it's a pay tool so
if we go look here great thing I like
about uh a screaming frog it will crawl
your site and it will give you some list
of issues just like Maz does of you know
what it's in your site is it
experiencing four fours broken links are
there any redirects it's picking up
duplicate content site Maps you know
their drava script issues how does it
see the site architecture so it really
does take a deep look at everything that
could impact your website from ranking
okay there are other tools out there
like you know deep crawl or woo rank
they're both paid and so pay tools are
really great as well it just depends on
you know your pricing structure what
your budget is but really when it comes
to all these tools they all more or less
overlap and do the same thing you just
need to rely on one of them to make sure
that you're able to see what the issues
are now there's nothing wrong with using
two of them just as a second reference
point to see if both are picking up the
same issue and of course I like to use
search console I always like to lean on
Google search console because that is
the source so search console will also
you know give you some feedback on how
Google Google's bot is crawling your
site so that's under the crawl error
section here so you can also you know
use search console to upload a site map
so that's a key to SEO you want Google
to be able to find your web pages
quickly so you can simply just uh
signify to Google where your site map is
located so the search console does a lot
more gives you some HTML improvements
gives you some backlinking uh and then
the process of updating the search
console user interface so there's a new
user interface that you can use with
Google search console the great thing is
it's free and it has everything you need
to know about your website and how it's
affected by SEO organic search the only
thing you have to do with search console
is verify the site but once you verify
it it has all the relevant information
you need so let's talk about backlink
monitoring and Analysis okay so this is
related to off-page SEO so you're going
to need a good tool to help you monitor
your website backlinks and backlinks are
simply just links from external sites
pointing to your site and you need to
keep an eye on what sites are linking to
yours are they spammy related sites are
they good relevant sites or anything in
between so you need to really be able to
analyze what the good links are and what
the bad links are pointing to your
website you want to identify and disavow
Port pack links okay so you want to be
able to recognize which sites are
linking to yours that's actually hurting
you from an SEO standpoint and you want
to be able to do something about that
okay you want to measure citation flow
and Trust flow you want to check the
ratio of Link distribution in terms of
is it internal or external or you know
what kind of sites are linking to my
site are they you know social related
are they pure content related and then
you want to be able to track the number
of do follow and no follow links you
know how many links pointing to our site
are actually telling Google and other
Bots not to follow the link or how many
are actually allowing the Bots to follow
that link if a bot follows a link it's
going to pass what we call link juice so
you're going to get credit for the
backlink if it's a no follow you're not
going to get credit for the backlink and
we want to be able to measure that and
so we want to have tools that will help
us do that so what are some of those
tools well HRS is a good tool it's a
pain tool Majestic is a fremium tool M
again Moz is the tool I use SC rush and
then again I got to mention Google
search console so this take a look at
some of these tools in terms of backlink
monitoring and Analysis so let's start
with Google search console again it's
free you just have to verify your site
and so if I go to Google Search console
I can look at links and I can see what
external links I have pointing to my
site okay so I could see I have 177,000
in this example pointing to the homepage
of this particular site okay so if I
click on that I can see all the the top
sites pointing to my homepage now from
an off-page SEO perspective do you want
every back link or external link
pointing to your homepage no so you want
links pointing to internal pages so you
want to be able to measure that so I
could see what the top linking sites are
and I could also see what the anchor
text is so do I want my anchor text
always to be my brand name no I want it
to be you know keyword we're trying to
Target search console also gives you
some internal links okay what are the
top link Pages for internal links so
from an SEO perspective you always want
to have a nice balance of internal
linking so this report helps you
understand what pages are getting links
and are the links evenly spread so this
is Google search console this is the
links report this is totally free this
is provided by Google all you have to do
is verify your site now if we go over to
Moz we type in a domain any domain so I
just typed in simply and learn okay MZ
has some metrics that are important to
off-page SEO including domain Authority
so the higher your domain author the
better off you are and so what helps a
domain Authority grow is how many
quality links are pointing to that
domain and so here we could see over
7,500 linking domains to Simply learn so
what's important is we just don't want
any site we want quality relevant sites
pointed okay so we could see how many
total inbound links and then how many
ranking keywords we have okay so here
Moz is going to give me kind of an idea
of what my domain Authority has has been
over time they're going to tell me the
top fold links to the site so they're
going to tell me you know what are those
links pointing to my site and what's the
page authority of those sites okay here
I can get a nice graphical breakdown of
the linking domains by domain Authority
so you want pages with high domain
Authority pointing to your site so here
I can see 69 linking domains between 91
and 100 so that's really good we want
High relevant domains link to our site
so just like search console I can see
the top anchor text being used okay and
I can see the top pages that have you
know good page Authority on the site I
could see following versus no follow on
internal and external links so this is
just the overview so Moz really really
does break down for you you know what
those pages and linking domains are so
if I just click on linking domains now I
could get a detailed look for my
homepage what domains are pointing to
our domain so I can see microsoft.com
has a domain authority of 100 YouTube 99
and so not only does moss provide you
with the domains it also provides you
with their domain Authority score and
spam score so you want to keep an eye on
any particular site that has a high spam
score so having a site with a high spam
score and a low domain Authority will
hurt your domain and Page Authority for
that page so M does a great job of
breaking out and this is for any page it
doesn't necessarily have to be the
homepage okay if I take a look at
another example here Majestic so
Majestic again I can use a free version
of the tool they have their own metrics
citation flow trust flow so when they
say trust flow what's the link quality
all about okay citation flow what's the
link volume and they can get an idea of
how many external back links are
pointing to the site and what's the
trend on that referring domains so
Majestic does does a really good job
again some of the same metrics that we
could see here except they go into
detail about languages as well so this
is majestic and you got search console
you got a lot of other tools and then
I'm going to just revert back to Moz
because you want to be able to compare
link profiles if you're in a competitive
space and you're doing off-page SEO you
know Moz will help you compare how your
site stands against maybe another
competitive site or relevant site so
just doing this analysis I can compare
my domain Authority spam score how many
total links you know how many external
followed links or external no followed
links got breakdown of linking domains
so it does a nice job of comparing one
site versus another that's going back to
MZ and that's what you want you want a
good tool that's going to help you do
that I mean there's other tools out
there not listed like bright Edge that
will also help you compare linking
profiles so at the end of the day if
you're doing off page SEO you want to
get a sense of what sites are linking to
yours are they quality sites are they
spammy what anchor text are they using
are they no follow are they do follow
you know are they top domains how do you
compare against your competitors I mean
all these metrics are related to
off-page SEO so you want a good tool
that's going to help you measure this
okay so let's talk about rank tracking
so when we do keyword research we're
looking for Relevant keywords we find
our relevant keywords we assign primary
and secondary keywords to page we
optimize those pages we do off-page SEO
and we do an all this work for SEO okay
we want to be able to measure the fruits
of our labor we want to be able to
measure how we perform for on and off
page SEO for the keywords we cover and
the pages they're related to and so
that's where rank tracking comes into
play so we want to be able to track our
website's ranking and not just our
website all the pages we've optimized we
want to be able to measure our
clickthrough rates and Impressions we
want to be able to track the ranking for
both desktop and mobile for specific
locations and we want to identify top
performing gaining and losing keywords
so in other words we want to look at
Trends is a keyword ranking is it going
up in ranking is it going down in
ranking if it's going down in ranking
then you need to take action so you need
a tool a good tool for rank tracking so
we can look no further than again Google
search console it's free it's right from
the source so let's take a look at what
Google search console has to offer in
terms of rank tracking so if I go to
Google Search console and I put in a URL
what it's going to do is it's going to
give me and this is the search queries
report it's going to give me what
queries people have used to actually
type into google.com and it's going to
be able to tell me how many times my
pages show Pages showed up for that
query it could be more than one page
that's an impression and if I did
receive an impression meaning did my
page show up in the organic listing then
did I get a click as a result and so in
this case if I got 68 Impressions and 10
clicks for keyword somebody typed in
that's a 14.7% clickthrough rate and so
what search console will also do is say
hey look for that particular keyword you
appeared on average in position 4.1 so
it gives you really good insight as to
you know what people are typing in and
how you're being found for those
keywords it breaks it down by Pages it
breaks it down by country breaks it down
by device device so I could see you know
mobile I had
899 Impressions over the last 3 months
on mobile and I received 33 clicks as a
result my average position on mobile was
2.6 so search console does a really good
job again this is free information of
providing you the actual keyword
somebody's using on Google search as a
query and how many Impressions you're
receiving for that keyword how many
clicks click the rate and then average
position so in theory the higher you are
positioned on Google the more clicks
you're going to receive so if I'm not
positioned properly for keyword let's
just say page two then I'm probably not
going to receive as many clicks as I
would like so that's search console
there are other tools out there like HRS
again does a good job of tracking AMZ
tracker we look at winter so there's
some good tools out there I'm just going
to show you another one again I'm going
to go back to MZ for example so MZ has a
tool called so if I go back into the
account so MOS has a a rankings tool
that you can look at to see where your
keywords are ranking so if you've
already chosen keywords and optimized
Pages for those keywords then you want
to be able to load those keywords in MZ
and so Moz allows you to do that and so
what Moz does they do a crawl once a
week and they'll be able to tell you
where you rank for all your keywords are
we moving up in the rankings are we
moving down how many keywords do we have
ranked between positions one and three
11 through 20 4 through 10 21- 50 so
we'll be able to see where our keywords
Rank and so it gives you a breakdown
here of nationally in the United States
where this keyword is ranked and if it's
moved up or down and for what URL is it
ranked for and so you can label so the
keywords and and this is what you want
to look for in a good tool you want to
be able to organize your keywords and
label them so for all our branded
keywords we want to be able to label
them branded because ideally you don't
want to optimize for your brand keyword
so maybe we want to exclude our brand
keywords and look at our non-brand
keywords in terms of ranking and so you
can certainly add locations and look at
specific locations the whole idea
between a good ranking tool is to be
able to measure you know if a keyword is
trending up or down okay so I can simply
look at a particular keyword and I can
see the trend of that keyword and then
you know if a keyword's not ranking then
we want to wonder why it's not ranking
well is it is it difficult is it not
ranking because of its difficulty or can
we do a better job of optimizing for
that keyword and so Moz also has a page
optimization tool so if you're not
ranking for keyword you can flip over
the page optimization tool then put in
the keyword put in the URL and MZ will
give you some idea as to what you can
further do to optimize the page okay so
that's MZ you know this is HRS so you
can see HRS does the same thing they
provide you some visibility average
position how much traffic you know where
you're ranking in terms of positions 1
through 3 4 through 10 11 through 50 and
so you want to be able to get a sense of
where my track keywords are trending are
they trending up are they trending down
and the whole idea again behind the
ranking tools if you're trending down
you want to be able to address why it's
trending down so you want to start with
on page SEO can we do a better job of
optimizing or off page does that page
need more backlinks so that's why you
need a backlink tool to support your
ranking and HRS does offer up some
competitor information as well so you
can see how your competitors are
performing so these are some good
examples of ranking tools that you could
take advantage of now there are also a
few important SE tools that can be
helpful in different ways for example if
you're doing video so there are some
tools that help you measure how you're
performing via video for example vid IQ
so let's take a look at vid IQ
so if I load in say a video in YouTube
in this example how to rank YouTube
videos I have a vid IQ extension loaded
into my browser in Chrome and so now I
can get a good I sense of how many views
the duration the engagement rate the
like ratio how many people shared it on
Reddit but further I can look at how the
video was optimized so they're telling
me the title's too long here maybe
shorten it up but we have tag we have
descriptions we have cards we have end
screens it's been shared on Facebook it
hasn't been shared on Twitter okay it is
public we do have pinned comments and we
do have hearted comments and so this
gives me an idea of how we did in terms
of optimizing this particular video okay
so if we wanted to tweak it we could
tweak the title tag make it a little bit
shorter to help it rank better on
YouTube so you want to be able to use a
tool like this because if you have
videos then you want want those videos
to rank and so you can certainly watch
this video on how to rank your YouTube
videos and in that video we do allude to
vid IQ so you want to be able to use a
tool like this because you know YouTube
it is a video portal but it's the second
largest search engine behind Google so
if you do have videos you want to be
able to rank for them and you want a
tool that's going to help you measure
and help you understand if you are
ranking if you're not ranking why are
you not ranking now for Content
optimization
there are tools you can use like SCA
site checkup or site analyzer are some
good tools if you already have Moz as an
example just going back to MZ as you
already know I use Moz a lot so they
have a page optimization so you could
check the content and how you're
optimize your content so it's going to
give me some good feedback on you know
is your page title meta description are
they in line okay so it's going to give
you some good feedback on that you also
have again I have to allude to search
console you can always look at a
particular page and search console see
if it has any errors as well so is it
duplicated meta description is it a
duplicated title tag is it any Pages
missing title tags or meta descriptions
so when it comes to content you can look
at search console you can lean on MZ or
you can lean on some of these other paid
versions like site analyzer when it
comes to traffic and metrics look no
further than Google analytics there is a
free version of Google analytics as well
as a paid version so if I go into Google
analytics it's going to tell me all of
my website Behavior okay who's coming to
my site how they got to my site how they
behaved once they went to my site and
are they achieving the goals I set out
for them to achieve via conversions and
so you want to look at first in Google
analytics how much traffic you're
getting so if I go to Google analytics
if I go to acquisition all traffic
channels I should be able to see how
much traffic organic search is driving
over a period of time so I can see how
many users how many sessions then if I
click on landing pages I can see what
landing page they went to so I could see
the homepage over a particular time had
over a th sessions I can also see
engagement from organic search are they
balancing how many pages are they
looking at in the session after they
landed on a particular page are they
staying on the site a long time what's
their duration or are they achieving any
goals so so analytics will provide me
all that information about how organic
search as a channel is performing the
other thing about Google analytics I
like and that goes back to the technical
aspect of SEO and that's sight speed so
if you go to behavior and you go to
sight speed overview you'll be able to
see how my pages are loading what's the
average load time so they'll break it
down for you by browser by country and
by specific page so if I look at page
timings I'll be able to see what page is
loading slow what page is loading quick
compared to site average and so the
great thing about analytics is if I have
a page that's loading slow compared to
site average they'll actually provide me
with some suggestions so if I go to site
speed and speed suggestions what they're
going to do is they're going to have a
link in the report that's going to allow
me to click on it and I'm going to be
able to see what suggestions they can
provide so when this report loads I'll
be able to see what the speed
suggestions are for my pages so here I
can see the page I can see what the
average load time is of that page so for
example this particular page is loading
at 6 seconds ideally we want to have you
know 3 seconds or under maximum so if I
just click on this link here they're
giving me six page speed suggestion so
if I click on that I'm going to go to
another Google tool called page speed
insights and then page speed insights is
going to run for both mobile and desktop
for this particular page and then this
page speed insights report is going to
give me feedback as to what I need to do
to speed up the load time of that page
so here you can see for desktop and
mobile they're going to give me some
suggestions and opportunities so reduce
the server response time properly size
images serve images in next gen formats
so all these will shave off time off my
page load time and so that's what's
going to help me speed up the page load
and that's page being insights you can
get to from the spee suggestions report
and analytics so so in theory the higher
your page low time your chances of
ranking on Google organic search
diminish so Google wants pages that have
very low page load time that load
quickly so Google analytics is a great
tool for Speed suggestions it's a great
tool for finding out what the traffic is
doing on your site how they're engaging
and are they achieving goals now there
are other tools out there from an
organic perspective like keyword it
that's a good keyword research tool for
Reddit so if you go to keyword it you'll
be able to see from a Reddit perspective
what keywords are driving volume these
are just the results but you can put any
keyword in there and get the results of
that keyword SEO is an important part of
the marketing strategy in case your
website doesn't show up on the first
page of the search engine then you need
to work on it to solve all your SEO
related problems we've come up with a
solution welcome to Simply learns
YouTube channel and today we will be be
discussing the top 10 tips that every
marketer needs to know so let's get
started and see the first step the first
step is voice search now voice search
will impact search queries in 2021
according to dialog tech.com
in the United States of America 55% of
the households will have their own smart
speaker by
2022 well that's a lot so if you're
planning to optimize your voice search
consider choosing why
keywords find out longer phrases that
Searchers use in daily life
conversation voice search is a more
suitable way for searching long and more
natural sounding phrases creating
detailed and relevant answers are
essential when optimizing for voice
search so always remember to create
Persona based content next create web
pages that can answer FAQ use because
when Searchers ask a question they begin
their question with words like who when
what however there are many reasons for
using voice search such as dictating
text messages looking for a video on
YouTube calling a person from your
contact list asking for directions Etc
according to Forbes voice search
drastically improves your user
experience due to its extensive use
search engines such as Google are
focusing on voice search optimization
Google's voice search shows websites on
top that load quickly in that case you
must always ensure that your website has
a responsive design its images are
optimized the files are compressed
implementation of website caching is
done properly to improve page speed and
finally the last important Point your
server's response time is
reduced now the second step in the
process is the mobile
optimization now you must already know
how important it is to make your site
mobile friendly for a better user
experience but did you also know that
having a mobile friendly application
impacts your search engine
optimization sem Rush confirms that by
the year
2025 approximately 70% of Internet users
will access the internet through mobile
devices Google's mobile friendly update
has resulted in a big change in search
rankings with the help of Google's free
mobile friendly test have a look at how
effective your mobile website is also
take a peek at the mobile usability
report in Google's search console now
let's talk about tip number three that
is Google's eight principles Google has
confirmed that content quality is an
essential factor for ranking on search
engine result pages but what does
quality mean to Google well content that
fulfills the Google eat principle will
rank higher e stands for expertise
authoritativeness and
trustworthiness these elements will
determine if a web page has a useful
quality content Google uses the
combination of algorithms to deliver the
best results for users Google Panda is
one of the famous algorithms of Google
which emphasizes delivering highquality
content it removes web pages from the
index that have lowquality and duplicate
content not just that there is one more
algorithm called
rankbrain rank brain is a processing
algorithm that uses machine learning to
interpret search queries that users
search on Google whereas the searched
query may not have the right keywords
that were searched
for for example when you're searching
for chocolate cake recipes you will also
get results for chocolate truffle cake
recipes on the search engine results
page Google Panda and rank brain send
Bots to crawl each and every website and
as a result shows high quality content
on the top of the search engine results
page next is our tip number four
featured
snippet these results are featured on
the top part of the page Google
programmatically chooses the best answer
from the thirdparty website and displays
it on the featured snippet here's what a
featured snippet looks like according to
ah refs for for a specific search query
almost 99% of web pages shown in the
featured snippet already rank on sep's
first page some of the ways to optimize
featured Snippets are organize your
content in a structured way make sure
one article answers many similar
questions use eye-catching images and
the last point is to create answers with
tables to drive clicks and write
dedicated headings to answer featured
Snippets
like is red meat healthy suppose you
want to create Snippets plan on creating
question-based questions along with the
relevant keywords for ideas you can also
look at the Google search function that
is usually written in the blue color and
it reads out as people also ask so now
let's move to the fifth tip image
optimization according to sem Rush image
optimization will play a prominent role
in search in case the images on your
website aren't optimized make sure to
take care of them right now remember to
use high quality images relevant images
and use a suitable label for your image
file include images in your site map as
it becomes easier for the Bots to crawl
and finally use alt tags as crawlers use
it to classify the images alt text is
displayed on the web page when an image
fails to load on on a user screen it is
also utilized by Google to drive meaning
from images a well optimized image can
improve your page ranking and increase
the engagement on it image optimization
can help your web page show up in the
image carousels on search
engines next we have semantically
related
keywords semantic search will have
become an important factor for ranking
in the future semantic keywords are
linked to the primary keyword
they drive relevant traffic on search
engine result Pages a simple way to look
for LSI keywords is on Google
sep semantic search can be performed
wisely by writing content that targets
the question that your target audience
is looking for remember to optimize
content for topic clusters instead of
focusing solely on keywords and finally
use structured data and pick your
semantic keywords this can also be done
with the help of a comprehensive keyword
tool it finds out semantically related
keywords next comes tip number seven
building quality links building quality
links to your website is important if
you are aiming to manage a successful
and long-term SEO strategy building
quality links cannot be ignored in 2016
Google declared that building quality
links are one of their top three ranking
signals always opt for quality over
quantity as building quality links to
your content can give your product and
category Pages a boost in
scps let me share a few effective
strategies that will increase the number
of links pointing to your website
dramatically the first one earn back
links from relevant and authoritative
web pages next promote your content
regularly on social media
up for guest blogging and influencer
marketing next take advantage of social
media platforms like Facebook Twitter
Instagram and start your own page then
participate in forums to engage with
your target audience start your blog and
attract your target audience with your
valuable content finally get listed in
the highquality link directories this
will help you build links from
authoritative
websites next number eight is local
search
listings local SEO is the practice of
optimizing a website in order to obtain
traffic from location-based searching it
is the best way to Market your products
and services to local
customers according to Google local
results are based on relevance distance
and prominence these factors help Google
to find the best match for your search
for this reason it becomes important to
to have your nap details accurate and
consistent across the
internet sem Rush confirms that local
search listings will play a larger role
in the SEO
strategies suppose you want to know how
to get your business in the local pack
go to Google my business page and create
your own for this it is also important
to have a strong backlink
profile next we have number nine that is
improve the user experience for the past
few years ux has become an important
ranking factor for Google however more
and more SEO Specialists have gained an
interest in
ux ux optimization is nothing more than
focusing on the visitor consider the
partnership of search engine
optimization and user
experience this way the search engine
optimization focuses on search engines
and user experience exp erience targets
website visitors so both share a common
goal of giving users the best result
this is what the content King app says
about the user
experience let me show you a few
practices on how to effectively leverage
ux designs to provide your site's SEO
performance simplify your sit's
navigation a good site architecture
helps to gain traffic utilize ux design
to to SEO friendly layouts which means
make content easy to digest infused
images and videos whenever possible use
ctas very
wisely and finally optimize for Sight
load speed optimize for mobile
responsive design as more than 50% of
all the traffic is now driven by mobile
search in case your site isn't mobile
responsive you will notice poor
engagement and finally we come to our
10th and last
tip that is using schema
markup according to search metrics 36%
of Search keywords bring up at least one
feature snippet that is derived from
schema markup schemo markup is Micro
Data that every individual can add to
his website in order to give an enhanced
description to users on a search engine
results page in simple words words
schema markup is used to define website
content adding structured data will give
your website a significant SEO boost and
increase your
rankings some of the schema markup
examples are ratings and reviews image
thumbnails product availability and
finally site links adding schema markup
to your HTML is one of the ranking
factors hello everyone welcome to this
new video by simply learn search engine
optimization has been playing an
essential role in the success of various
businesses for those who are still
looking for growth in the industry and
have search engine optimization
otherwise known as SEO as their primary
weapon then yes you are in the right
place this video on how to rank number
one on Google will give you the best
tips to get a higher ranking without
spending a penny but before we begin
subscribe to our Channel simply learn
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn so before we
begin I have a question for you the
process of getting the quality and
quantity of traffic to your website
organically is known as search engine
marketing search engine optimization
search engine advertising or none of the
above let me know your answers in the
comments section Below in this video
first we will understand why it's
essential to rank high in search engines
next we will have a look at the top five
mantras on how to get ranked number one
on Google search result pages and while
understanding this we will put a light
on why these success tips are important
for getting a good ranking and how we
can actually implement it we will share
some necessary tools to help you carry
out the needed process and stick to the
end of this video to find out the one
thing that can impact your business
tfold so definitely we're going to take
a look at the best tips for ranking high
on Google but before that
it is necessary to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google well we
are all aware that most of the
businesses are shifting online nowadays
ranking on search engines has become one
of the most important aspects that
Define the success of a business the
data states that around
1.17 billion people across the globe use
Google search which is estimated to
increase exponentially in the coming
years moreover Google has gained the
trust of their users with their services
over over the years this definitely
makes the point of interest to
understand why it's important to rank
high on Google search ranking at the top
of search engine result pages also known
as Surs allows a business to generate
more traffic to their website and
possibly get more leads by which then
they can get a chance to convert leads
into customers thereby boosting sales it
also helps in generating authenticity
for your business well not one or two
there are new numerous reasons which
makes SEO important to know more about
SEO check the complete playlist on SEO
you can find the link to the playlist in
the description box below to gain
expertise in search engine optimization
get certified as a skilled SEO
professional with simply learns search
engine optimization training course you
can check the course details from the
link in the description box below as we
know how important it is to rank high on
Google so in the next 10 minutes let's
get to know the top five success mod
cont that will help you rank high in
Google so the fifth tip on our list is
promote your content whether you are a
business owner or a blogger you
definitely need to promote your content
to get a good audience reach by content
here we mean data on your website that
can be products services or even a
simple blog to do this find the relevant
groups on the social media platforms
like Facebook or Instagram and post your
content with an excellent call to action
context so blogging or article
submission sites like Kora Tumblr and
hub pages may also prove helpful online
forums and communities can be a good
option to spread a word about your
content with people having similar
interests let's focus on our number four
tip internal linking a good site
architecture is always a happy bite for
webcrawlers a website with good site
architecture and internal linking helps
webcrawlers understand the website
structure and helps them to crawl the
site more effectively the more the pages
of your website are crawled greater are
the chances of getting indexed if pages
are successfully indexed they get
eligible for appearing in the search
results let's move to our tip number
three yes it is backlink building any
website linking to your website is a
backlink for your website websites with
more backlinks suggest to the search
engine crawlers that that website has
good content and is trustworthy and
should be ranked higher on the search
results pages to get a backlink the most
important thing is to understand that
the da or the domain authority of the
website for which you are looking for
the backlink is greater than yours
getting backlinks is somewhat entirely a
gesture of Goodwill you can find a page
relevant to your business and ask the
website owner to add the link to your
website to the page in a humble manner
you can create a better or updated
version of some other web content let
the site owner know about it and then
ask for a backlink in a humble way yes
you can find some more relevant backlink
building techniques in the video how to
build backlinks check out the link in
the description box below at number two
we have a tip which is of utmost
importance to win a good position in the
search results onpage optimization
onpage optimization or also known as
onpage SEO is a process in which we take
essential measures to improve the
website or web Page's position in engine
rankings onpage optimization is a vast
concept that includes technical
optimization of websites like server
speed page loading speed removing page
errors submitting Pages for indexing and
more maintaining a good website
structure and improving it adding
internal and external links on the site
adding SEO optimized images and video on
the page efficient use of keywords on
the page and links and much more get the
detail guide to learning onpage
optimization ation by simply learn check
the link in the description box below
and finally the best tip we have is the
most effective one and the one that
rules them all which is keyword research
keyword research is a process of
identifying and implementing the
relevant keywords for the content you
tend to create proper keyword research
may prove a boon to your business but it
also has the power to ruin your business
so be wise When selecting your keywords
try choosing longtail words if you are
new to the business as these are easier
to rank for you can look at Google's
Autos suggest feature to understand what
people are looking for in your industry
be updated with what your competitors
are doing if something is working for
your competitor there are high chances
that it may work for you as well you can
also take the help of various keyword
research tools like Google's own Keyword
Planner answer the public tool Google
Trends and Etc these fantastic and 100%
practical tips can drive drive your
business to Heights make sure you
implement all these tips with more
detailed attention as SEO can make and
break you so what according to you is
the most effective way to grow your
business online let us know in the
comments Below in a world where a
dedicated managers struggle to meet
sales Target due to a lack of product
awareness the Need For Change became
evident enter the Su expert a
professional hired to transform the game
tasked with making the product more
visible and enticing to potential
customers the SEO expert delved into the
realm of blog SEO so what is blog SEO
blog SEO or search engine optimizations
refers to the practices and techniques
employed to enhance blogs visibility on
search engines search engine result
Pages or in other words it refers to the
process of optimizing your blog content
to make it more visible and rank higher
in search engine results by implementing
VAR ious SEO techniques bloggers can
attract organic traffic to their
websites thereby increasing their online
presence and reaching a wider audience
the ultimate goal is to make the blog
more accessible and appealing to both
search engines and human readers as
search engines constantly evolve staying
updated with the latest SEO practices is
crucial for maintaining and improving a
blog's search visibility now let's
explore the importance of blog SEO why
is blog SEO important so blog SEO is
crucial for several reasons first one is
improved visibility blog SEO enhances
the chances of your blog appearing in
top positions on search engine result
Pages scps increasing the likelihood of
users discovering and visiting your blog
second is increase traffic and
engagement higher visibility in search
results can lead to influx of organic
traffic as users are more likely to
click on the links that appear at the
top of the search results this increased
traffic can also result in higher
engagement with your content next is
enhanced user experience ASU
optimization often involves improving
the overall user experience of your blog
such as faster loading times mobile
making it more userfriendly and
accessible next is attraction of quality
backlinks well optimized blogs are more
likely to attract quality backlinks from
other reputable websites these backlinks
serve as a vote of confidence in the
eyes of search engines contributing to
the blog's authority and credibility so
this was something about the importance
of blog SEO all right now let's
understand how to optimize your blog for
SEO optimizing your blog for search
engines is essential for increasing its
visibility and attraction organic
traffic Etc by implementing effective
SEO strategies you can improve your
blogs chances of ranking higher in
search engine results first is obs
observing Google search results one of
the first step in optimizing your blog
for SEO is to observe Google search
results analyze the top ranking blogs in
your Niche and identify the keywords and
content structure that are driving their
success this will provide valuable
insights into the type of content that
resonates with your target audience and
the SEO strategies that are working
effectively next is finding keywords for
each post keyword research is a
fundamental aspect of blog SE identify
relevant keywords and phrases that are
commonly searched by your target
audience tools like Google Keyword
Planner sem rush and AHS that is
ahrefs can help you discover high value
keywords with reasonable search volumes
and low competition incorporating these
keywords strategically into your blog
post can significantly improve their
visibility in search results all right
now the third is optimizing your blog
post when creating blog post ensure that
they are well structured and and contain
high quality relevant content use
headings subheadings and bullet points
to organize your content and make it
more readable additionally optimize your
images by using descriptive file names
and ALT tags to improve their visibility
in image search results following this
there is title and tags craft compiling
and relevant titles for your blog post
incorporating primary keywords to
attract both readers and search engines
furthermore utilize meta tags including
meta descriptions and meta titles to
provide concise summaries of your
content and entice users to click
through to your blog next one is on page
and off-page optimization on page
optimization involves optimizing
individual web pages to improve their
search engine rankings this includes
optimizing metatags internal linking and
ensuring a seamless user experience
off-page optimization on the other hand
focuses on building back links from
reputable web webs sites social media
promotion and other external factors
that can influence your blog search
engine rankings following this we have
backlinks acquiring high quality
backlinks from authorized websites is
crucial for improving your blog's SE
backlinks from reputable sources act as
a vote of confidence in the eyes of
search engines signaling The credibility
and relevance of your content to attract
these valuable backlinks focus on
creating content that is not only
informative and engaging but also
sharable content that provides unique
insights addresses common challenges or
offers innovative solutions is more
likely to be linked to by other websites
in addition to creating compelling
content engaging Outreach efforts can
significantly boost your backlink
profile building relationship with other
bloggers and website owners in your
Niche can led to collaborative
opportunities and natural backlink
placements at last we have internal
links utilizing internal linking to
connect related content within your blog
this not only helps users navigate your
websites more effectively but also
distributes link Equity throughout your
blog improving the visibility of
individual post and Pages blogging in
SEO is a powerful tool for enhancing the
visibility and reach of your blog by
implementing the strategies outlined
above bloggers can optimize their
content for search engines attract
organic traffic and establish their blog
as a valuable resource within their
Niche embracing blog SEO is essential
for staying competitive in digital
landscape and maximizing the impact of
your blogging efforts so YouTube SEO or
search engine optimization is the
process of optimizing your YouTube
videos to rank higher in search results
and gain more visibility it involves
using relevant keywords creating
compelling video titles descriptions and
tags and encouraging user engagement
YouTube SEO is crucial because it helps
your videos get discovered by wider
audience did you know that 70% of what
people watch on YouTube is Det Mind by
its recommendation algorithm this
staggering statistic highlights the
significance of optimizing your content
to align with the YouTube's algorithms
when people search for content on
YouTube the platform uses an algorithm
to determine which videos to show by
optimizing your videos you increase the
chances of your content appearing in
search results and suggested videos
attracting more viewers by incorporating
an optimal number of tags in your videos
typically ranging between 31 and 40 you
can boost views up to by
89% ultimately effective YouTube SEO can
boost your videos visibility increase
organic traffic and help you grow your
channel by reaching a larger audience
furthermore YouTube SEO involves
understanding viewer behavior and
creating content that keeps audience
engaged factors like watch time click-
through rate and user interaction impact
how YouTube Ranks videos to enhance SEO
consider creating compelling thumbnails
and crafting engaging video
introductions consistent Y in uploading
content and building a loyal subscriber
base also play pivotal roles now let's
have a look at the overview of key
elements of YouTube Su so key elements
like video titles descriptions tags and
thumbnails are critical components of
effective YouTube content
optimization so let's understand these
first video titles a video title is like
a headline it should be attention
grabbing and contain relevant keywords
to help both viewers and YouTube
algorithm
understand the video's content a
well-crafted title can significantly
impact whether users decide to click and
watch the next is description so the
video description is an opportunity to
provide more details about your content
include relevant keywords naturally add
links to related content or external
sites and use the description to engage
with your audience YouTube often looks
at the section to understand the context
of your video all right now the thir
third one is TXS TXS are like labels
that help categorize your video they
consist of keywords related to your
content using accurate and popular tags
can increase the likelihood of your
video appearing in search results and
recommended video lists and the last one
is thumbnails thumbnails also play a
very important role thumbnails are the
visual representation of your video a
compelling thumbnail can attract
attention prompting users to click on
your video use clear and high quality
images and consider adding text that
hints add the video's content thumbnails
play a crucial role in The Click through
trate by optimizing these key elements
Creator increases the chances of their
videos being discovered and clicked on
by a broader audience so this was about
the key elements of YouTube SEO now
let's understand the role of tags in
YouTube SEO so in YouTube SEO tags play
a crucial role in enhancing a videos
discoverability and reach tags are
essential descriptive keywords that you
associate with your video content here's
how they contribute to optimizing your
videos first is categorization and
context tags help YouTube categorize and
understand the context of your video
when users search for Content or when
the algorithm suggest videos it relies
on tags to identify and recommend videos
that are relevant to the user's query
and second is search engine ranking tags
contribute to your videoos position in
YouTube search results using relevant
and specific tags increase the
likelihood of your video appearing when
users searches for Content related to
your text all right now the third one is
related video recommendations YouTube
uses tags to determine which videos are
related to each other well choosen tags
can lead to your video being suggested
to viewers watching content similar to
yours this expands the potential
audience for your videos the next is
optimizing for Trends and topics tags
can be adjusted to align with current
trends or popular topics this can help
your video write the way of trending
searches making it more likely to be
seen by a larger audience so this was
about the roles of tags in YouTube SEO
so now let's understand practically how
to use chat gbt for YouTube SEO all
right so first of all let's navigate to
Google and search for
aipm so this is the first link that will
appear all we have to do is to just
click on that visit this link and as you
can see it is an extension so aipm for
chat GPD is an extension so you will
have to click on this add to Chrome ADD
extension all
right so as you can see chat GPT
is is opening and this is what we can
see human written 100% unique as you
optimized article so this is basically
AI PRM extension that helps us do all
these tasks they are pre-written prompts
and we can use these prompts to write
whatsoever we want we can also select
from these topics what we can do what we
want to do like copywriting devops
generative AI marketing Etc activity
ideation keywords slink building
marketing Etc
Outreach then we can also sort it by a
top vs trending model not specific we
can use all of these so basically they
are pre-written prompts so you don't
have to write the complete prompt over
here you can also select from these
prompts and as you can see there are a
lot of prompts one showing 1 to 12 there
are total 1,5 prompts so we can also
navigate from previous and next all
right so now what we can do is basically
we'll have to do a YouTube SEO using
chat GPT so first of all we can select
SEO usually it is on by default it is on
all we can select SEO first of all now
uh we'll go to
search wait a minute you can go to
keywords as well now we can can select
search and we can type
YouTube seu all right so these all
prompts are appearing so this prompt has
370k so this means 370k people have seen
this or you used this then there is
YouTube SEO template 4.2k YouTube SEO
keyword template 3.9k so we basically
want to use this one only because this
prompt this pre-written prompt is
providing us create 15 SU
clickbait YouTube titles so it will give
us 15 clickbait titles for YouTube
YouTube description it will write
YouTube tags it will provide and YouTube
hashtags as well so there are pretty
more as well as you can see in just one
click all right so we basically will
click on this and select so this prompt
is basically have selected so now all we
have to do is write the seed keyword or
write the keyword on which we want to do
YouTube SEO so let let's say the seat ke
is
MBA
in MBA in
USA so let's see what this will
create all
right beginning middle and end all right
so it is also telling us the best title
to pick from all these that is beginning
middle and end so mastering MBA in USA
Insider tips and tricks all right so
this title combines Authority mastering
relevance MBA in USA and Intrigue
Insider tips and tricks making it
compelling and likely to track clicks so
it is also telling us how they are
selecting this title as the best title
so they have written that this title
combines Authority relevance and the
Intrigue Insider tips and tricks making
it compelling and light to track clicks
all right and this is also YouTube
description as they have written in the
prompt so welcome to ultimate guide on
achieving an MBA in USA in this
comprehensive video we will delve deep
into strategy Secrets how professionally
they have written this description we
can see and don't miss out the insights
that can transform your dreams into
reality subscribe now for more valuable
content on educational persuades and
career growth so they have written a
perfect description that will also
contain all the relevant keywords so
that the videos get ranked and when it
comes to hashtags as as we can see MBA
in USA success strategies mastering MBA
Career Development USA study guide
Insider tips future leadership Etc all
right so this was about the hashtags and
now let's come to the tags that is the
important part also MBA in USA success
strategies they have separated each of
the Texs with commas so you can use and
select on your own whichsoever you want
to select so they have written quite a
few of tags we can select from these all
so they have provided us tags hashtag
best title pick to pick and we can also
select from these as per our choice but
they have basically created a best title
from all of these and these are the
descriptions that we can use so what
else do we need to do YouTube SEO so you
can just take a help from this extension
of chat GPT and you can use and do the
YouTube SEO using the chat gbt all right
so let's do another one all right so new
chat let's do again SEO keywords you can
select YouTube SEO all right so again
we'll click on this prompt YouTube SEO
title description with text generator so
this is basically giving us all of these
things that we want and let's write this
time the seed keyword would be let's say
cat
preparation let's
see so beginning keywords I mean
beginning title middle and end so best
title is your success awaits dive into
effective cat preparation this title not
only promises success but also
encourages immediate action making it
compelling for viewers so this is the
description welcome to transformative
journey in cat preparation in this video
we will delve into the effective
strategies to boost your scores and
elevate your skills all right so these
are the hashtags cat preparation success
mastering cat exam tips cat preparation
strategies Etc these are the hashtag
that we can use and these are again the
tags so we can select the tags as per
our choice what all things we are
covering and what all things we want to
include in our video so we can take a
help of this extension of chat gbt and
do our YouTube SEO so this is how you
can do YouTube SEO using the chat GPT
what is technical SEO so technical SE is
like making sure your website is easy
for search engines like Google to read
and understand just like you organize a
book with chapters and a table of
contents to make it easier to navigate
technical SEO involves organizing your
website so that search engines can
easily find and show your web pages to
people searching for information this
includes making your website load
quickly fixing any errors that might
prevent search engines from reading your
site using special tags to highlight
important information and making sure
your website works well on mobile
devices all of these things help your
website show up higher in the search
results and make it easier for people to
find what they are looking for site
speed is also crucial in this just as
people prefer fast loading websites
search engine prioritize websites that
load quickly fixing crawl errors is like
repairing broken links in a book it
ensures that search engines can access
and understand all the content on your
website without any UPS now just a quick
info for you all right now let's
understand why should you optimize your
site so let's have a look at the first
reason which is improved search engine
ranking search engines reward well
optimized websites with higher rankings
technical SE ures that search engines
can easily understand and navigate your
site contributing to better visibility
and ranking next is enhanced user
experience technical SEO is not just
about pleasing search engines it also
improves the user experience fast
loading Pages mobile responsiveness and
secure connections all contribute to
positive user experience which can
impact your site's bounce rate and
overall engagement the next is
competitive Advantage as the digital
landscape becomes increasingly
competitive technical optimization can
provide a distinct Advantage websites
that load quickly are mobile friendly
and have secure connections are more
likely to attract and retain Visitors by
doing these you can attract more organ
organic traffic enhance user engagement
and ultimately achieve your online goals
more effectively now coming to the next
part which is key metrics so there are
several key metrics that website owners
should track to ensure their pages are
optimized these include sight speed
mobile friendliness crawl errors index
coverage structure data implementation
and overall website Health monitoring
these metrics allows for identification
of potential issues and the
implementation of necessary improvements
to maintain an optimized website all
right so this was about key metrics now
let's move on to the next topic which is
crawling so crawling is a process by
which search engine Bots that is also
known as spiders or crawlers navigate
the web discovering and collecting
information from websites the efficiency
of crawling directly influences how well
search engines can index and rank a site
when a search engine bought visits a
website it follows links from one page
to to another collecting information
about each page it encounters though the
technical SEO website owners can ensure
that their site is easily crawlable by
search engine Bots this involves
creating a clear site structure
optimizing internal linking and
utilizing tools such as robots.txt and
XML site maps to guide crawlers through
the site efficiently next is indexing
indexing is the process by which search
engines organize and Store The
information collected during trolling
it's like the search engines way of
creating a detailed catalog of all the
web pages it has form a well index sites
ensures that search engines can quickly
retrieve and display relevant
information to users when they enter a
search query this process is crucial for
ensuring that the right web pages are
shown to users when they search for
specific topics or keywords all right
now this was about indexing now let's
understand about crawling and
indexing all right so understanding
crawling and indexing so before search
engines can answer a search query they
first go through the calling process to
find publicly available web pages to add
to their innex this is like their way of
discovering and collecting information
from all over the Internet during The
Crawling process search engines boards
follow links from one page to another
discovering new content and updating
their index with the latest information
available on the web once the crawling
is done the search engine organizes
sorts and stores the information to find
it in the database which is called the
index this index is like a huge library
of web pages and it's what the search
engine uses to quickly find the right
information when someone searches for
something during The Crawling process
search engine boards also pay attention
to the instructions provided in the
robots.txt file which tells them which
page they are allowed to crawl and index
on a website additionally web Masters
can use a known no index tag in the HTML
code of a web page to instruct search
engine boards not to include that
particular page in their Index this
allows website owners to control which
pages are made available to users
through search engine results these
mechanisms help website owners manage
how their content is discovered and
indexed by search engines all right so
this was about crawling and indexing now
now let's move on to the next topic
which is technical SEO best practices so
first one on the list is on page
optimization so optimize your website on
web page elements such as title tags
meta descriptions headings and image alt
text to make it easier for search
engines to understand the content of
your web pages so second thing that is
the second practice for technical SEO
that you can do is mobile friendliness
ensure that your website is optimized
for mobile devices as mobile
friendliness is now a crucial ranking
factor for sege engines so this is
another important factor now the third
practice that we can do for technical
SEO is speed so improve your website's
loading speed as faster loading Pages
tend to rank higher in search results
and provide a better user experience the
next is link building so acquiring high
quality back links from reputable
websites to improve your sit's Authority
and credibility in the eyes of search
engines this also Works in many cases
all right now fifth is analytics and
monitoring using tools like Google
analytics to track your website's
performance monitor keyword rankings and
identifying areas of for improvement so
this is another practice for technical
SEO now sixth one is fix broken pages so
identify and fix any broken links or
pages on a website broken links can
negatively impact user experience and
search engine rankings regular L check
for broken pages and ensure that they
are redirected or fixed promptly next is
duplicate contential shoes avoiding
having a duplicate content on your
website as it can confuse search engines
and impact your sites ranking ensure
that each page on your site offers
unique and valuable content use
canonical tags to indicate the preferred
version of similar content and address
any duplicate content tissues all right
so excluding these duplicate content
issues is also a very important
important factor and it improves your
SEO and site visibility so as we
conclude our journey through technical
SEO we have uncovered the vital
components that shape your website's
visibility in search engine results from
the significance of optimizing your site
through the mechanics of crawling and
indexing understanding these elements is
key to a robust online presence armed
with insights and best practices you are
now better equipped to navigate the
dynamic landscape of technical SE
ensuring your website sites not only
meets but exceeds the expectations of
both users and search engines like today
we have got an essential topic for
anyone diving into the world of websites
how to create a website sitap whether
you're a season Web Master or a total
beginner understanding site Maps is
crucial for improving your site's
visibility on search engines in this
video we will break down what a sitemap
is why it matters for SEO and most
importantly how you can create one of
your own website stick around because by
the end of this tutorial you will
equipped with the knowledge to enhance
your site's performance all right so
let's start with the first one that is
what is a sitemap and why it is
important so sit map is a file that
contains a list of all the pages on a
website it serves as a road map for
search engines to discover and index the
content on a site having a well
structured sitemap is important for
several reasons firstly it helps search
engines understand the or ionization of
your site and prioritize the indexing of
important Brides this can improve the
visibility of your content in search
engine results secondly a Sit map can
also benefit the user experience by
providing an easy way for visitors to
navigate through the site and find the
information they are looking for in
essence a sitemap is like guide that
helps both search engines and visitors
navigate and understand the content of
your website making it an essential tool
for Effective online presence and
visibility so now let's have a look how
it actually looks this is google.com
here let's say We'll type
indianexpress this is a News website
we'll click on it we'll open the website
all right so as we can see this is an
News website the Indian Express all
right so now if we want to have a look
at its sit map sit map all we have to do
is to click on this and slash
sitemap do XML so now this part is
called domain so website domain serves
as the address for a site on the
internet like example.com
the/ site. XML is a specific path where
a sitemap file is St now the sitemap and
example file details the structure and
relationships between pages on a website
when a search engine encounters the/
sitemap.xml extension it fetches the
associated file enabling efficient
indexing and understanding of sites
content this benefits search engine
optimization that is SEO by enhancing
the visibility of the website in search
results organizing the content for
search engines and facilitating
streamlined crawling and indexing
processes all right so now by writing
this we can click enter and as you can
see the XML file now we will be having a
look at the documentary as you can see
this is the XML file so this is
basically basically a XML sit map for
this Indian Express website what is this
XML sit map so uh think of an XML
sitemap as a website road map for search
engines it's like a cheat sheet that
tells search engines all about your web
pages when they were last updated how
important they are and where to find
them like this helps search engines
explore your sites more efficiently like
a GPS for websites by having this map
your site has a better chance of showing
up in search results because search
engines can easily understand and
organize your content so it's like
giving your website a VIP pass to be
noticed and ranked higher in the online
world so this is what XML sitemap is now
if you want to have a look at HTML sit
map then all we have to do is instead of
XML we'll write HTML so as you can see
here this is the HTML format this is a
simple and easy to understand format so
that everyone can easily understand and
go through the entire website what all
links are there so this HTML sit map is
basically a userfriendly guide for
visitors like exploring your website
instead of technical details for search
engines it's a page on your site that
list all the important links and
sections in a clear organized way
imagine it is a visual map visitor can
easily follow to find what they are
looking for a simplified navigation tool
when you have this /sit map. HTML page
it's usually accessible to users
enhancing their experience by providing
a quick overview of your website
structure it's like having a directory
at entrance of a mall making it easy for
everyone to find the desired destination
so it's basically that now the question
is how to create a website's sit map all
right so for that all we have to do is
to just open a website copy the link and
we'll have to paste State at www.
XML sit
maps.com all right so as you can see
this is XML sitem maps.com site is an
official website now all we have to do
is we have to paste the URL over here
all right now online generator Pro
sitemaps PHP script we can ignore this
one and we can click on this start so
this site basically scans the the
website scans the pages of the websites
and create an XML file for you so it
depends on the size of the website how
much time it will take now that XML file
will have to upload that XML file to the
root folder so what we are doing is we
are basically creating the XML sitemap
file and we are downloading it and then
we'll upload it to the root folder after
uploading to the root folder we'll paste
the link on the Google search console so
basically to create an XM sitemap file
we use a sitemap generator tool or
Plugin once generated download the file
and upload it to the root folder of your
website using a FTP client or file
manager after uploading access Google
search console navigate to the sitemap
section and paste the link of the
sitemap file this allows Google to
easily discover and index all the pages
on a website improving its visibility in
search results the third step would be
submit your sitemap now that your site
map has been created and added to your
site files it's time to submit them to
search engines to submit and verify your
websites with Google you'll need to use
the web master tool a cloud-based
software designed specifically for
website owners by Google this tool acts
as a Gateway for submitting your website
to Google search engine it's worth
noting that web master tool has
different versions so you have the
flexibility to choose the one that best
suits your needs even if you prefer the
older vers version it's still accessible
for your use this allows website owners
to manage and optimize their websites
effectively for search engine visibility
now to verify the website start by
visiting the web master tool so first
step is start by visiting the web master
tool next select add property located in
the top left corner all right proceed to
your input your sites URL all right
after submitting once the scanning
process is complete you will rece
receive options for verifying ownership
of the domain to complete the
verification the web master tool will
generate an HTML file download this file
now head to your web host and access the
cpanel file manager navigate to your
domain name file directory all right
after navigating to the domain name
ensure file is uploaded to the root
directory of your domain once the upload
is finished return to the web master
tool and click on verify option Google
will automatically search for the file
on your website once the HTML file is
detected within your domain your domain
name will be successfully verified now
let's talk about the Google search
console in the Google search console
once you're on the search console
dashboard navigate to crawl sit maps all
right select the ADD test sitemap option
located in the top right corner on the
screen this provides an opportunity to
reevaluate your sit map for potential
errors before proceeding naturally any
identified mistakes should be corrected
once your site map is errored free
proceed to click on submit and you are
done so in conclusion leveraging XML sit
Maps whether with the tools like XML sit
maps.com or others is a strategic choice
these digital road maps enhance SEO
streamline navigation and ensure your
websites content shines in the crowded
online realm Embrace this powerful tool
to elevate your online presence and
Captivate both search engines and users
alike first what is Google search
console then we're going to have a
Hands-On demo on how you can register
your website on Google search console
and once we've done that we'll do
another demo where we're going to
explore the various components on Google
search console like properties overview
performance s maps and URL
extensions yep so and you inspections so
are you ready let's get started on this
Google Search console it is a free web
platform provided by Google that allows
website owners to Monitor and manage
their sites search engine results on
Google search including the performance
of individual Pages the performance of
keywords and many other metrics that we
will show you in this demo now it's an
indispensable tool for website owners
for web Masters and for SEO specialist
so in this demo we'll guide you through
practical steps from how to register
your website to Advanced features
enabling you to fully harness the
potential of what Google search console
can do for optimizing your website's
performance in the Google search so
Google search console you may remember
it formerly known as Google Web Master
tools was officially launched on May
20th 2015 although its predecessor
Google Web Master tools had been in
existence since 2006 so here's a brief
history Google Web Master tools
introduced in 2006 help web Masters
Monitor and maintain their sites
presence in Google
search it provided various tools and
reports to assist web Masters in
optimizing their website for search in
May 2015 Google rebranded Google Web
Master tools as Google search console
now the rebranding was done to emphasize
that the tool is not just for web
Masters but for everybody with a website
who wants to improve their visibility on
Google search so it had gone several
updates and improvements over the years
it offers a range of tools and reports
including performance reports index
coverage reports URL inspection tool
sitemap submission Etc all these
features they help you as a website
owner or a marketeer to understand how
your website performs in Google search
and address any issues that might affect
its visibility in Google search and
Google continues to enhance and expand
the capabilities of search console new
features are regularly introduced so it
will give you more more insights into
your website's performance better search
analytics and information about user
experience and with the growing
importance of mobile friendly websites
Google also has placed a strong emphasis
on mobile first indexing so search
consoles provide insights into how
Google Bots View and indexes mobile and
desktop versions of your websites it's
also a very valuable tool for monitoring
the security of your website it notifies
you as the owner about security uh
issues and manual actions taken by
Google allowing you to address and
revoke any problem yeah that may affect
the site search rankings so in summary
Google search result search console has
evolved over the years from an essential
tool for website owners developers and
marketers to an missible tool a very
Advanced tool to help you manage your
search performance on Google it plays a
crucial role in optimizing your website
for search and also very important to
ensure a positive user experience so
these continuous updates from Google yep
and improvements demonstrates Google's
commitment to providing you as a web
master or a website owner with the tools
you need to to succeed in this
everchanging landscape of online
search so there's a lot you can do with
Google search
console yes so again as I mentioned it
is a free web platform provided by
Google that allows you to Monitor and
manage your site search engine results
on Google search so what does it do for
you it provides extensive analytics
about how your site is performing on
Google search
including search results data
Impressions clicks and user engagement
metrics it identifies and fixes issues
that might be affected affecting your
site's visibility on Google search
including search results content errors
URL with duplicate content crawl errors
and site performance
issues and you can request manual
actions and spam reports from Google for
your site and file appeals when you
think Google has made a
mistake so lots that you can do with it
but let's dig a bit deeper let's start
by looking how you can register your
website on Google search console it's a
fundamental step in gaining access to
the wealth of data and insights that can
Propel your sites visibility in the
Google search results the process is
straightforward it is simple and by
following a set of steps you will be
sure that your website is accurately
represented and monitored within the
Google search console platform so let's
go through those step and let's go to
the Google search console
website so to initiate the registration
process navigate to search.
google.com/ iph console slab and if you
don't have a Google account the first
thing you need to do is to create one
and if you have already got an account
you can simply log on best way to get
into it is to click on the start
now yep so when you have started when
you start Google search console you get
to this screen which is your overview
dashboard now we're going to go into
this dashboard in a little while the
first thing I'm going to show you is how
to register your own website here you
see the different websites that I have
registered yeah for my own account but
I'm going to show you how to register
yours now obviously I can't register
your website because I don't have
ownership of your website but I'll show
you the
process so we'll click here on the
little arrow on the top left and we'll
click on ADD property now if you haven't
got a property installed it will
automatically take you to this screen
yeah it will select ask you to select
the property type for the domain or a
URL prefix yep so here you will have a
URL across all your subdomains or it
could only be for the URL under the
entered address so for you to decide how
you want to do this for now I will just
go to click learn more so it gives you
all the details you want to know of how
to add a website
property okay and the process is as
follows you enter your domain as we saw
here yeah then you click
continue and then the next step is that
Google will start verifying if you are
the owner of the domain and in order to
verify your website are a few things uh
that you must do and there are different
roots that you can choose to verify your
domain now to find out about how to
verify your domain yeah here is all the
details about the different website
properties if you want to verify you go
down and then here you see you will be
asked to choose a verification method so
let me show you the verification methods
yeah so it means providing to search
console that you own a specific website
and why is that so important because you
are the owner of the website you don't
want your competitor to get access to
your uh your your Google search console
data yeah so now the most common method
is to download an HTML file and upload
it to your website's root directory on
your uh your host your hosting provider
yep so it's a little bit technical but
if you are a web developer then you know
exactly what we're talking about but
fortunately there are lots of other
methods like adding a metatech to your
site's HTML or even using Google
analytics and often that is one of the
most simple methods yeah so here are the
the different methods there is the HTML
file upload like you download an HTML
file provided by the Google search
console then you upload that file to the
root directory of your website using an
FTP client or through your hostings
provider file
manager you can also do an HTML tag yeah
so you can uh copy the tag that Google
will provide you and you can paste that
metatag into the HTML code of your
website preferably in the header section
and again you can use um directly in the
HTML you can also use Google tag manager
for that and how to do that you can see
in one of the other videos that I made
for simply learn about how to use the
Google tag manager now the easiest
method and that may be maybe enough for
you is to use the the Google analytics
tracking code if you have set up your
website for Google
analytics yeah then it is very simple
you start your Google um search console
you input your website and then when you
click the verification Google will
automatically connect with your Google
analytics check for the tracking code
and it is already done that is the
easiest way to set up your um your
Google uh your Google search console
verification we talked about the Google
tag manager yeah that you can use as
well for the HTML tag you can also go
for the method used by your platform for
instance if you have a WordPress website
then you can get plugin for this where
you can easily connect your website to
the Google search console and there may
also Al be a process through your domain
name provider yeah so the only way to
verify is through your um domain name
provider okay so if it's um if they're
in the verification wizard then that's a
very simple
approach okay and that is um that's it
so once you've verified your website you
can then access the Google search
console and then you can get access to
all the tools and all the
functionalities that you get with your
um with your uh with Google search
console now what you would usually do
after that process you would upload your
sitemap although it's not mandatory for
verification it is highly recommended
it's a file that lists all the pages on
your website helping search engines to
understand the structure and we'll come
back to the sitemap in a little bit and
I'll show you how to upload a um a s map
okay so again once you've entered your
website so let's say
uh let's do see if this
works you click
continue it verifies the
property and then here see the
instructions if you want to do it
through your GoDaddy yep and U that is
where I have my uh my domain hosted my
website hosted yeah then you press the
start verification if it's
already verified yeah you just click
Start
verification it goes through the
process and then I need to sign in
through qu now I'm through my GoDaddy
account now I'm not not going to do this
because I've already registered my
website on um on Google search
console so let's start our second demo
and in this demo we're going to go
through the Google search console
dashboard and it's different components
so back to the console and here again
you see the Google search console with
the dashboard yeah here you see the
command center offering a very high
level summary
of your critical elements after logging
in and selecting your property yeah you
navigate to the overview section to
access the snapshot of your website
performance it gives you total clicks it
gives you Impressions the clickthrough
rate average position like key metrics
that allow you to quickly access the
performance of your site's visibility
and the user engagement so this
dashboard is the starting point for a
deeper orientation on your
website yes so by regular checking this
section you can stay informed about
Trends about patterns enabling you to
make informed decisions about your
ongoing SEO
improvements so let's go to the heart of
this performance report which is the
performance yeah this report shows you
and it gives you detailed insights into
how users interact with your site on
Google search it displays data on clicks
on Impressions on average clickthrough
rate and average
position yep and here you see that over
specific time
ranges yeah so here you see the date for
the last three months and here you
search type it's on the web and here you
see the
statistics by day navigating through
this report it allows you to identify
the high performing Pages the impact of
changes that you make on your website
and then understand user Behavior Yeah
by analyzing this data you can make
informed
decisions that refer to refine your
content strategy focusing on what
resonates best with your uh your uh your
audience yeah again here you see the
queries that are being used here you see
the most popular Pages you see the
countries that are popular here you see
the devices that are being
used yeah so it gives you a full
snapshot of your um of your data and of
your performance of your website you can
see it by Pages you can see video pages
of if you have those so lots of data
that you can get now a very interesting
Port report is the queries so if you
click on the average
position column header you can sort
keywords by their average position from
high to low that helps you identify
which keywords are performing well and
which are not performing well which ones
may need Improvement so you can learn a
lot from this data you can also filter
to refine your data for example you can
set date ranges you can compare
different metrics or you can uh focus on
particular uh keyword performance
sections okay so that's what you can do
with the filter
functionality and if we move on you can
also explore the pages section this
provides Insight how specific pages are
performing on your website including the
associated keywords that come with
them yeah so you can also export the
data yeah so that allows you to analyze
the information offline or share it with
other people so lots of data that you
get here as
well okay an important one that you want
to check as well is your the trends in
your position yeah what's the average
position of your keywords and how they
change over time because that can really
help you assessing the effects of your
SEO activity yeah and you may identify
areas for improvement so by following
these steps you can effectively check
and analyze keyword data in Google
search console yeah man regularly
managing and regularly monitoring this
information helps you to refine your
content and your SEO strategy to better
align this with the user search intent
and improve your website's overall
importance so use that data that you get
in the performance report it's very
valuable and again it summarizes around
the keywords that are being used and the
pages they are the most effective and
the most powerful tools that you get in
this performance report yeah the next
Topic in your reports is the URL
inspection tool which is a Precision
instrument for in understanding how the
Google Bots interprets specific URLs on
your website to use the tool effectively
enter a URL in the search bar and then
Google will provide you insights into
the indexing status the mobile usability
and any issues affecting the url's
appearance in the search results so if
if I put in the URL for the website and
see what it comes back
with
enter yep and you see that the URL is on
Google it can appear in the search
results if I want to see the crawled
page yeah does it uh page change request
indexing if I want to yeah so but the
page has been indexed it is usable on
mobile mobile it is an
https version and there is a site links
search box yes so this URL inspection
has been positive I can test a live URL
and that shows me that to takes me to
the URL so this is how I can inspect and
if the different URLs of my website are
indeed indexed by Google it's
particularly valuable for
troubleshooting and optimizing
individual Pages by addressing any
concerns highlighted in the URL
inspection tool you can ensure that your
content is well represented in the
search results the next one is the
indexing
reports this indexing report is a
comprehensive guide to understand how
well Google has indexed your site yeah
we've seen it that it has indexed in the
URL in inspection but in the indexing
section you can actually see how well
have they done
that it provides a list of all the index
pages but also highlights any issues
that may hinder a proper indexing so
here you see all the index pages and
here you see if there are pages that are
not indexed you may want to see say here
why Pages aren't indexed it allows you
to identify and Rectify issues such as
craw errors no index tags and any other
factors affecting your sites visibility
in the search
results regularly monitoring and
optimizing based on these reports gives
you a healthier and more search engine
friendly website yeah so use that you
can see that for your pages your video
pages and you can also see this for your
s Maps now we talked about sit Maps
earlier they act as a navigational guide
for search engine Growers they provide a
structured road map of your sitemaps of
your site's content and in the section
on the Google search console you can
submit your sitemap you can test it and
optimize your sitemap for efficient
Crawling by Google it's important that
you submit an accurate and upto-date
sitemap so you ensure that the search
engine can actually easily discover and
index all the essential pages on your
website it's foundational for a well
organized and search friendly website
structure now a quick guide on how to
create a sitemap what you do you just go
to your CMS tool or use a tool yeah or
your website development platform form
like WordPress or use a WordPress
plug-in yeah um to generate a sitemap
automatically you can also create a
simple XML file using a text editor
listing your URLs and additional
information about each page you save it
as an sitemap.xml and then you upload it
in the root directory of your
website yeah and you use an FTP client
to upload it or or use your hosting
providers file manager yeah Google needs
to find that sitemap in the root
directory of your website if you're
using Wordpress and use a WordPress
plugin for your sitemap it's all done
automatically yeah so it will create a
sitemap for you and it will upload it on
your uh in the root directory as well
and by do doing this yeah you can then
upload your sitemap here in which is
basically a URL yep and then you can
submit your sitemap so if I go to um my
other
website yeah no I haven't uploaded a um
a sitemap for these I should have done
that but um I'll do that that
later yeah so but once you've uploaded
your site map in the Google search
console then you've basically notified
Google that your sitemap is active and
you do that on other search engines as
well of course make sure that your
sitemap is regularly updated if there
are changes on your
website right if we then go to the next
topic which are
removals removals refer to a set of
tools and features that allow webm ERS
and site owners to request removal of
specific content from Google search
result either temporary or
permanently so these tools like removals
are designed to address situations where
you need to remove content from Google's
index for various reasons like outdated
content or sensitive
information the key components of this
removal section
yeah it could be for temporary removals
they allow you to take content out of
Google search results for a short per
period yes so um it could be for
outdated content like request a removal
of outdated Snippets of cached pages is
very useful when the search results
display information that is no longer
accurate or relevant due to recent
updates on your website it could be
clear cash du L removal of the cached
version of a specific page yeah so to
make sure that Google will fetch and
display the most recent version of a
page rather than showing a cached
version you can use it to clear outdated
content inform to inform Google that a
content on a specific page has been
updated or removed and should no longer
be considered or you can also go for
permanent removals they're more robust
and are used when you want to request
the removal of content for an extended
or indefinite
period now very important to note that
while these removal tools are effective
in controlling what appears in Google
search results they do not remove the
content from the internet entirely it
may still be accessible directly through
the website or other means or other
search engines so it also makes some
take some time to reflect in the Google
search results yes so it depends on
various factors including Google's
assessment of the request validity and
compliance with their
policies so use this the URL
removal yeah use it carefully and be
aware of the implications as improper
use or abuse of these features can
really impact your website's search
visibility right so that's on the
indexing and the quality and the
completeness of the indexing of your
website look at the status help Google
by uploading a sitemap and make sure
that there is content maybe that you
want to remove a next important part of
Google search console is the user
experience of your website it's a core
component designed to provide web
Masters and owners with insight into
various user experience aspects of the
website this part of a broader set of
tools focus on enhancing the overall
performance the
accessibility yeah the accessibility and
usability of
websites in the eyes of both the users
and the search
engines now it looks at various things
and a very important part are what we
call the core web
vitals so it shows in the core web FAL
report how your page is performed based
on real world users data it's at the
core the core web vitals are the heart
of your experience section yeah there
are a set of specific metrics that
access the loading performance the
interactivity and the visual stability
of the web page they're essential
indicators of the overall user
experience reflecting how to quickly a
page loads and how responsive is and how
visibly stable it remains during the
interactions there are other page uh
aspects of page experiences as well yeah
so it encompasses a broader factors that
contribute to the overall page
experience it includ includes the mobile
friendliness and it includes the
security the
https security and the absence of
intrusive interstitials like popups for
instance that might hinder the um the
user experience so the mobile usability
report found in this experience section
identifies issues specific to mobile
devices that may impact the user
experience and therefore the search
performance by addressing those mobile
usability concerns you enhance the
overall accessibility of your site yeah
and you cater to the increasing number
of users who have access to your website
via their mobile devices it improves the
SEO but it also improves to a positive
user
experience yeah part of your experience
is also the site links search
box they refer to the search bar that
sometimes appear within the site links
for a specific website in Google search
results there are additional links that
appear beneath the main search result
snippet and provide direct access to
specific Pages within the
website this inclusion of a search box
within these s links allows users to
perform a s specific search directly
from the search results page so there's
lots of benefits of having a site link
search
box it first of all facilitate
facilitates on-site search yeah so it
makes it more accessible it enables
users to search within your website
without navigating to the site
first it also helps with the providing a
better overall user experience by
offering a convenient and efficient way
for users to find specific content
within a
website now to have a sink search box
featured enabled yeah you need to
implement structured data markup on your
site the website should include the
search action structured data markup
with the
HTML that structured data markup helps
Google understand the
relationship between the site and the
search functionality it provides
information such as the URL pattern for
on-site searches it's crucial for Google
to recognize and display the search box
in the S
links
good that is very important to keep in
mind that the availability and features
in the Google search console can change
over time yeah keep that in mind because
Google updates its algorithms and search
features all the time always refer to
the latest Google search console
documentation for the most accurate and
up to-date
information we'll then move to the
security and manual
actions so maintaining a secure online
environment is
Paramount Google search console security
and manual action section acts as a
Vigilant Guardian alerting you to
potential security issues such as
mware regularly check this section it
ensures a proactive approach to the site
security and addressing security issues
not only protects your users but also
maintains The credibility of your site
in the eyes of both the visitors and the
search algorithms so a secure website is
a found
for your ongoing website
success okay then there are a number of
Legacy tools from the uh that Google no
longer actively promotes on the Google
search consoles then there is the links
there is settings for your Google search
console you can submit feedback and here
is a learning section about your Google
search console so born out of the
digital revolution in the late 1990s
early 2000 Google ads formerly known by
the way as Google adsw traces it Roots
back to early 2000s it was launched by
Google in fact in October 2000 and it
was a groundbreaking response to the
needs of online businesses to get closer
to the customers Google AdWords in those
day introduced a paradigm shift by
allowing advertisers to reach potential
customers through targeted online
advertising so over the years Google ads
has undergone massive Transformations
adapting to the changing dynamics of the
online landscape and additional
opportunities that arose from that from
the introduction of the quality score
algorithm to the evolution of campaign
types it consistently innovated so
advertisers could find more and do more
with more effective and efficient tools
so today Google ads is the standard as a
comprehensive and a sophisticated
platform serving a bridge between
advertisers and businesses and their
target audience and there are various
online channels that you can use like
Google search ads Google Display Network
YouTube shopping ads and many other
opportunities that you have within the
Google ads platform so as we journey
through the Google ads demos that I'm
going to share with you let's not just
look at the functionalities but also
evolve uh understand how it has evolved
into an indispensable tool for
businesses who want to thrive in the
digital era so let's unlock the power of
Google ads together so you can position
your brand in this Dynamic landscape of
online
advertising so what exactly is the
Google ads platform it is an advertising
in platform where businesses can create
and manage digital advertising campaigns
on Google search YouTube the Display
Network and other owned by Google
properties so it is an online
advertising platform it connects
businesses with a global digital
audience now it works on a paperclick
Model where advertisers bit on keywords
related to their business
yeah that is for the Google search ads
and it is one of the most popular areas
to advertise and ads appear when users
search for Relevant keywords or on
Google or its partner sites so it also
allows you to Target very specific um
sort of interest groups or Affinity
groups or groups that have done certain
um have shown certain Behavior like
visiting your website and offering them
like the display advertising that they
will see on websites or YouTube ads that
they are
visiting they can get specific campaign
types for specific goals like driving
traffic to your website generating leads
increasing brand
awareness the Google ads platform allows
targeting based on demographics on
interests on Geographic locations it
provides comprehensive tools and metrics
for campaign management and
optimization it also supports various ad
formats like text ads image ads video
ads and display ads and it finally
empowers businesses to reach Their
audience in an effective manner to
achieve their marketing objectives so
with that introduction behind us let's
kick off our demos so navigating to
Google ads is a must in today's
competitive leral landscape yeah the
journey goes beyond the basics so we're
going to cover setup we're going to look
at campaign intricacies and we're going
to look at how do you create Those ads
so it'll be a practical demo so it gives
you the knowledge to refine your online
presence because digital advertising is
dynamic yeah it allows you to get into a
dynamic conversation with your customers
and it gives you fantastic in insights
to engage effectively with your uh your
customer let's start by laying the
groundwork and how and look at how you
register your business on the Google ads
platform so let's kick off our journey
by registering your business on the
Google ads platform so simply go to
Google or the ads. goole.com log in with
your Google account and initiate a
process of connecting your your business
with this extensive online audience but
before that let me quickly show you this
ads. goole.com page it gives you lots of
information and and knowledge about the
Google ads platform it can show you what
you can do with it how you can use it to
achieve your goals yeah you get you see
a voucher that you can get if you spend
$400 you get $400 pound in add
credit
so let's kick off your journey by
registering your business on the Google
ads platform so simply visit ads.
goole.com and you get to this website
which is kind of the entrance to Google
ads and on this website you find lots of
information about the Google ads
platform you even see here on the top
right that they give you a foucher for
£400 in the UK yeah where you can if you
spend £400 on uh on Advertising so
you'll see they do that across the world
so you should be able to get those uh
those ad vouches as well so it gives you
lots of suggestions on the goals that
you can achieve the power of Google
advertising for your business and it
gives you some case studies as well and
what I really like about the Google ads
program that you can actually get freeof
charge personalized support yep and by
scheduling a meet meeting with a Google
ads expert and I would highly um sort of
uh recommend you use that surface
because they can really help you with
setting up your first Google ads
campaign so let's go into this system we
can click Start now yeah or you can sign
in if you have an existing account so if
you click start now it'll probably
immediately log in to my existing
account but what it will do it will
actually give you an overview of the
Google ads accounts that you already
have yeah or you can create a new Google
ads account so this step forms the
backbone for your online identity and it
gets you with an an seamless integration
between your business and the Google ads
um environment as it were so very
practical steps to get you started on
the Google ads platform effectively so
let's go on to create a new Google ads
account so create a new
account and here it goes into the
process of creating a new Google ads
account so you need to add big business
information you can then go straight
into creating your ad and set up your
budget now you can case go straight into
your first campaign and in the process
you will actually fill in your data to
sign up but what I advise you do here is
to skip the campaign creation that
you're not ready and then you will go in
a proper setup for your Google
ads so there's different elements that
you can do here so you give your billing
country you give your time zone your
currency if you want personalized
campaign guidance I would certainly
advise you take that as I mentioned
earlier yeah you fill that data in and
then you click submit and then yes to
continue I'll I'll select no for now so
click submit and then you're basically
all done and then uh The Next Step
what's going to happen is is actually
you need to go through the verification
process now a few more steps here the
details are very important if you go
through the entire process like your
business name your physical location
your contact information it's not about
getting the data but it's about crafting
your digital presence yeah so it goes
beyond checkboxes make sure that you add
every step yeah that you fill in every
step in the
process okay so the next step is that
you will go through the verification
process when you've done that process it
is very important that you are going to
verify your account so how do you verify
your account you go back to your main
Google ads dashboard and I will explain
this dashboard a little later and you
click here on the billing and uh here
you see Advertiser
verification yes so here is where you go
into
verification
to make sure that Google recognizes your
account and understands that you are the
actual business owner of this account so
that gives you an extra level of
security and integrity on your Google
ads account and once you verify it yes
so B Google has then reviewed your
business details and you can ensure your
accuracy but it can also gives you a
good foundation for this for your
advertising experience so it's more than
Security checks it's about making sure
that your data is correct and you have a
solid basis to start your journey in
Google
advertising
entering the ads
dashboard so here we are on the Google
ads
dashboard so let's start the so let's
start the second part of our Google ads
demo here is the ads dashboard it's like
stepping into the command center of your
digital advertising operations this
centralized Hub of offers a panoramic
view of your campaigns the performance
metrics and a toolkit for efficient ad
creation and AD management it's the
nerve center as we say where you have a
comprehensive overview and control of
your entire advertising landscape think
of it as your strategic headquarters it
gives you the insights and the tools
needed to navigate the entire Google ads
advertising platform so what it gives
you it gives you tabs for campaigns for
goals for tools for billing to admin to
the admin of your account and it also
gives you the overview recommendations
on how to and where to improve your ads
it gives you insights and reports it
gives you an overview of your campaigns
your advertising assets your audiences
your keywords and the change history and
it is um each step as it were serves as
a gateway to specific functionalities
for monitoring and optimizing your
advertising activities so getting
experienced in using this dashboard is
key for Effective campaign management
yes so you really need to start
practicing this it is not complicated
you don't need to use every
functionality but in these demos I will
show you the path you need to take to go
through the um the different menu
settings so the overview gives you a
deeper insight into your campaigns and
your campaign metrics yeah it gives you
the number of clicks you had on your
campaign it gives you the number of
Impressions the average cost per click
how much you've spent on the campaign
you can download the report you can set
the dates these are very important
metrics that can help you in improving
your campaigns here you see your
recently created campaigns yeah and lots
of other details that you are get vital
signs of your campaigns guiding you to
make informed decisions for your
campaign progress and again it's very
important that you understand these
metrics so it makes it helps you to make
sure that your advertising efforts are
not just active but that they are
effectively aligned with your overall
business
goals okay now a very important part is
the toolbox that you get in here yeah so
in the toolbox you get information to
plan your campaigns like a Keyword
Planner a performance planner a reach
planner there is your shared Library
where you get access to your audience
manager your exclusion lists your brand
lists yeah the content the Google tag um
that you can get here we'll talk about
that later troubleshooting bulk actions
more info about budgets and bidding so a
lot of e extra additional aspects you
can get here in your uh your toolbox
that you will definitely need in
executing your campaign and uh a number
of these tools we will discuss in our
demo it's very important that you master
the tools that you have here because
they will make the execution of your
campaigns and planning them a lot easier
if you use these tools so each tool
serves a unique purpose in enhancing the
effectiveness of your um your campaigns
so let's start the second part of our
Google ads demo here is the ads
dashboard it's like stepping into the
command center of your digital
advertising operations this centralized
Hub offers a panoramic view of your
campaigns the performance metrics and a
toolkit for efficient ad creation and AD
management it's the nerve center as we
say where you have a comprehensive
overview and control of your entire
advertising landscape think of it as
your strategic headquarters it gives you
the insights and the tools needed to
navigate the entire Google ads
advertising platform so what it gives
you it gives you tabs for campaigns for
goals for tools for billing to admin to
the admin of your account and it also
gives you the overview recommendations
on how to and where to improve your ads
it gives you insights and reports it
gives you an overview of your campaigns
your advertising assets your audiences
your keywords and the change history and
it is um each step as it were serves as
a gateway to specific functionalities
for monitoring and optimizing your
advertising activities so getting
experienced in using this dashboard is
key for Effective campaign management
yes so you really need to start
practicing this it is not complicated
you don't need to use every
functionality but in these demos I will
show you the path you need to take to go
through the um the different menu
settings so the overview gives you a
deeper insight into your campaigns and
your campaign metrics yeah it gives you
the number of clicks you had on your
campaign it gives you the number of
Impressions the average cost per click
how much you've spent on the campaign
you can download the report you can set
the dates these are very important
metrics that can help you in improving
your campaigns here you see your
recently created campaigns yeah and lots
of other details that you are get vital
signs of your campaigns guiding you to
make informed decisions for your
campaign progress and again it's very
important that you understand these
metrics so it makes it helps you to make
sure that your advertising efforts are
not just active but that they are
effectively aligned with your overall
business
goals okay now a very important part is
the toolbox that you get in here yeah so
in the toolbox you get information to
plan your campaigns like a Keyword
Planner a performance planner a reach
planner there is your shared Library
where you get access to your audience
manager your exclusion lists your brand
lists yeah the content the Google tag um
that you can get here we'll talk about
that later troubleshooting bulk actions
more info about budgets and bidding so a
lot of e extra additional aspects you
can get here in your uh your toolbox
that you will definitely need in
executing your campaign and uh a number
of these tools we will discuss in our
demo it's very important that you master
the tools that you have here because
they will make the execution of your
campaigns and planning them a lot easier
if you use these tools in setting up
your campaign it's also very important
to look at the structure of your Google
ads and the standard structure of a
Google ads campaign is to in it's three
fold there is the campaign level there
is the ad group and within the ad group
sits the um s the ads and the ads they
inherit the setting of the ad group and
the ad group they inherit the setting of
The campaigns on campaign level you talk
about the objectives of your campaign
you look at the um the the bidding
strategy that you have for your campaign
in the the price that you the budget
that you want to assign in the ad groups
you can look at your keywords and you
can specify your ads as well so very
important that you think about that
structure and that will really help you
into organizing your campaign in a
structured
manner okay having gone through this
dashboard now now let's jump into the
Google ads Basics and create a campaign
and picking the right keywords so to
create a campaign you just go to the
campaigns stab and you click here the
plus to start or I can click here on the
campaign step I'm getting an overview of
my
campaigns and um but in this case I just
click on the campaign tab on the plus
button and that will take me to the sort
of the starting screen of my um Google
ad setup so I can decide my campaign
goal I can set a budget and I can pick a
bidding strategy so this is the
beginning of your ad game here you state
what you want do you want more clicks do
you want leads do you want brand
awareness how much do you want to spend
what is your bidding strategy do you
want to set it or do you want good gole
to handle it yeah do you want more
clicks more
conversions and when you start this
process you're on the way to create your
first ads plan so here you
see
the different types of campaign
objectives that you can select and each
objective will kind of pre-select the
digital narrative within Google ads so
they serve different purposes whether it
is driving sales or driving website
traffic um or whether it is capturing
leads whether it is promoting your app
whether it is a local store visit
whether it is sales or a product and
brand consideration or you can also
decide to create a campaign without
selecting any of these and that is for
the more experienced people who can who
know exactly what to specify but if you
click one of these then Google will
automatically prepopulate kind of the
settings for you in the uh in the Google
ads screens that will follow so aligning
these types with your goals is very
important and they ensure that you get a
very impactful digital marketing
approach to your customers so let's
click on one of them yes so let's click
for instance on the uh we want website
traffic so here you see what type of
conversions that you want yes so that
could be page views that could submit
lead forms it could subscribe so you can
specify these conversions and you just
click here you click on continue and
here you select the campaign sort of
type that you want to select want to to
to run do you want a search campaign do
you want a display campaign do you want
Google to sort of Select it for you yeah
do you want a shopping campaign a video
campaign or do you want a demand gen
where you run ads on Youtube Gmail and
various other channels so let's say
we're going to create a um let's start
with a search campaign yeah so you put
in your website your website address
which in my case would be this website
you're going to give your campaign a
name and you click continue I'm going to
start a new campaign and here it's very
important that you specify the bidding
strategy that you set as you know Google
ADS works with an auction system you put
in a bid for when what you will pay uh
when people click on your ads and then
Google in the auction when people have
actually put in one of your keywords
Google will then use different methods
for making sure that the um the the best
bit in combination of various other
factors wins as it were and shows up at
the top of the uh the advertising
listings on Google ads now the the
highest bidder doesn't necessarily be at
automatically be at the the number one
spot there is also a quality score of
your ad that is impacting whether or not
you would show at the top so your
financial uh core rest on the budget and
the bidding strategy so determine your
daily budget yeah align it with your
advertising
objectives and uh it's very
important how you want to set this do
you want to run it for conversions do
you want to run it for
clicks yep so you can set a maximum cost
per click or you can let Google set that
automatically for you yep and when
you're happy with how you set it you
click next and then you specify where
you want to show your ads yep so here
you see you can specify the for the
Google search campaign you can specify
the search Network you can also show
search ads on the Display Network you
can look at the network the locations
the languages you can specify specific
audiences or you can also do some
keyword matching for your search
campaigns there's various location
options they work very powerful yeah so
you can spe spe ify by language you can
select audience segments so for instance
I would just do an advertisement on a
specific
sector so I can say give me just people
that are interested in
travel and they will then be added to uh
they will then be targeted with your
your
ads yep and then here you're going to
specify your uh the type of key word
match that you want
so uh so that is very important and as
you can see in the Google search ads the
keywords are very important but I'll
come back to that in a minute what I
first want to do is go through the more
settings where you will sort of open up
additional functionality that will make
you use um give you a more advanced use
of the Google ads like how do you want
to rotate your ads is there a start and
an end date for your campaign do you
have a specific ad schedule do you have
campaign URL options that is where you
want to um to track your campaigns or
Are there specific brand restrictions
that you do not want to associate with
your ads and the placement of your ads
so particularly on the ad schedule my
recommendation would be to select all
day when you start your ads let Google
decide what is the best timings for your
ads that gives the best response what
you will see when you set up your ads
that you set up multiple ads and Google
will mix and match the ads and will
select the best combination of the ads
that will give you the best performance
and will also select the best timings so
the first couple of days that you're
advertising in campaign is running
Google will be in what we say learning
mode and it will do all the tests it
will run the various options of your ads
and it will sort of slowly calibrate
your ad campaign to the best format the
best settings and the best
structure so this type of
control yeah is not about just Reaching
Your Right audience but it also does it
at the most opportune moments the best
times so it maximizes the effectiveness
of your uh your ads so very important
part of this is your keywords as I just
mentioned so for search campaigns here
is where you can specify your keywords
so what you can do you can get
suggestions from Google by entering your
website address and then Google will and
will sort of select the best keywords
for you and you can use those for your
search ads which means that every time
somebody types in any of these keywords
your ad will show to the to those people
depending on your bidding strategy or
you can add your own keywords based on
your keyword research and the tool that
I showed you earlier the Google Keyword
Planner is a Fant fantastic tool that
can help you in building those um those
those keyword lists for you now I'm not
going to go into the details here of
keyword uh research that may be the
topic for a future uh campaign so it's
very important that you align your
keywords with your business and that the
keywords resonate with your target
audience and make sure that you use the
key Google Keyword Planner to find the
right keywords or any other tools that
uh that are available in the market the
keyword is fundamental for your search
campaign it's not about what you say in
your ad but it is also how do those
keywords resonate with your
audience good that concludes the basic
setup of your ads on a campaign level
and on an ad group
level we're now going to look at our
next demo where we're going to look at
targeting and also where we're going to
look at how to create an
ad so as we shift Focus the spotlight
turns now to defining and refining your
target
audience and particularly this will be
important when you set up a display
campaign and when you go into the
campaign settings for the display and
you follow the menu down here you get to
the targeting option and that is the
first place where you can specify your
the which people you target with your
display ads so this is where you can
identify demographics interests and
behaviors that resonate with your brand
so this ensures if you set that that
your ads are displayed to those people
that are most likely to engage with your
brand so navigating through this
audience setting is not about casting a
wiet it is about Precision about
reaching the right people at the right
time so let's click on the targeting and
you see here that you hone in on various
areas you can hone in on audience
segments demographics keywords topics
and placement and here while you're
going through these targeting options
you can keep track of your um estimated
number of Impressions and your estimated
performance for your ads so exploring
this array of audio targeting options
audience targeting options is about
tailoring your message to different
personalities these different audiences
so look at audience
segments that is where you can select
audiences who are particularly
interested in travel or lifestyle and
hobbies and there is literally hundreds
of segments that people can um can
select yeah you can search for any
segment you can let's say here let's do
um train
enthusiasts just taking a random topic
yeah let's see what comes up and here is
train
information train hobby traveling by
train um yeah so everything to do with
trains that you can pick here you can
even probably take miniature trains so
you can Target those people very
specifically that ensures that your ad
is not visible but also relevant to
specific segments of your target
audience so that is through the audience
segments and again if you pick one so
say um train information then here you
see how your weekly estimates are um are
changing yeah so you can go by selecting
you put them in your Target and then you
see how your um advertising campaign is
likely to perform so let's stay away
from the train let's go to um Adventure
travel for instance and now you get all
those people that are interested in
adventure
vacations activity
holidays Wildlife trips Etc and again
you see how your performance is changing
so that is the audience segments we then
going to go to the next level that is
demographics we're targeting male let's
say um
between 25 and 44 years with a slightly
higher higher household income let's say
the top um 21 so we're going for the the
top uh tier and again your estimates are
being adjusted and then you can go to
the next one you can add targeting so
you can Target keywords so this is for
instance I am targeting those people
that have a specific interest in
Kilimanjaro for instance and um
Karo yep and I can add that as a keyword
if I want and
Morocco and you see how my weekly
estimat are becoming more and more
specific I can add keyword ideas through
for from my website as well so let's say
that is done and then we can go to the
the
final uh targeting which was by topics
yeah or you can even Target by
placements so if we want Adventure
magazines yeah so Adventure magazines
you can then select those magazines or
those online Publications where your ads
will show so you can ask by default ask
Google to select this for you but if
you're very experienced in your industry
you know specific magazines where you
want to place your ad then very likely
you will find them in the list here it
takes a little while to go through this
list of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of online Publications but
then you can really Target very specific
by magazine while it is doing this let's
go to the optimiz targeting which is on
which means Google will actually help
you get more viewable Impressions yeah
find people beyond your targeting
signals so that is what Google will help
you to fine tune your um uh your
targeting and um give you even better
results for your campaign yes so we
targeted the adventure Channel Adventure
magazine so here are 253 websites there
are YouTube channels that you can Target
YouTube videos apps and app categories
where your ad can show so this is a very
good section where you can make your ads
reach the right people so that is one
area where you can
feature um where you can be very
specific in the targeting of your ad
that is within the display campaign
settings you can also Target People
based on
behavior and one very important behavior
is um what they have done on your
website in the
past yeah and that is what we're going
to look at next as part of this audience
segmentation and audience targeting
we're going to look at how can I
Leverage
activities from people behavior of
people for instance visiting my website
or buying a product yeah how can I how
can I capitalize on those um on those
people and maybe put them in a separate
audience that I can then Target with my
ads this is what we call retargeting and
I can Target people with an ad once they
fish it at my website for a particular
product P page for instance and I'm sure
you've experienced that yourself that
you were visiting an ad and that you or
that you were visiting a product on the
website and then you put a product in
the basket but you decide not to buy
that product and then the next time you
go on Facebook or on YouTube you
actually see a product for that ad so
that is the next section that we will be
looking
at a new feature in Google ads are
conversion
goals conversion goals help you organize
your conversion actions so that you can
more move more easily towards achieving
your advertising objectives so actions
that you want your customers to take or
conversion actions are grouped together
based on related categories to form
these conversion goals so how do you get
there you go here to goals you click on
conversions and here you have a summary
of your conversion goals for example the
purchase conversion or the Subscribe
conversion goal would automatically
contain all conversion actions from
people to subscribe to a particular form
and this simplifies your conversion
management and it improves your campaign
performance so very powerful new aspect
within Google ads to manage your
conversions in one central place so how
do you set a aay conversion you set it
up here in the new conversion
action so you can set up a conversion
action for your website for your apps or
for phone calls or you can import data
from Google or from Salesforce or other
um tools but the most important one
again is getting conversion tracking set
up for your website so when you click on
that you can then put in your website
domain you can click
scan and it will then scan the website
if it's already set up to measure
conversions which basically means have
you already set up conversion tags on
your
website so Google ads can track those
web pages so you can it has been set up
so you can actually create specific
conversion actions you can do that from
website events you can also create
conversion actions manually by using
specific code so if you use transaction
specific values transaction ideas yeah
so then you can use this option but the
easiest one is to use the create
conversion action from website event so
you can actually accept suggestion or
for set setting up a conversion goal you
can also add a conversion goal so you
can select a category for
instance um a subscribe the event type
could be a page load on this website and
then you just click
add the URL is required for that would
be the about us yeah and then I click
add and then the the code has been the
conversion goal has been created I click
save and
continue and then it sets up this
conversion
action where of course I need to make
sure I set it up properly with a Google
tag through Google tag manager now this
section is not about teaching you how to
use Google tech manager we have a
separate video for that but I just just
want to make you aware of the process of
how to do that you can also email the
instructions to your Web Master yep so
let's say if we want to email the
instruction then we'll just put in the
email address and then it's uh sent or
you can also set it up yourself and then
what you do is you get a piece of
code where you that you basically need
to copy and that you need to paste in
the Google tag manager so you can use
the Google tag manager that's where you
use this particular piece of code you
can also install manually and here is
the piece of code that you need to
install on every page of the
website so then Google can see that that
is a tag for those specifical specific
conversion goals that um Google then can
then start
tracking good you can test the
installation as well but I'll just want
to make you aware where you go to set
that
up okay so those are the conversion
goals in
Google the last topic of this
demo the last topic of this demo is AD
placements and the networks the ad
networks and the actual creation of ads
this is very important it is like
choosing the stage for your performance
and exploring the very various options
including the Google search Network the
Display Network and YouTube is vital to
align your uh your ads with your
advertising Network your advertising
objectives so the
different ad options that you have they
start with the Google search Network the
Google search Network places your ads in
search engine results that gives you
visibility for your ads when users activ
ly search for related content the next
area is the Display Network that
showcases your ad across a multitude of
websites and apps thereby having a big
reach of your uh your ads YouTube as a
video platform offers a very extensive
advertising platform with lots of
advertising opportunities and different
um different versions of ads and
tailoring your approach to each platform
it will amplify the effectiveness of
your ad strategy to make sure that you
get maximum impact on your ads now let's
go to the fun part of Google ads and
that is the actual creation of your ads
so we'll head to over to the ads we go
to the campaigns click a campaign here
is the campaign we're going to first
create a search ads which is let's say
for website
traffic we go to continue and here is
the search ad that we're going to create
we'll add our
website and we'll click continue and
we'll start a new campaign and where
we're going to is the keywords and the
ads so we have already set up the
keywords we're going now straight to the
actual ads and this is a very important
section where you are able to set up
your Google search ads they are based on
um
the a combination of headlines up to 15
and
descriptions up to
four and a number of extensions like
site links or call outs and different
other
extensions okay okay you can set that
all up and then Google will mix and Ma
match those different elements of your
ads to come up with the ad with the best
performance and what's really nice here
is they show you a preview of what the
ad will look like with the different
headlines and the different
descriptions and here you see your
campaign optimization score with the
weekly estimate
of how many conversions and how many
what your weekly cost is here you see
your ad strength and you see at the
moment it is poor because I need to make
the description more more unique so you
can get ideas and you'll see that this
area will become more and more advanced
and more and more driven by artificial
intelligence in the future yeah to make
sure that you get the best ads possible
for your your
market so again this is a short demo I'm
not going to go into every little detail
yeah but this is where you create your
search ads so that is the first
area the second area where you create
your ads is of course for the display
campaigns so if I go back to Google
ads and I am going to create a new
campaign but now I'm going to create a
brand awareness campaign for display ads
again here I say riat far
russia.com I click continue I'm going to
go start
new and here I can of course we've been
through all these settings remember the
campaign settings the budget and the
bidding and the targeting and here we go
to the
ads and here you can specify the URL
your business name you can add up to 15
images so where you upload an image
let's say we're going to use the image
of this room and you see here in
different formats and we're going to add
this images as well so we're going to
click
save and then you can add a text you
could even add a video you can add a
headline and here you will see what the
add will looks look
like now make sure that you have
switched off your ad blocker if you have
set up an ad blocker and because when
you have an ad blocker then this the the
the preview of the ad will not show so I
need to add the final URL I need to add
the https for
this yep so here is the final URL with
the business name and now we in a bit
the ad should show up we should have the
business name two images One headline so
we'll add um welcome to riat for
Russia and a
description book your
adventure holiday
now okay and then here you see how the
ad would look
like very simple very straightforward
but it is all about of course the
quality of the images the headlines that
you're using the description that you're
using but at least this gives you an
idea of what an ad looks like and how
you would create that within the display
um ad
category so here is a few
tips yes so uh add copy is very
important yeah relevant VIs visuals and
formulate clear call to actions they are
the fundamental elements of your in of
your ads compelling add copy is about
Clarity and enticement and about having
a concise message and be different so
the integration of the relevant visuals
that enhances the overall appeal now
calls to action I can't emphasize enough
and the they guide users on the design
ired next steps and that will drive
conversions so keep that in mind and
this all comes back to clearly defining
your objectives
so outline your advertising goals
whether it's increasing website traffic
generating leads or boosting sales
welldefined objectives will guide your
entire ads
strategy also do very thorough keyword
research yeah comprehend do a
comprehensive keyword research to
identify the relevant terms for your
business and try to familiarize yourself
with the tools like Google Keyword
Planner so you can discover the high
performance key uh
keywords also think about your ad copy
develop compelling ad copy that speaks
directly to your target audience use
your unique selling point points include
relevant keywords create a craw strong
to call a strong call to action landing
pages very important ensure that your
landing pages yeah that your ads direct
the users to optimized and seamless um
and seamless experience on your landing
page content on your landing page should
be aligned with your ad and the page
should be user friendly and have a very
clear call to action
in the search ad make sure that you use
ad extensions take advantage of those ad
extensions provide additional
information in your ads and increase ad
visibility so extension links like site
links call outs structured Snippets they
enhance your ad providing users with
more reasons to click to
conclude remember yeah that Google ads
isn't just a tool it is not just a
presence it is a dynamic connection with
a fast online audience and they say
through Google ads you can reach around
90 plus perc of the internet audience
and by crafting well organized campaigns
and using the um library of tools in the
ads dashboard that will be the perfect
combination for for
Success think about the keywords it's
not just an afterthought it is the the
glue that holds your campaigns together
and understanding these intricacies of
Google ads that can become your
competitive difference in launching your
ad campaign so that basically concludes
this uh this video we've covered the
essentials on Google ads from campaign
initiation to add Creation with an
emphasis on
practicality yeah now armed with this
knowledge you are better positioned to
orchestrate your own effective ad
campaigns and make sure that you get the
conversions that you uh that you want so
that concludes it for today thanks for
joining this exploration as you venture
in this new world of Google ads your
campaigns make sure they are strategic
your keywords be impactful and your D
Dynamic your digital presence be dynamic
so I wish you the best of luck in your
advertising behaviors remember if you
like this video click the like button
below and subscribe to our um our
Network so you get access to other
videos that we will be publishing in the
near future what is email marketing well
email has been around for a very long
time of course and in the very early
days there wasn't an email marketing
service that you could use yeah you
couldn't easily send out hundreds of
emails so what you did you were actually
using the BCC or the blind carbon copy
in your email system to send out emails
to many people of course the IT
department of companies in those early
days they didn't like that because it
would block the email system of the
company so they come up with with little
marketing uh email Marketing Solutions
on the company's main frame but it was
all very inflexible you had to take your
email you had to take your mailing list
give that to the guy in the IT
department and if you're lucky then
maybe in a couple of days later your
email would be sent you wouldn't get any
data at all about those emails yeah you
knew how many emails were sent but you
didn't know who would have opened the
email or who would have clicked on the
email nowadays of course things are
completely different yeah now you have
email marketing where you can use email
service providers who offer you lots of
tools and lots of analytics to manage
and plan and measure your email
marketing campaigns so what actually is
email marketing it uses email addresses
from people to inform your email list
about your product or service we call
these commercial emails which is
completely different of course from the
billions of personal emails that are
being sent yeah around the uh the
internet every day so this is a
commercial email that you send to an
email list about your product your
service or a newsletter and what have
you Additionally you can integrate it
into your marketing automation so you
can and it can help your customers to
see your latest products and offer
and you can obviously use the email list
to and persuade them to buy or book a
demo or sign up for a trial or register
for an event yeah we call this email
nurturing where you can send a range of
emails to take people through that
journey to help them to make the
decision so what are the different uses
of email marketing it can be used in
relationship building with existing
customers who bought the product for
instance send them a thank you you email
it could be to boost brand awareness it
could be about promoting various pieces
of content it can help you in generating
leads or to promote or Market your
products and very important you can use
it to nurture leads so what are the
types of email marketing there are a
whole range of different emails that you
can send through email Marketing Systems
we'll talk about welcome emails
newsletter emails could be a lead
nurturing email confirmation email
specific emails to specific people
invitations promotional emails or an
email to do a survey or seasonal
marketing emails so a whole range of
emails you have available that you can
use for different marketing purposes so
now that you understand the basics of
email let's talk about how you get
started with it it's not that
complicated first of all like with many
marketing activities you you need to
Define your audience and establish your
goals why do you want to use email
marketing and then you start with one of
the most important aspects of your email
marketing that is about building your
email list and that is the most
important it's a very important aspect
because if your email list is not up to
dat yeah there will be a lot of bounces
on your email and your email service
provider may get back to you say hey
your email list is not up to date so we
may actually block you because you may
be spamming your customers you then
choose the uh the email campaign type
that you want to run you make a schedule
when you want to send out the emails and
then of course you need to measure your
results marketing there is social media
there is um what's it influencer
marketing there is advertising you name
it so they had to enrich their
services and you will see that when we
go into MailChimp that there is now a
whole range of additional Services even
down to developing your own website that
MailChimp can offer you but at the core
of MailChimp is its email system so
let's go and have a look into how to use
MailChimp and how to set up your first
email Campa
so if you go to mailchimp.com
yeah you can see here a little overview
of what it does yeah then um again we're
going to go into automations I'm going
to show you some of the analytics I'm
going to show you how you can segment
with um with MailChimp and how you can
synchronize with other applications in
MailChimp as well so lots of stuff that
you can do here is a little promotional
video um and here is the pricing so so
you can see that a free version gives
you limited functionality but it does
give you all the functionality you need
to send emails to up to 500 contacts per
month yep and then it goes up to 1170
and then the premium version gives you
all the Full Features
$299 but let's focus on the free version
again that's what I kind of like of um
of MailChimp so let's go into my account
yes so I go on
[Music]
to let's have a look I'm logged in yeah
so here is
my
audience so here you see the features
that MailChimp has to
offer so first of all there is create
you can create
campaigns yeah that is where you run
your email campaigns and where you
create your marketing campaigns a very
important part of your MailChimp is your
contacts or your audience of course if
you don't have any emails in your
database as it were then yeah then
there's not many people that you can
send stuff to so contacts are very
important that you get an email list
that you can connect with your campaigns
there are automations that you can do
which basically means you can send
emails automatically there is analytics
there is website you can create your own
website and cont modules of it there is
content so that is sort of your library
of assets and then there are different
Integrations that you can do here you
see kind of your dashboard of the
campaigns and this is your audience
dashboard so so the very first thing of
course that you need to do when you are
starting on MailChimp that is create an
audience yeah and that's where you go
into your contacts so there is your
audience dashboard as you see here you
can have all an overview of all your
contacts you can create signup forms
that you can add to your website to
capture people's email addresses there
are tags that you can set to contents
you can group your contents into
segments and you can do surveys and
there is your inbox if people send you
messages yeah so lots of functionality
but your first challenge will be how to
get your emails there's lots of ways to
do that first of all there may be your
existing customer database or your
existing customer list you probably have
them in a
spreadsheet yeah so what I'm going to
show you in a minute is how you can
enter or um import that spreadsheet into
uh MailChimp yeah so that is one way
second you can actually set up on your
website a form that people can fill in
to sign up for your newsletter for
instance or you can run a campaign where
people go to a landing page and if they
download a certain piece of uh
documentation then they need to give you
their um their email address yeah so
there's lots of ways another really
effective way if you're at an exhibition
for instance have a little box on your
uh your counter where people can leave
their e their um their their business
cards yeah and then you can take all of
that information and put them in your uh
your MailChimp so the question here then
is of course how do I bring contacts
into my ma chimp audience so let's go to
all
contacts yep and then you see I already
have two contacts in my
myo that's the name of my audience yeah
so I'm going to add additional contacts
I can get an overview of my contacts I
can add contacts manually I can add a
subscriber yeah and then I can just put
in the name yeah so that is Mark at uh
simply
learn.com and then it's
Mark there is simply learn don't have to
put in address I can get phone number I
can get birthday I can get company name
that would be simply
learn I can add a tag so that would be
training add or create a
tag
yeah that could be
training there's my tag now very
important what simp what what the
MailChimp wants to know that the people
that you have in your
database that you that they gave you
permission to email them yeah there are
very strict requirements these days for
people yeah that you need to respect
their privacy you need to have
permission before you send them an email
yep and there's different ways that you
can ask that permission you can ask it
on the website before they fill in a
form you can ask it in your newsletter
yeah so make sure that you have those
permissions because if people get
unsolicited email through a commercial
email campaign yeah in principle that is
not allowed and you may be subject to a
fine the you may have heard of the gdps
regulations in in in Europe and there is
also regulations in the United States
there's regulations in Asia yeah there's
a real tightening of those privacy
regulations when it comes to email
marketing if this person for some reason
is already in my audience then I can
update it will update their profile so
let's click
subscribe let's
see there's probably one field I
forgot phone number that is
075 yeah so the phone number was a
required um item as well yep and then I
click
subscribe so if I now go back to all
contacts you will see that Mark simply
learn.com is now has been added to my
database so that is one a way to get
emails in your audience list the next
way is if you go to add contacts you can
import
contacts there are three ways how you
can import contacts you can import
contacts from another service yeah so
when you connect with another piece of
software you can upload a CSV file or a
text file and you can even copy and
paste yeah so if I import from another
service you can see you can import for
Salesforce from square space from
Shopify and there's probably a lot more
Integrations that you can have if you
want to upload a file it will then
basically ask you to upload your file so
what we need to do we need to create a
spreadsheet that we save as a CSV file
so if I go
to Google
Drive and I'm going to actually I
already have a file here yes so let's
open this file so you
see that I have these names in there I'm
going to take them out very important
that you add first name last name
company email and all the fields that
are relevant for you you yeah so let's
say telephone as well so then we're
going to say the first name is uh
Jacob uh last name is Jones company
is
bco and email is
Jacob jones.com
telephone number is 012 3 4 5 6 7 yep
then the second name is um n
Marie uh
Carol and that is
carol.com
and that is
[Music]
an at
carol.com and that is 9 87654 telephone
number okay let's take out that dollar
sign right yes so now I have the file
and this name is MailChimp or whatever
MailChimp
one so the first thing I'm going to do
of course is to save this I am going to
download this file as a comma separated
values file which is a CSV
file and M chimp wants me to upload this
CSV file
into this field yeah so that's how I can
upload my context so I'm going to
my uh
YouTube download here is my MailChimp
CSV
file yep so there it is I'm going to
continue to organize now the first thing
that MailChimp is going to do now if
there were
any existing context day will be updated
the first thing I can add a tag yes so
I'm going to let's say a
member and I'm going to continue to
match that is what MailChimp is going to
do now remember the first line of our
spreadsheet was sort of the field names
first name last name company name and
telephone MailChimp is going to match
those MailChimp thinks that the first
line was first name the second name was
last name so these are correct company
it has picked up it doesn't know what to
do with telephone yeah so what I can do
I can edit this column yeah and I can
look at the fields that they have yes so
is telephone in here I don't see yeah
here phone number yeah and I'm going to
link it with phone
number so now it is okay and I can now
see here five columns will
imported and I'm going to say finalize
import yep so now it has added two
contacts to the list so I'm going to say
complete
import and if I now want to view my
contacts you will see that my contacts
have been added to my email
list yes so now I have two additional
contacts in my list list I could also
add a subscriber actually have done a
copy and paste go back add contacts
import contacts I could do a copy and
paste so I'll show you how that works
continue yeah so when I go back to the
spreadsheet and I would copy these just
copy it command copy going back to my
MailChimp and I can now just base them
here just like this and now MailChimp is
going to analyze this yeah and it says
okay this is what I think it is and it
goes back into that same stage that we
saw in um when we up when we imported
the
spreadsheet yeah you see here first name
last name company name and then the
telephone yep now I'm not going to
import this again because we've already
imported these contacts but this is how
you import your
contacts
okay now a few tips on your
database yes very
important you sure you want to exit this
okay yeah so you may build up a list of
a couple of hundred contacts in your um
in your MailChimp and that is fantastic
yeah the bigger your list the more value
that you will get from it a very
important aspect of this is to make sure
that your database is
clean yeah people may ask to be removed
from your database people change
businesses yeah make sure your database
is clean when you run a
campaign and you use your email list and
there are a lot of emails that cannot be
sent because there are a lot of wrong
emails in your list yeah you will have
what we call a high bound rate and if
you have a continuous High bounds rate
MailChimp may come back to you and say
hey why do you have such a high bound
rate and if you can't explain why you
have a high bound rate MailChimp may
actually block your account because
MailChimp wants you to work with a clean
database that is also the risk if you
buy an email list that you don't know
the source from and if you import it and
then run your fa first campaign if you
get a whole lot of bounces on your
emails yeah then um MailChimp May block
your account so be very careful make
sure that your emails are correct that
your bounce rate is low and never
Buy email lists because you don't know
what the quality is of the list make
sure that you segment your mailing list
and then you can within one mailing list
you can send it to your different
segments could be customers could be
prospects could be uh suppliers um or
what have you yeah constantly work on
growing your database make sure you
don't spam people always get um
people's um approval yeah that they are
happy for you to send them um emails and
of course honor unsubscribed as well if
people ask you to unsubscribe them from
the mailing list make sure you do
that okay just a few tips when it comes
to managing your database so now that
you have your email audience set up your
contacts set up let's look at a campaign
let's when you go into the campaigns
here you have an overview of all the
campaigns that you've run now we haven't
run any campaigns here is a draft
campaign yeah but what you're going to
do you're going to create a
campaign yes when you click here on the
top right on the create campaign button
you have then the different types of
campaigns that you can or can create
you can do a regular email you can
actually create a landing page or you
can also create an embedded form yeah
that helps you in capturing context that
could be part of your landing page
campaign but what we're going to look at
is regular emails yes so when I click on
email I can just sign click here design
email
yeah then there is a new email Builder
that you can use and since you're
probably new to uh simply learn um and
new to um to MailChimp I click straight
onto the new Builder because that is a
lot easier to work
with yeah so here you see it's time to
design your email yeah I put this little
icon already in yesterday yeah so
there's different ways of doing that
here you see sort of your editor for
your email here you can preview the
email here you see your editing building
blocks the layout The Heading paragraph
button Etc here you can specify Styles
and here you can specify templates for
your emails so here you see a whole
range of email templates
yeah if you click on the creative
assistant that is beautiful but it will
drive you to a
premium account yeah so I'm not going to
show that I want to show you the free
features of MailChimp so let's say we're
going to go for a little design here
we're going to go for this one we could
do preview that's how it will look like
yeah and then we're going to click apply
continue with start with a clean
template yes so this is how it will look
like so what you can then do start
optimizing the text and the
images so let's do that so here view
this email in your browser that is
always good to have you can change your
image yes so if I click on
that yeah you see here replace logo yeah
so if I click click on replace logo I
can
then go to uh the content studio and I
can just upload different files here and
this is the image that I picked yeah so
let's stick with this particular image
here then I can add a photo so I can say
add a photo I can say upload an image
yeah so if I go to my YouTube I go
to uh
thought I had an image somewhere
videos
Banner yeah so here I've added a banner
as an image I can align it left center
right full yeah I can just line to the
right I can align it to the center left
I'm going to do a full alignment okay
and then here you see my text it's time
to design design your email so here I
can say um
welcome to this week's
newsletter in this
newsletter yep so then in this
newsletter we
will be
talking
about and then blah blah blah blah blah
okay then here you see a button yeah and
I've added that I can then just click
here first I click done y so the buttons
I can bring in here through my
um my uh build units yeah and here I can
change the button text so I here is book
now for instance so here I have my
social media buttons yeah and I can
there put my own social media onto
that yeah I can do the same with my
Instagram and I can do the same for my
Twitter I can add another social link
I'm going to leave it at like that
here's my logo again then here this will
be picked up automatically every email
will at the bottom have details about
your company about your address how can
people
unsubscribe yeah and because you're
using the free version there is this
item grow your business with MailChimp
yeah that is a little bit of MailChimp
branding that will be added to your
email if you're using the free version
so keep that in mind okay so then you
click preview this is how your email
will look like
yep and then you're going to exit
preview mode and if you're happy with
this you're going to save and exit now
here you kind of have your admin screen
for your
campaign yeah so you see here the name
so I need to type in the name so I'm
going to name it is
MailChimp demo for instance and I'm
clicking save then here I have
selected all the context so I can just
go to my audience I pick the audience
that I've created I can then have all my
subscribers or I can pick certain
segments or tags in my subscriber base I
can personalize the two field yeah and
then I click save here is the from so
that is it's from me or you can edit
that have it from sent from somebody
else you can add a subject now your
subject line of course is very important
in email marketing because in the
subject line people will when they read
the subject line people will decide
whether or not they will open the
email yeah so the subject line always
has to be catchy so and it could be five
reasons why you should read our
latest email uh
newsletter
newsletter yeah or any other subject
line but they are they need to be short
and sweet yeah you could use emojis you
need to in that one line you need to
give people the reason why they should
open this email preview text appears in
the inbox after the subject line yeah so
so in today's
newsletter we will
talk
about social media and email
marketing for instance and you click
save so that is your subject that is
your
content yep and then here is part of
your contact you can send yourself a
test email
that is always useful to send it to
yourself and check it on your desktop
and check it on your mobile so I send
myself a test email send a test to any
email yeah so let me quickly check here
my
[Music]
Gmail that is
uh to
me that is tube for
Mark okay so I'm going to send that
email to tube for Mark okay I can send
it to multiple people and I'm going to
click send
test email has been
sent so let's check the email so here we
see the email test five reasons why you
should read our latest
newsletter and then here you see the
email and then you check it on typos you
check it on the links that are in there
yeah make sure that your social media
buttons work
etc and if you're then happy with your
email you can then publish it yeah and
there's two ways of publishing it you
can schedule it when you schedule it you
can set a delivery date and a specific
delivery time but in order to use use
that feature you need to upgrade to
premium okay so you can send it directly
so when you click Send it will go
straight
away yep so very important or you can
say finish later if you don't want to
share your campaign you see here the
link for the
campaign yeah and you could change that
your defil campaign URL yeah so
MailChimp generate randomly five reasons
why you should read our email if you
upgrade to premium you can turn this
MailChimp into your uh own
URL okay good and then you can track
your uh your Campa your email campaigns
but um we'll put they we use we'll cover
that in a in a next video on on mil
chimp and we go into more advanced
features okay so I'm just going to click
finish
later and if we're now having our list
of campaigns then here you see we have
our MailChimp demo as a draft ready to
be
published so that is the so that is the
campaign how to create a campaign on mil
chimp right now let's have a look at a
few more things so first of all a new
feature in MailChimp is the analytics
when you send out an email campaign you
will get basic analytics here in your um
campaigns dashboard as well but
MailChimp now also has an analytics
dashboard and here you see the type of
data that you will get in MailChimp and
it is using sample data so we can
explore the dashboard so here you see
number of emails sent whether it's up or
down you see the number of people or the
percentage of people that opened the
email and very important the actual
percentage of people that clicked on the
email or clicked on the link in the
email and that is very important yeah so
that's where you can really follow
through on your email campaigns yeah on
who opened it who clicked it to the form
the frences that needed to be filled in
so very useful information that you can
get out of your campaign and you can see
that from various periods yeah you can
even actually in the other reports you
can actually see who are the people in
my uh mailing list in my audience who
actually clicked on the email and who
are the people who opened the uh clicked
on the link yeah and then you can
approach them
separately yeah so here you see
engagements email sent and the click
rate yep so here you see by email the
the number of recipients the open rate
The Click rate the revenue that you made
if you had that set up so lots of data
that you can get on your email campaigns
open rates are very important and they
differ by industry yeah and general and
open
rate uh anywhere between up to 15% and
higher are usually good open
rates okay so that is the analytics that
you can get and then finally what I
really like in MailChimp is that you can
use MailChimp to create landing pages so
if I'm going back to my
campaigns and I'm going to click create
campaign then I can also decide to
create a landing page name of the
landing page is
myo select an audience myo and I'm going
to click
begin yeah and here you
see a number of templates that I can use
for my landing
page yeah so very simple templates so
let's take this
template
accept I'm going into the
editor yeah so here is the editor for
the landing pages I can add text I can
do box text I can add dividers images I
can change the text yeah you see here
bandmates yeah that's is the logo I can
change the
logo yeah so I can replace the logo and
I can uh edit a logo and what have you
I'm going to stick with this text for
the time being and here is my email
address form yeah and the beauty about
it when people fill in their email
address in this form it will
automatically be added to my mailing
list
list in MailChimp so that is a very
powerful feature I can also create this
as a separate
form okay
so so here you see the available fields
that I have email I can add first name
if I want to yeah I can add last name
and I can add phone number as
well yep I can then go to the
settings I can do the style different
styles that I can have so this is my
sign up form yeah the button text is
subscribe I can then also send visitors
to a confirmation message I can preview
the confirmation message success you've
been added to the
audience yeah exit
preview yep and that is my signup form
and again it will automatically be added
to my campaign uh email list and I click
save and close yep and here is the full
campaign yeah and when I'm happy with it
I can click save and
close so here is my landing
page and it's now here I have the page
title and site icon here's the social
share preview here is the URL of my C my
landing page here is the
content and I can then get
my finish it later or I can publish it
and as soon as I publish it this URL
will be
live yeah so click
publish so this landing page is now live
so if I now go to this landing
page yeah so here you see email address
I'm
saying uh um
Cherry
oh Cherry at hungry.com
com and that is
Cherry hry and I say
subscribe so now let's check the litmus
test if I go to my contacts and I'm
going to all my
contacts and here we have cherry HRI the
famous Arsenal football player who has
just joined my mailing list so that is
the power of
MailChimp imagine it's the year
2004 this is Phil Phil's looking to
release a book and set up a Blog he's
sure that it'd be successful but he's
only worried about one thing he doesn't
know how to ensure that his book reaches
the right target audience who could
enjoy his book during that period of
time however there were only a few forms
of advertisement available like print
ads Billboards radio Direct Mail direct
sales and the television all of these
options were pretty expensive their
effectiveness couldn't be accurately
determined and they didn't let him
advertise his content to the appropriate
audience PHS book would never find the
audience it deserved now let's have a
look at the same scenario in the present
day alongside traditional forms of
advertising Phil would have access to
digital marketing a form of marketing
that's a lot more lucrative inexpensive
and configurable marketing that would
enable marketers to advertise Their
audience digitally using channels like
search engines websites social media
platforms emails Etc among these types
social media marketing caught Phil's eye
social media marketing would give Phil
the opportunity to take advantage of
social media platforms to advertise his
content to a highly targeted audience it
would help more people learn about his
book increase the interaction with his
audience It's relatively inexpensive
unless he goes into advertising and will
help him get Marketplace insights that
might help in understanding his audience
preferences better Phill started by
taking up a certification to learn about
social media marketing since he was
already familiar with the concept of
social media marketing his next step was
to learn about the different types of
content he could post on social media
some of the most common forms of content
content that Phil could post would be
images text posts holes and videos but
over time Phil begin to notice that not
a lot of people were being exposed to
his content Phil needed to advertise his
content for that he would need to use
the advertising options provided by the
social media platforms like Facebook
Instagram YouTube LinkedIn and Twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text they also have a call to action
that encourages user interaction Phil
could use images from his book advertise
websites that sell his book and more
then there are text and post ads these
ads could advertise posts or excerpts
from Phil's blog or his book further
garnering interest from an interesting
audience he could also use video ads
Phil could use video ads that feature
favorable reviews and customer
testimonials to advertise his book
Phil could also use lead ads through
which he could collect information from
users who are interested in a Weekly
Newsletter or regular updates from his
blog but that wasn't the only thing Phil
could do with social media platforms he
could create a brand for himself and
drive audience interest to it engage
with them create an identity engage with
content finding content that works for
him social media platforms also allowed
him the opportunity to Target audiences
based on demographics like their age
location gender and much more and in
time Phil began to see an increase in
the number of viewers coming to his
social media page and by extension his
blog he also saw an increase in the
number of people who bought his book
greatly increasing his audience here are
some things he learned one to set goals
that were quantitative smart and follow
a constant deadline two to understand
his audience by engaging and connecting
with them three to set up a social media
calendar to plan competitions polls
surveys videos and more four using tools
like buzz Sumo ift buffer and more for
lead generation creating email lists
setting buyer personas and more five to
perform visual storytelling with the
help of images and videos but how did
Phil get so good at Social Media
Marketing before we find the answer to
that question let's have a look at a
quiz what can you do with social media
marketing a create create a brand for
yourself B engage with an audience C
Target users based on demographics D all
of the above choose the right answer and
have a chance to win an Amazon voucher
now back to our question how did Phil
get so good at Social Media Marketing
Phil had taken up simply learns digital
marketing course it was thanks to this
course that Phil had the skills and
training to get good at social media
marketing and now you can too by
clicking on the top right corner and
with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing social media
marketing actually means what is it yeah
and we got to put this in the context of
the definition of
marketing yeah I studied Marketing in
the very early days in the 80s and um my
main sort of uh Guru in marketing was
Philip Cotler and over the years
marketing has sort of developed from
traditional marketing to online
marketing but the basic concept has not
changed if you look at the definition of
marketing it's the activity of creating
communicating delivering and exchanging
offerings that have value for
customers yeah so you supply you deliver
you to exchange products or services
that have a value for your
customers so two very important aspects
here there is value and there is
customer and that is what we capture in
the marketing concept you put the
customer at the core of what you do yeah
because when you do that you
automatically will look at what value
are we giving to the
customer yep so take social media
marketing in that context then the
second part of the social media
marketing sort of term is the word
social media what is social media when I
explain social media I'm using the three
C's the three C's of social media
marketing and they are content they're
community and
campaigns
content is the fuel of your social media
content is the um the currency of social
media if you have really good content
that you can share on the internet yeah
using various multip multiple social
media channels like Facebook like
YouTube or like video or like Instagram
or blogging you name it yeah people will
engage with your
content and then when people start
engaging with your content they may come
back for more content that you supply
and they will then become part of your
community so Community is a very
important aspect of your social media
definition with really good content you
can create communities and then you can
push that process by running
campaigns yeah and a campaign makes it
relevant for
businesses because when you run a
campaign you have a goal for your
campaign you have an objective you have
a start date you have an end
date yep and that is what social media
marketing is it's all about running
campaigns to develop your communities
with really exciting
content and then you put it into the
marketing context you do that with a
customer at in the core of what you
do yes so if I then take that to a
definition of social media
marketing is very basic it says the use
of social media to develop a company's
brand increase website traffic and boost
sales that is what we call social media
marketing yeah the most important aspect
here is that you need to have an outcome
you need to have a result which is
customer
related and that is where the sales
element comes in you do this to get the
customer to do something and in the end
that is buying your product or your
service yeah so social media marketing
is not the
Tactical combination of your social
media networks yeah to um to reach as
many people there needs to be a goal to
it and when we talk about marketing it
comes down to selling your product or
service with a
value yeah so that is the um kind of the
call to action as it were that comes out
of your social media marketing so keep
that in mind everything you do with your
social media marketing in the end comes
down to reaching your goals or achieving
your objectives of developing your
company's brand increasing website
traffic or growing your
sales now a big benefit that you're
getting these days in D digital
marketing and social media marketing is
data is
intelligence is
knowledge in the early days of marketing
the biggest problem has always been how
to measure the success of your marketing
campaigns if I ran adverts in a magazine
how do I measure the effectiveness if I
do a PR campaign and uh they write about
me in the newspaper how do I measure the
effectiveness of that how can I track
that when somebody buys a product it
actually is as a result of the pr
campaign that I Ran So in the early
preet days yeah we the only way to
measure customer engagement as it were
were through Loyalty cards or credit
cards yeah with a loyalty card you had
some basic custom data through credit
cards you could track transactions but
it's very difficult to relate that to
your marketing then the internet emerged
and all of a sudden I could track
traffic to my
website yeah I could see how many people
visit my website are these people that
visit my website for the first time are
they returning visitors what are the
most popular pages that they see how
long do they stay on my website and are
they actually bu buying my
product yeah so that was a major
advancement of marketing in the early
2000s and then when social media emerged
it all of a sudden became possible to
measure
engagement how many people are having
conversations with us I could even
measure sentiments are people positive
about my brand are they negative about
my Brands I could track the
effectiveness of my marketing
campaigns I could measure the
effectiveness of my advertising
campaigns that I ran online so today's
reality is that we can measure
everything we can measure clicks we can
measure transactions we can measure
engagements we can measure return on
investments yeah and we can now even
take that a step further through
artificial intelligence that we can
actually start making predictions how
people may respond to campaigns that
we're going to be running so it's a very
important aspect of your digital uh your
social media marketing tend to be so
busy putting content out on different
channels that they miss the need and the
value of having a centralized Hub and
what I mean by that is having one place
where all of the collateral that they're
creating for their social campaigns is
actually housed and accessible in one
centralized Hub and in general they do a
pretty good job with social media
they're active on Twitter they have a
YouTube channel they're on Facebook and
Pinterest and all sorts of different
places so what happens is your target
audience can miss a lot because social
media efforts are scattered you know
people who find one type of content they
don't always know hey you also have a
YouTube channel hey you also have an
Instagram channel so they're not
necessarily aware of all the
possibilities now if I actually go into
the Annie's website
now I'm going to find out about their
grants for Gardens program and I've been
a fan of Annie's for years but I had no
idea this program existed until I use
them as an example to go and pull
screenshots for this so it's important
to keep in mind that if you are
utilizing your social channels is a way
to draw people into deeper content on a
site that you own you have much more
flexibility and ability to pass them
through different types of content now
the other thing about having a home base
a place where your content on third
party channels points back to is that
then your social media efforts help
boost your overall marketing efforts
simply because of the way they impact
everything online so for example if
you're using your third party channels
as a way to attract people into deeper
content on your site you're pulling in
traffic focused traffic potentially high
volume traffic and traffic that's
emotionally invested because if they've
seen your content somewhere and chosen
to click into your site they clearly
have an interest it also delivers links
volume of links topical links and
credible links the idea of social
proofing so that has a big potential
benefit for you it can deliver
conversions it can be much easier to get
a conversion once you have someone in an
environment that you have more control
over than to get it out on a third party
Channel even as third party channels are
improving their ability to get those
instant conversions you know we look at
things like Twitter cards even while
those exist you still have more control
over the overall process and your
ability to test and refine it when it's
happening on your site and then finally
this just a way to deliver credibility
because it lets you get out on some of
these channels and demonstrate that
knowledge and offer that teaser content
that says you're here you're present and
you have something to
offer now one of social media's biggest
Powers is the concept of touch Point
okay it's important to understand that
being able to go and meet customers
where they already are and lead them
back to you that's where social channels
truly have their power yes it's also in
the connecting it's also in the ability
to drive engagement and get exposure but
those are your starting points to get
those conversions there's a lot of value
in inviting them back into a place where
they can engage with you on a deeper
level the other thing to understand
about touch points is that the more more
times a consumer sees your brand or
campaign mentioned the more likely they
are to engage with it and again that's
one of those areas of true power and
getting that exposure through social
media so if you look at each of our
little person icons here and you look at
the sort of ripple effect circles that
are spreading out around them view each
of those circles is a post to a social
media channel and maybe the bigger
circles are posted by an influencer in a
specific area and the smaller circles
are posted by you know a friend or maybe
a lesser-known blogger oh years ago with
Candy Crush Saga which was a huge huge
mobile phenomenon here in the United
States most people didn't know about it
until a friend invited them to play and
most people probably got half a dozen
dozen maybe two or three dozen invites
before they took the time to check it
out it takes a lot of exposure a lot of
your friends sharing the same video or
linking to the same news story before
you finally cave and go okay if that
many people think it's worthwhile maybe
I should take a look at it so if you
look at those places where we have one
person being impacted by multiple Ripple
effects that's where we see the highest
likelihood of Engagement and that's
where having a good presence across
social media channels and good social
sharing across social media channels
gives you those touch points and those
ability to draw people into an
experience with your company now most
social media channels have slightly
different reasons for existing
again we we mentioned earlier and we're
going to talk a little bit later about
the fact that it's important to
customize the way you put your content
out there so that it has the highest
likelihood of catching the attention and
being engaged with by consumers so if we
look at things like micr Medias um
Twitter and Tumblr it's a great place to
sort of connect and listen same thing
with forums but as we move down from say
forums to social networks now we're also
looking at building relationships and it
require sort of a frequency of contact
and you can see that each of the
different forms of social channels has a
value to it and a specific thing that it
has the ability to accomplish now if
each of your social media efforts
connects back into your home base you
have the ability to pass consumers
through multiple support channels and
you can play each channel to their
strength to again create a better
experience where people can then come in
and engage with you on sort of your
owned media on the home base or the blog
or the area that you have created now a
great example of this of leveraging
touch points is a company called smarty
had a party um it's a party planning
site they sell um high-end disposable uh
party products you know plates and
glasses and things like that and they do
an excellent job of using blog content
and social channels to attract visits
and then leading buyers from the blog
into their sales process so for example
you can see here a Facebook post they
put up that talks about a new product
that they've just released they had a
contest that went with it and they gave
free product away for a couple people
and they linked into a blog post that
they put together that says here's how
to use this product to create favor or
an appetizer or something that you can
use at your next party now when you look
at the blog post they put up and you
zoom in a little bit you'll see that at
the bottom they had a link to go and buy
the product so they're using the
Facebook post and a teaser to draw
people into their website where they can
give more information get them more
actively engaged and then eventually
push them into that conversion funnel
that's an example of leveraging targeted
touch points on a specific social media
channel to draw someone into a home base
now let's see this approach in action
and how we can take one of the ways that
uh companies tend to use social media
and make a slight tweak but really make
a big difference in their ultimate
impact so an example here is Bader
flowers a small florist in the US that
was using YouTube to sell boxwood trees
for Christmas several years ago and they
ended up making a couple mistakes and
what's really interesting is I was
actually doing a webinar once where I
included them as an example and they
were actually on the call because it was
a florist webinar and they did end up
implementing some of these changes and
said it worked out really really great
so several years ago I was on Twitter
and I saw this tweet come by that said
boxwood trees are now available for
Philadelphia Flower delivery your cat
will love them too it linked from
Twitter over to YouTube where there was
a little homemade YouTube video about
sort of the owner's grandson decorating
this little boxwood tree and then I
think they took it off to a relative
that might have been in a nursing
facility you know where they couldn't
have a full Christmas tree cute video
does a decent job of making me go hey
that might be really good for my
grandmother or my great aunt now there's
a couple challenges here one of the big
ones is that you have to actually go and
look for the links there weren't there
wasn't anything embedded you know they
didn't have the call outs with the link
straight into to go bu the product so
you had to actually look around and see
if you could figure out what the URL was
or go back and Run a search for it of
course that's all assuming you don't get
distracted by all of the you know up
next or related videos and run off down
a rabbit trail that you know 20 minutes
later you find yourself going oh my
goodness why did I even come to YouTube
in the first place we know that tends to
happen there so assuming you stayed
focused and you actually found that link
and you clicked into the site when I
clicked into the site there were no
boxwood trees and I looked all over for
boxwood trees I even used the search
function to look for boxwood trees and
most people don't tend to use the search
function they just go right back to
Google and they run a search again but
as I was clicking around I realized that
they actually had a Blog which means
they had the opportunity to write a
great post about the benefit of using
boxwood trees for aging relatives or in
small apartments and to embed that video
right there into the blog post because
by embedding it into the blog post now
they're removing some of the
distractions of being in that YouTube
environment and they're allowing me to
be in their blog environment where
they're controlling what the layout
looks like on top of that they also have
the ability to put an image and an add
to cart and a call to action button
right there in the same blog post to
lead me into where I can purchase that
boxwood tree instead of making me hunt
around and look for it now if you
consider the difference of making these
slight changes and you look at the
before and after you'll see that the way
they had it set up I had to be on
Twitter see that the tweet on Twitter
click into the video watch the video
look around for the URL to the site and
you know ignore all the other
distractions on YouTube click through to
the site search for the boxwood tree
read all the pricing and then click to
order now if you use this Homebase
mentality now now when I'm on Twitter
and I see this link and I click I come
into the blog post and I can watch the
video right there on the blog post I can
view the pricing information right there
on the blog post and then I can click to
order that's two clicks instead of seven
different steps up in the first one now
if you know anything about conversion
optimization you know that the fewer
steps that you have the higher the
ultimate conversion rate so again very
very big difference and that's just in
the conversion process that doesn't even
count the inbound links the potential
for traffic traffic that might click
around to other areas of the site and be
interested in a purchase lots of
benefits to looking at it from this New
Perspective now a final word of advice
is that social media provides an amazing
opportunity to make a connection with
customers it's great to get out there on
different channels and really engage but
you need to remember to invite them into
your conversion funnel and a lot of
times that's going to mean inviting them
into your site or inviting them into
some point of conversion activity that
gives you the ability to contact and
engage with them in the future time to
talk about the social media marketing
platforms let's have a look at some of
the most relevant ones out there now but
before that let's make sure that you
understand the essence of the social
media marketing platforms how do they
work very simple they all work according
the same concept what you do you create
an account on the social platform like
Facebook for instance you fill in your
profile on Facebook you put in a lot of
data about yourself on Twitter a little
yeah so you fill in your profile and
once your profile is ready you're going
to connect with friends or follow and be
followed there some platforms when you
send somebody a connection request or a
friend request request when they accept
your mutually connected
like Facebook and like LinkedIn other
platforms like Twitter and like
Instagram when you follow somebody
doesn't mean that that person follows
you yeah so we're talking about
followers and following as it were yep
and then when you've got that you're
going to start sharing updates and
you're going to check your news feed
where you will see the updates from your
friends
now as a business every platform enables
you to create a Facebook page or to
create a page yeah and what you want to
do you create your page you put in your
company information you brand it to your
company branding guidelines and then you
get people to follow or like your
Facebook page or your LinkedIn page yep
and then you start sharing updates and
people that liked your page they may see
your company updates in their
feeds and this is what we call organic
reach so you do a post as a business and
then the people that follow you will see
your posts on their personal news
feed now in the early days of social
media this organic reach could be 40 to
50% which means that if you have 10,000
followers on Facebook so 10,000 people
liked your Facebook page 5,000 of those
people would see your update on their
personal news feed which is
fantastic and that was in the early days
for social media many Brands they spent
lots of marketing building huge
communities because it was a fantastic
free way of reaching out to your
Market nowadays things have changed
Facebook has been driving this yeah
Facebook wants you to advertise on
Facebook all these social media
platforms they have to make money so
they have advertising sort of on their
platform and they want you to use
advertising so over the years Facebook
has lowered organic reach to less than
3% so again if you have 10,000 people
that like your Facebook page fewer than
300 people may see your updates in their
feet and Facebook says hey that's the
way it is we offer you a fantastic
marketing environment and we need to
make money as well so hey yeah start
advertise on Facebook to reach your
entire audience and businesses Now
understand that they now know that
social media is pay to playay to reach
your audience it's no longer
relying on organic reach you have to pay
to use payperclick advertising or PPC
but we're going to talk about that in
the next
videos all right so it's very important
that you understand this concept of how
social media marketing platforms work so
let's start with the first one the
biggest one Facebook with 1.9 billion
active users worldwide
fact is that over the years the younger
generation has left
Facebook yeah why have they left
Facebook because it's not cool anymore
yeah and their parents are on it yeah so
if you want to reach the young teens ear
late teens early 20s don't go to
Facebook you want to be on social
networks like Snapchat or Tik Tok if
that's a available in your market now
there's still markets where Facebook is
enormous yes so they are the leading
social media Network in your Market if
that is the case then of course you have
to be on Facebook but in general we can
say that the audience for Facebook is
now a slightly older audience Generation
X or Millennials it's still a really
good Network to reach these people
particularly when you talk about about
consumer type products now what does
Facebook offer you as a business to use
Facebook has the Facebook page that you
can create to reach your audience
nowadays Facebook really would like you
to use Facebook
groups Facebook groups is a fantastic
area in Facebook where you can get
really good
engagement and as a business you can
offer a group to your customers as a VIP
area or a product knowledge area or a
pre-launch area or just for your
customers yeah lots of Reason lots of
areas where you can use a group to reach
your
customers then there's Facebook
Messenger of course that you can use for
your business where you can set up Bots
yeah so you can have sort of all
automated conversations with your
customers on Facebook messenger and
there is Facebook live don't ignore
Facebook live Facebook loves you to use
Facebook live the beauty about using the
Facebook live it gives you sort of Buzz
and engagement before the event during
the event and after the
event yeah we call this tent pole
marketing you can build up excitement
leading up to the event and after the
event as
well and then finally of course Facebook
is betting heavily on the metaphors yes
so it's Mark Zuckerberg's Vision that
instead of engaging with your friends in
a news feed you engage with them in a
virtual world now the verdict is out if
this is going to work but fact is that
although we've been talking about
virtual and augmented reality for years
it is here now yeah there's more and
more apps becoming available on your
mobile on your desktop that use
augmented
reality and virtual reality I can now
download Ikea place I think it's called
where you just open up the app you pick
a product from the catalog like a table
and then you can just position that
table in your living
room yeah and then you can move it
change the color of it or whatever yeah
using augmented reality through your um
your
camera okay so that is Facebook let's
look at the next one Instagram I love
Instagram yeah a lot of users from
Facebook have gone to
Instagram why because it is a visual
social media platform and it has
inherently higher engagement than
Facebook it's easier to reach the
audience not just your friends friends
yeah so lots of cool features in
Instagram one of the coolest features is
the Instagram
stories yep and people now spend more
time on the stories than on the uh the
timeline where they see the posts so
Instagram started as a photo sharing app
very simple yeah you made a photo you
put a filter on top of it which almost
felt like you're a photographer and then
you share it with hashtags and you saw
immediately the likes coming in and
people loved it for its Simplicity and
now it has grown to a fully featured
social media Network that businesses can
use to make their brand come to life via
photos and Via
Stories the audience is slightly younger
than the Facebook um audience but a more
and more mature audience is coming com
on there as well and it's it initially
it had very much a business to Consumer
Focus but nowadays it's not just photos
that you can share you can share visuals
I can turn a blog post into a carousel
of five
visuals yep and um in that way share
really good
content so very powerful and very useful
for
businesses to reach the audience that
hangs out on on
Instagram all right so that is Instagram
let's look at the next one and that is
YouTube now YouTube of course is not
just for watching video YouTube is a
fantastic social media platform to build
an audience of
followers yeah it's a great platform to
monetize your video video as well by
enabling advertising to be shown before
or during your videos a lot of video
creators they do that yeah and YouTube
has a program for that if you qualify by
um number of views that you have on your
video and number of uh and and the size
of your audience you can participate in
this program and it is a really good way
to make money on you for many content
creators now check out our earlier check
out our earlier video on how to create a
YouTube channel to find out how you can
set up a YouTube channel and how you can
use YouTube as a social media
platform YouTube is great for brand
awareness and since it's owned by Google
it's also really helpful for your search
rankings both on YouTube and on Google
Google Google and there's lots of
different videos of course that you can
make yeah videos that do well are
typical videos like howto videos
unpacking videos Vlogs video blogs we
call them review videos live videos lots
and lots of ways to reach the video your
audience yeah on um with video on
YouTube so the typical audience that
uses you YouTube are basically everybody
from young to old but very important to
understand with YouTube that people are
there for a reason they search for
something they may search for
entertainment they may also search for
answers to their questions which is
different than the videos you would have
on uh Facebook for instance yeah so
Facebook is very good for brand
awareness
where YouTube videos are very good for
um for lead generation for instance and
for building relationship with your your
audience good a very interesting social
media platform that emerged around 10
years ago is
Snapchat they have around 300 plus
million daily active
users and let me tell you a bit about
the history of Snapchat Snapchat was a
response to Facebook's problems about 10
years ago in
privacy and um not being cool anymore
and particularly the Privacy issue where
in those days a lot of people said who
is owning my photos on U on Facebook
yeah um is it Facebook or is it myself
so a lot of people and that there has
always been a gray area yeah combined
with Facebook not being cool anymore and
you know how important being cool is for
the younger generation yep so fa so two
guys who came up with the idea of doing
something radically different and they
came up with a social media platform
Snapchat where posts would delete
themselves within 24 hours
they built a a user interface around
this which was fairly difficult to
use yeah but that was for a
reason kids they love to explain to each
other how it works and if it's
complicated enough then their parents
won't be able to get on it yeah so kids
love that idea it's too complicated to
use for my parents so I really have my
own social media world yeah in Snapchat
that nobody else has access to so
particularly the teens the Generation Z
yeah was very uh keen and they were very
hot on the uh on Snapchat so it was the
new place for Facebook users to go to
and they grew ever since steadily not
huge but they are there and they are a
very powerful social Network
particularly when you want to Target the
younger generation now there are two
major features that they sort of drove
into social media land which was the
stories and second the vertical videos
so you all know the concept of the story
it self deletes in 24 hours but it
turned um social media instead of sort
of scrolling through your news feed you
swipe from story to story much more
visual much more fun much more
engaging yep and you would swipe those
stories vertically and that
automatically led to using vertical
video and vertical video is a major
Trend in social media content yeah which
is picked up by um by Tik Tok as the
main format for for videos on Tik Tok
YouTube have shorts so all social media
now networks they now have stories and
they have vertical video as a key
element yeah so vertical video
particularly for short 10 12 second
videos which we call snackable content
is very important why would you tilt
your phone to watch your video why not
just use it vertical which is also a
quite an interesting um sort of form
factor to get a good engagement on your
videos finally Snapchat has very
Innovative advertising
features yeah they have lenses they have
stories they have filters you can put a
filter over your face BMW had a really
good campaign to launch a new car where
you could place the car through a lens
anywhere that you liked in augmented
reality and you could actually put a
filter where you gave yourself a golden
face yeah so very powerful advertising I
think the the WhatsApp advertising
platforms is one of the best advertising
platforms out there it's also probably
one of the most expensive um advertising
platforms of all social media
networks right so let's look at
Twitter I call Twitter SMS on
steroids yeah it was one of the first
besides Facebook one of the first social
media platforms that came out and it was
a very exciting platform when it
launched and Twitter relied heavily on C
celebrities using it to drive acceptance
on a global scale yeah and many music
stars rock stars actors they started
using Twitter and that drove the global
adoption of the uh the platform now what
makes Twitter so power powerful there
are three aspects on Twitter first of
all you can retweet a tweet yeah so when
you send a tweet and I follow you I
receive your Tweet if I just click on
retweet it'll go to all my followers
yeah if somebody in my follower base
retweets that tweet your Tweet can go
viral without uh in in in in minutes Y
and there's various examples of tweets
that went viral um within minutes yeah
like the um which was it a selfie tweet
during the Oscar s ceremony a few years
ago yes so it is um so the retweeting is
very
powerful it also makes it instant yeah
because of this retweeting aspect news
goes on in on Twitter instantly and it
shares to a global audience instantly so
that makes it very very powerful for
news agencies as well and for businesses
a very powerful feature of Twitter is
the Twitter search each tweet is indexed
and you can
search in all the tweets you can search
for the very first tweet that was ever
sent yeah so that makes it very powerful
for Brands to find content so Twitter is
really good for finding jobs for
instance because lots of businesses they
tweet about I'm looking for a marketing
manager or a web developer so if I
search for web developer # jobs that
tweet will show up in my search
results one problem that Twitter had is
that they did not keep up with the
developments in social media platform
functionality yeah so most celebrities
went to Instagram because Instagram was
much more visual much better place for
celebrities to engage with their U their
fans so Twitter lagged behind and in the
last few years it clearly repositioned
itself so it now is seen as a great way
for businesses to use as a communication
and service Channel with their customers
and for media companies to share the
latest news so if you want to find out
what is happening in the world now or
what businesses are doing now or if you
have a problem with a product from a
business Twitter is the best place to be
and for you individual as I always say
you don't need to be on Twitter to tweet
but you must be on Twitter to find great
content to
search whether you want to search for
jobs or whe you searching for
opportunities if you're a photographer
yeah and you in London for instance and
you go to Twitter and you search for
looking for wedding photographer London
you get a list of tweets of people who
are tweeting I'm looking for a wedding
photographer does anybody know
anybody yeah so extremely powerful to uh
to use for lead
generation right so what about Pinterest
Pinterest is a visual bookmarking
platform it's very cool the concept is
simple you see a photo on the website
that you like yeah what you can then do
you can pin that photo on Pinterest in a
board yeah and you're not copying the
photo you're just copying the link in
your board so by doing that you can
build fantastic collections of visuals
that you like and want to
organize so I bought a house in Marakesh
a number of years ago in Morocco and we
needed to design the interior so we had
a board with Morocco design we had a
board with Morocco riads we had a board
with um tying and what have you and we
just build up a whole collection of
ideas that we liked and then we got the
people that helped us in in making the
things that we wanted and we could just
share them the links on Pinterest of the
ideas that we had work really
well now because you can save those
Boards of course you can then share them
as well yeah so everybody can access
your boards which means that it becomes
a great tool for getting ideas and
Inspirations from boards from other
people so if you want ideas for home
design or your wedding or fashion
Pinterest is a fantastic place to get
inspiration another major benefit for
businesses is that you can put your
product catalog on Pinterest as visuals
organized in boards yep and then when
people find those products on in on
Pinterest and they click on them it will
take them to the cat calog of your
website where they can buy your product
so it's a great way to drive additional
traffic to your website if you want to
see a good example for that go to the
Ika UK um Pinterest page and look at
their boards you see boards for small
living room ideas back to school
Christmas holiday celebrations and then
you get lots of ideas with um for
instance for small living rooms and then
you click on some of the products that
you see and that takes you to the page
on the Ikea catalog website where you
can buy the product now Pinterest is
very popular amongst women amongst
Millennials and it also has very
powerful advertising
features and then LinkedIn LinkedIn is
serious yeah I call LinkedIn Facebook
with a tie where Facebook is fun
LinkedIn is serious in Facebook you can
get away with a funny profile photo in
LinkedIn your photo needs to be
professional now if you go to
linkedin.com
sales
SSI you get your Social selling index
and that is a score between one and 100
of how good you are on LinkedIn and you
will see
in the score in the summary that are
four components that contribute to your
SSI score or four components that
contribute to how well you do on
LinkedIn so those four are your
profile yeah your activity level in
connecting with
people how much content you share and
your activity level in building
relationships with
people yeah so the better you do in
those four areas to higher your score
your profile of course is very important
make sure that your LinkedIn profile is
as complete as possible now linkedin's
biggest challenge as I mentioned earlier
is to get people to engage and share
content so how does LinkedIn make money
very simple there are four areas where
they make money first of all they allow
people to to upgrade their LinkedIn
account to a premium account where they
get more
features there is a whole section in
LinkedIn specifically for
recruiters yeah so a recruiting version
of LinkedIn there is a whole area for
sales we call this sales
Navigator yeah if you run a sales team
that use LinkedIn of course you want to
keep the customer data so you're getting
a sort of customer relationship
management system within LinkedIn when
you sign up for sales Navigator and then
there is LinkedIn
advertising LinkedIn of course is best
for businesso business and it's really
good for developing your personal online
profile as long as you share content
through publishing articles and sharing
uh sharing posts so I
been operational on LinkedIn from the
very beginning and I shared lots and
lots of content and articles on LinkedIn
and I got lots of business coming in
through Linkedin yeah we're talking
about serious amounts of business that I
did by being on LinkedIn so you got to
be on LinkedIn if you are in
business right now one thing that I will
will not talk about here is uh is Tik
Tok yeah we haven't got a slide for that
but bear in mind Tik Tok although it's
not available in India um Tik Tok is a
very important social media Network
these days which thrives a whole new
format of uh of of engaging and
communication but more about that that
later now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and
tricks number one setup your
goals now what good will your actions do
if you don't have a goal in mind the
goal of your marketing strategy may be
the driving force behind every decision
that you make and this is exactly why
setting up goals is very important
moreover your marketing efforts have to
align with the goals of the
organization here are some things that
you need to keep in mind while setting
up your goals first of all your goals
need to be quantitative for example you
need to have a th000 conversions by the
end of the quarter or 5,000 followers on
Instagram by the end of the month and so
on number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your options number three
make sure your goals are smart now smart
refers to specific measurable attainable
relevant and
time-based now let's go to number four
like I mentioned earlier your goals need
to be aligned with the marketing
strategy and alongside these goals there
also needs to be the Northstar metric
now what is the Northstar metric well
this represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this Northstar
metric will also give your team Clarity
and
focus now let's have a look at some
popular northstars there's increased
engagement ment greater conversion rates
more leads generated app downloads and
so on now let's go to number two
understanding your
audience social media allows you to
interact engage and build relationships
with your Audience by understanding what
they need want and desire you can
deliver content in a way that makes your
product or service the answer that
they're looking
for there are also other ways that you
can understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them the age demographics of
Their audience by conversing with them
in forums responding to their comments
and blogs and social media taking up
their feedbacks of suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learn's audience is predominantly
working professionals and graduates
unacademy has high school graduates and
BYU app has high school students as
users now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform now when performing social
media marketing choosing the right
platform is really
important When selecting them you need
to ask questions like why you're using
that particular platform who you will
reach with this platform what content
could work best on the platform and is
there any content that was unique to
that platform like for example YouTube
and then there's the
video answering these questions will
help you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn
Facebook Instagram and Pinterest now
let's talk about the purpose of each of
these platforms LinkedIn is a
professional Network that's best suited
for B2B audiences for Facebook well just
about everyone has an account on
it content that is related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook then we have Instagram visual
content works best on Instagram now
although it works well for sta images
and short form video It Doesn't Really
drive a lot of traffic to your website
and then finally we have Pinterest
Pinterest is also limited to static
images however it's highly effective at
driving traffic to your
blog now let's go to number four setting
up a social media
calendar a social media calendar demands
the message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform let's have a look at some of
the most popular types of posts on
social media first off we have
competitions now I'm sure all of you
have seen posts like tag a friend who
does this or comment or like to win
something and stuff like that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag and competitions help
grow your presence on social media then
we have polls and surveys polls can help
you with you need a collection that also
encourages followers to take action and
interact polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't and to receive their
feedback and then we have videos and
live streams although we'll be covering
this in a little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
these will help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and has so
much more to offer live stream with its
live nature and having a human face
alongside your business humanizes your
brain brand and by extension helps
increase customer loyalty and trust and
then there is infographics articles and
images so social media calendars are
successful because of their ability to
increase collaboration within the team
help understand what works and what
doesn't and in distributing resources in
an effective
manner next up we have number five using
social media marketing
tools so social media marketing tools
align to the goals of your organization
with it you can create highquality
content attract new potential customers
and drive engagement and it also helps
you with the planning process you can
plan create and schedule posts on your
social
calendar now some of the more popular
social media tools include buffer hoot
site Buzz Sumo if T and much more now
these tools also help with generating
leads creating email lists finding a
relevant audience to show your content
creating buyer personas providing you
insights on what works and what doesn't
and giving you templates for different
kinds of
posts now for number six visual
storytelling visual storytelling
involves passing out a lot of
information in the simplest of forms
visually using pictures and videos your
followers are able to grasp the message
quickly and remember it for a long time
afterwards visual storytelling is also
not limited by language barriers and
this helps it become interesting and
entertaining to anyone watching it can
also help your audience stay interested
and engaged grab the attention of
potential clients and so much
more but it also has some other
advantages it helps you build a bond
with your audience visual storytelling
connects with your audience methods like
live streaming help humanize your brand
and help grow customer loyalty and trust
it has the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential
customers
so have a look at some of our videos so
here's what is machine learning data
science in 5 minutes and AI in 5 minutes
now these are some of our most viewed
videos on our Channel and now you know
why visual storytelling if you guys are
interested in watching these videos you
can check them out on our Channel
homepage and we also have similar videos
on blockchain devops and Six Sigma but
now back to the list
let's go to number seven paying for
advertising this is a method that helps
you find a Target and reach your
audience with ease it can greatly help
with achieving your organization's
marketing
goal and this can help you improve your
reach and improve your Brand's
visibility it's payperclick model and
shows cost Effectiveness by providing
great results and return on investment
it also helps improve targeting by
letting you control who sees your ad you
get to choose from a number of different
factors like interests Hobbies
personality types alongside the basic
user demographics like age location
gender and so on now since most social
media platforms have native analytics
you also get to assess and Define the
performance of your ad
campaigns now as great as it sounds
there are certain pitfalls that come
along with peer advertising first of all
your audience could get exposed to your
post too many times and tune out your
content disregarding it in the
process second it could get really
expensive for small businesses or
startups to manage a campaign to its
maximum Effectiveness third people could
pass off your content as irrelevant or
unimportant you you also have to deal
with a lot of
competition smaller companies with
lesser budgets have more of an uphill
battle to deal with than better funded
organizations next we have number eight
newsjacking newsjacking is a method that
involves using current events to promote
your own Brands products and services
now it's a popular method that's used to
improve brand awareness newsjacking uses
the popularity of current events
and drives it to your brand it helps
shine a spotlight on your products and
it also helps you show off that you are
up to date with current events in the
industry and that your product is
relevant by extension it also improves
engagement and website
traffic now for number nine AB
testing AB testing is a popular method
for comparing copies creatives and ctas
or call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content AB testing helps determine which
of the variants your audience engaged
with the
most AB testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on and next up number 10 community and
influences
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your Niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the
industry actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up
with and on the other hand partnering up
with influencers helps promote your
products or services to a brand new
audience it helps provide an additional
layer of authenticity in YouTube which
is also a social media platform if you
didn't know here are some very very
popular influencers we have Marcus
brownley unbox therapy Mr who's the boss
and lonus Tech tips each of them with
more than 4 million
subscribers and finally we're at number
11 measuring and analyzing
results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process it ensures that you're
making the most out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand and these metrics can be tracked
weekly monthly or on a quarterly basis
and based on these results appropriate
actions can be
taken so on Facebook you could look out
for reach and engagement on Twitter you
could look out for Impressions clicks
and Impressions and interactions on
LinkedIn and likes comments and mentions
on Instagram and engagements and
Impressions on
Pinterest some of the most popular tools
used for this purpose are Sprout social
buffer HootSuite Google analytics and so
on social media social media social
media do you know how many social media
users are there in the World 4.8 million
and still counting from the purpose of
entertainment to spreading awareness
from learning to taking business to
Great Heights social media have proven
to be an all-in-one solution talking
about social media and the business
World social media has revolutionized
business providing a platform for Direct
Customer interaction targeted marketing
and valuable insights it allows business
to build trust promote their brand and
adapt app to Industry Trends embracing
social media is essential for success in
the digital age with the rise of social
media in this digital age lots of job
opportunities are arising in the market
the average salary of a social media
manager in India is 6 lakhs rupees per
year however in us it is estimated to be
$64,000 per year so without any further
delay let's begin by understanding what
does a social media manager do what does
a social media manager do success social
media management Demands a strategic
approach encompassing various key tasks
here are the social media managers roles
and
responsibilities it begins with crafting
and implementing a goal aligned social
media strategy followed by the creation
of engaging content for diverse
platforms wig in Community Management
involves monitoring and responding
promptly to social media interactions
while campaign management requires adep
planning and result anal analysis social
listening is crucial for extracting
valuable insights from Brand related
conversations analytics and Reporting
form the backbone tracking key
performance indicator and providing
strategic recommendations collaboration
with other departments ensures cohesive
messaging while crisis management skills
address negative situations promptly
staying informed about platform changes
is vital for adaptability and adance to
guidelines ensures legal compliance and
ethical standards this comprehensive yet
concise approach ensures effective
day-to-day operations and long-term
success in the ever evolving landscape
of social media
management so let's see skills required
by a social media manager social media
managers need platform expertise
knowledge of major social media
platforms and features content creation
and creativity strong writing and media
creation skills with Innovation thinking
and engaging content strategy and
analytics strategic thinking and
analytics proficiency is must required
community and engagement effective
communication and Community Management
is required next we have is campaign
execution planning and executing social
media campaigns are must required for
being a social media manager next we
have is adaptability a social media
manager must be flexible to adapt to the
platform changes and Trends next next we
have is collaboration a social media
manager should be great at Teamwork and
collaboration with other departments
time management a social media manager
should be great at efficient task
organization and erance to schedules
problem solving along with that a social
media manager should have a quick
resolution of issues and crisis legal
and ethical awareness last but not the
least a social media manager should be
great at understanding of legal and
ethical consideration also
responsiveness to customer inquiries and
feedbacks will be a cherry on cake so
let's begin by knowing how to become a
social media manager in 2024 achieving a
role of social media manager in 2024
involves a strategic combination of
skills practical experience and ongoing
commitment to staying ahead of Industry
Trends here is a comprehensive guide to
help navigate your path into this
Dynamic field on number one we have
Educational Foundation while formal
education isn't always mandatory having
a degree in marketing Communication
business or any related field can
provide a valuable Foundation consider
pursuing courses or certification Focus
specifically on social media marketing
to augment your knowledge next we have
is skill development cultivate strong
writing skills to craft compelling and
impactful content develop a
comprehensive understanding of social
media platforms their functionalities
and trends familiarize yourself with
social media analytics to effectively
measure and integrate performance basic
graphic design skills or Proficiency in
design tool can enhance your skill set
next is establishing online presence
build and maintain professional profiles
on platforms like LinkedIn Twitter and
Instagram to Showcase your expertise
actively participate in Industry
discussions share relevant content and
engage with your network moving ahead it
is important to gain practice iCal
experience seek internships or
entry-level positions in marketing
public relations or social media to gain
practical experience volunteer to manage
social media accounts for organizations
or events creating a tangible portfolio
stay updated stay updated with latest
trends algorithms changes and emerging
platforms within the social media
landscape attend webinars conferences
and workshops to stay informed and ahead
in the industry developments next we
have is portfolio development compile a
portfolio showcasing your best work
including examples of content creation
Community engagement and successful
campaign management Network
strategically connect with Professionals
in the industry join relevant groups on
social media and actively participate in
the events networking can open doors to
job opportunities and provide valuable
insights into the industry apply for
entry-level roles Target entry-level
positions such as social media
coordinator or assistant to gain
practical experience tailor your resume
and cover letter to highlight relevant
skills and experiences highlight
achievements emphasize tangible results
during interviews utilizing metrics to
quantify your impact such as increased
engagement follower growth or successful
campaign outcomes last but not the least
adaptability and continuous learning is
the must have skill skill Embrace
adaptability in the phase of Industry
changes and commit to ongoing learning
maintain a proactive stance towards the
exploring new tools and strategies to
stay ahead in the dynamic field of
social media management by following
these steps you will position yourself
for a successful career as a social
media manager in 2024 equipped with a
robust skill set and a proactive
approach to the professional development
I hope now you can start your journey of
being a social media man is literally
content marketing um okay what is it so
content marketing Is Not A New Concept
it's been around for over a hundred
years in fact one of the classic
Foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the Michelin Brothers in France
and the Michelin Brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know little refresher
right now were two brothers who made
pneumatic tires and they were trying to
sell them along with an Innovative
product at its time called the
automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my God what was worth going out
there for you know rep Paris it's all
happening here and what the Michelin
Brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more
tires
they had to get people to drive farther
and farther and use them so what did
they come up with the concept that
really is the birth of content Marketing
in my
book was the Michelin
guide and the Michelin guide was unique
in that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the
provinces and the Michelin brothers are
the ones who came up with the one two
and three star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads U but guess what
to dive for the Ratatouille H you you
got to have it this is a three star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way since we're going
to give you a guide and you have to get
out of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way uh which hotels
uh you might want to stay at overnight
and oh by the way just in case you have
to how to repair a flat tire
particularly if it's a Michelin tire
because it's a Pneumatic and you know
what it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the features and benefits of
round or a tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to Their audience about
what Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in
1900 was
food and by creating
content that got the audience to get
into their new Innovative
automobile and drive all the way out
there into the provinces for that
absolutely remarkable three- Star
Restaurant people got more Flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the
way Michelin solds more tires so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of you know hit a pause and like well
we're doing content marketing we need to
come up with a concept think back to the
Michelin guide it's it's a great
foundation so let's let's go to a modern
definition where are we now in the 21st
century when it comes to content
marketing well you can read the slide
here and read the definition and some
people like reading definitions I'm not
going to read it to you but I am going
to highlight a couple of words in the
definition that I think are
absolutely critical to any definition of
content
marketing the content that you create
needs to be
relevant and it also has to be
valuable now if it's not relevant then
you're not actually meeting my needs or
interests you know and why would I be
interested in them and we've gotten way
too tired of screening out the
commercial that comes on um you know
trying to sell us snow tires and pardon
me we live in Florida I don't use snow
tires what what the heck is this
commercial doing you know interrupting
what I'm watching
so relevance is important relevance
means that this content isn't going to
get screened out and the valuable the
valuable can can work in a lot of
different ways it can be interesting it
can be useful you know value is an
interesting proposition all by
itself but that's the key to content
marketing uh it's not just creating more
spam it's not just throwing more trash
over the fence and hook something
happens this is something where if
you've created valuable and relevant
content you know what your customers
will find you it's a whole different
kind of
proposition I know there's some Skeptics
who are saying oh come on come on come
on content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're going to deal with
that in module
three but let me just be clear here
social media content is part of what
content marketing needs to create but it
can also create content for your website
and that's not the social media it can
also create content that U your PR
people can share with uh uh reporters or
bloggers and that's not normally
considered uh social media content and
by the way all of that content can be
optimized so maybe it actually is part
of SEO not social media marketing in
fact that's the other place that content
marketing really
overlaps and it's not
coincidental it so happens that around
February
2011 when Google rolled out the first of
its multiple versions of the panda
update all of a sudden even seos started
to pay attention to content marketing
why because Google changed the rules and
what Google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant you
know what it's not going to rank very
well in our search
algorithm and all of a sudden people
who' been used to like putting keywords
in the right places realized content
matters you mean I've got to actually
tell stories that are interesting I've
got to create information that's
valuable yeah yeah you can make it
relevant that's the optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash God bless you good luck so yeah
content marketing has grown it's like
tripled in terms of web search interest
since the panda update and we're talking
about Panda 1 of course there was Panda
2 Panda three Panda four I mean come on
Google is driving us in this direction
and so content marketing is pretty
relevant today
now one of the other things that uh
people in content marketing struggle
with is oh but you don't understand I do
B2B content marketing or I'm a small
business or pardon me I'm an Enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right well possibly maybe on
occasion so let's just question that
assumption for a
second you know content marketing has
been around now long enough and enough
people have done it that some research
has been conducted and it's been
conducted against B Toc marketers and BB
marketers and small business marketers
and Enterprise level
marketers and when they start asking key
questions like okay we're going to try
to determine what is the difference
between an effective content marketer
and an ineffective content
marketer let's see the results well
first first of all the most important
thing to Be an Effective B Toc content
marketer is you need a documented
content
strategy oh okay all right mean people
who are winging it aren't as uh
effective as people who actually have
thought about this and written it down
got it okay no great Insight but you
know interesting to note secondly they
got to have somebody in charge who
overseas content marketing oh Lord does
that mean we have to have a reorg or
maybe we just have to designate somebody
who reports to somebody else whatever
but guess what it really helps if
somebody is driving this
process third they've got to be using
more content marketing tactics than
their less effective
peers and this is not an argument more
is better this is just pardon me that's
the way the data falls out the people
who are actually more effective are
doing more different kinds of
things a broader range of
tactics and who knows maybe it's that
broader range that's part of the success
formula same thing is true with social
media
platforms the effective content
marketers are using more than the
ineffective ones and last but not least
and this may be a sort of a result of
the first four
by gosh effective content marketers
generally have greater
percentage of the overall marketing
budget in their
organization wow okay that's the b2c
marketing formula but you don't
understand I'm not a b2c
marketer okay so let's take a look at
the B2B content marketing
formula guess what you need to have a
documented content marketing strategy to
Be an Effective
B2B content marketer you need to have
someone who oversees content marketing
strategy it helps if you are using more
tactics and more social media platforms
and guess what you spend a higher
percentage of your overall marketing
Budget on content marketing well that's
similar to the B Toc content marketers
but do you understand B2B is different
yeah there's a couple small differences
but guess what over all the top five
criteria are similar and when you get to
small business here's what you're going
to see same five
criteria and you're in an Enterprise I
know the world is different for
Enterprises actually not so much so four
different data points let's net it out
there's a pattern and the pattern is is
I don't care what flavor of content
marketer you are you can be B Toc B2B
you can be small business you can be
large Enterprise at the end of the day
there are five things that you've got to
focus on if you want to be
effective we've already covered these
and are there differences between small
businesses and large Enterprises between
B2B and B Toc well
sure but they're all at the
margin what's the downside if we don't
do this you know is anyone going to come
in and like whack us the answer is um
maybe not inside your boardroom but it
may happen on the next sales call that
one of your salespeople makes they may
encounter someone I like to call the man
in the chair and the Man in the chair
actually refers back to a classic McGraw
Hill ad campaign from I think the
1960s but basically the guy in the chair
asks theoretically some questions from
quote maybe your salesperson okay I
don't know anything about you I don't
know about your company I don't know
about your company's product I don't
know about your company's you know
reputation or anything about you and so
what was it you were going to try to
sell me and that's the downside of not
having a Content marketing
program content marketing has been
around for over a hundred years but in
the online World customers are behaving
in l lots of new ways and they're
consuming content on various kinds and
types of devices and that changes things
content marketing is now about creating
content that consumers will engage with
and act upon not just read or listen to
or watch so in this introductory module
we're going to provide you with an
understanding of how content marketing
affects the decisionmaking process when
when people are on the customer journey
to making a purchase and with a solid
content marketing strategy your
customers buying decisions can actually
uh happen faster you can basically uh
shorten the decision making process and
you can reach and expand um to new
prospects so one of the things that we
hope that you're going to uh learn after
uh basically taking this module uh you
should be able to do the following first
of all you can Define content marketing
and other related Concepts secondly you
should be able to explain why content
needs to be relevant and valuable in
order for it to be effective third you
need to describe uh the overlap between
content marketing SEO social media
marketing fourth you need to name five
trades
of effective content
marketers and last but not least you
need to explain the benefits of content
marketing these are our objectives and
hopefully they're going to be your
learning
outcomes so content marketing Is Not A
New Concept it's been around for over a
100 years in fact one of the classic
Foundation stories of you know the birth
of content marketing goes all the way
back to the Michelin Brothers in France
and the Michelin Brothers you know in
case you haven't done your history
that's okay you know little refresher
right now were two brothers who made
pneumatic tires and they were trying to
sell them along with an Innovative
product at its time called the
automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible in a place France where
frankly people didn't like to get
outside of Paris and into the provinces
because my gu God what was worth going
out there for you know we're Paris it's
all happening here and what the Michelin
Brothers realized is if they wanted to
sell more
tires they had to get people to drive
farther and farther and use them so what
did they come up with the concept that
really is the birth of content Marketing
in my
book was the Michelin
guide and the Michelin guide was unique
in that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the
provinces and the Michelin brothers are
the ones who came up with the one two
and three star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to dive for the Ratatouille H you
you got to have it this is a three star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip
and oh by the way since we're going to
give you a guide and you have to get out
of Paris in order to get there we're
going to tell you where you can find
gasoline along the way uh which hotels
uh you might want to stay at overnight
and oh by the way just in case you have
to how to repair a flat tire
particularly if it's a Michelin tire
because it's a Pneumatic and you know
what is it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the features and benefits of
round or a tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature and
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to Their audience about
what Their audience was truly passionate
about which in Paris in 1900 was
food and by creating content
that got the audience to get into their
new Innovative
automobile and drive all the way out
there into the provinces for that
absolutely remarkable three- Star
Restaurant people got more Flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by the
way Michelin solds more tires so that
that's a great story every time you sort
of you know hello everyone and welcome
to this Google analytics full course
video by simply learn today we will
understand Google analytics which is the
best analytical tool provided by Google
to check up on our website we will
understand how Google analytics Works
how we can use it to measure the
performance of our website we'll also
understand how to set up goals and
create events that will help us keep our
website on track next we will look at
Google tag manager and towards the end
we will unlock the mystery of how to
rank at number one position on Google
it's not that hard as you think it is we
have Rob with us who has more than 15
years of experience in digital marketing
and analytics and he will take us
through these topics over to you rob
welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learn and today we're going
to talk about Google analytics I'm very
excited to be with you today because
Google analytics is one of my favorite
Google platforms and my favorite topics
so let's talk about what we're going to
cover today and we're going to start out
with how to set up a Google analytics
account and so we're going to talk about
everything that entails including
creating your Google analytics account
we're going to talk about setting up a
property in your account and what a
property is we're going to talk about
setting up a reporting view in your
property and we're going to talk about
in installing the tracking code so those
are the series of steps we're going to
go through today in terms of setting up
a Google analytics account so let's get
right to it and so really the bru
prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a Google analytics account is
to have a Google login and ID so when
you actually go to Google analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're going to walk through a series of
steps but really that's really all you
need to get the account going is a
Google ID and login so if you have a
Gmail account or other email account
that you use for other Google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for Google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new Google Analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be the name of your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here I'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the URL for this website
demo simply learn is going to be demo.
simplylearn dcom so that's the property
when we talk about properties in
analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
this is important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
okay and I'm going to talk about why
that's important important here in a
minute and then you're going to choose
your time zone and the time zone is also
important because that's when the DAT
starts in analytics then the day ends
based on that time zone so the data that
Google analytics collects starts and
ends with that time zone so very
important to choose the time zone your
business is located in okay and then you
have some additional options here okay
so you have some settings and so the
first setting is to allow Google
products and services so if you opt into
this then basically what Google's going
to do is share some products and
services with you via email I would go
ahead and opt into that that's of course
recommended by Google it doesn't hurt to
hear from Google on related products and
services that may enhance your business
the second is benchmarking so
benchmarking to me is something you
should opt into so going back to that
industry and category we chose jobs and
educ tion so by opting into benchmarking
basically what Google's going to do is
share your data that it collects on your
website in this case demo. simplylearn
docomo with others in the industry in
this case jobs and education and because
you've opted in it's going to do the
same exact thing for you it's going to
share Anonymous data on other websites
in the same industry and the benefit of
that is we get to see what other
websites or how other websites are
performing compared to ours what's the
Benchmark in our industry and so the
benchmarking to me is important and I'm
going to go over that in a few minutes
when we go over the different reports
but to me I would always opt into
benchmarking because this is the only
report Google provides in analytics
about how others in your industries
performing versus versus your website
okay so it's a way to compare your
website performance against others in
the same industry the other options here
technical support and account specialist
I would also recommend you opt into
those because then it allows you to
basically Google allow Google access to
your account and they'll be able to help
you if you occur or run into any issues
so these are the options in setting up a
Google analytics account it's very
simple very easy to do you're just
entering in a few Fields note that we
talking about a website right now so I'm
talking about demo. simplylearn decom
but just know that if you want to track
a mobile app Google analytics will allow
you to do that as well you just choose
the option mobile app so we're tracking
a website we want to know how users
behave when they get to my website and
that's what Google analytics is going to
allow us to measure and look at we just
need to do a couple more steps in the
process so once we fill out these fields
here we're going to click get tracking
ID now I'm going to accept the terms of
service I'm going to accept another
terms and service in relation to data
protection I'm going to click accept
once I accept I'm going to be able to
get some tracking code the tracking ID
is the ID associated with your account
and so this number is going to be
associated with your account so your
account I D starts with UA and it's
going to be this number here now the
dash one is the property you set up so
in this case I set up demo. simplylearn
docomo just know that every property I
set up in that account is going to have
a d
1-2-3-4 Etc depending on how many many
properties I set up so by default I set
up one property so my first property ID
is -1 if I set up a second property the
same account number it's just going to
have a-h to and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID in the snippet of code
now this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or jumo
or even more popular platform like
WordPress adding the tracking code
sitewide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analy plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plugging in
the ID now there's an alternative to
adding the Google analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend commend watching the YouTube
video we have on Google tag manager you
can just go to YouTube Type in simply
learn Google tag manager and this will
give you a nice overview of you what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
to having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associate it with
tag manager if you can associate it with
tag manager then that's the easier route
to go versus putting code on your
website okay so again take a look at the
video we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that's the route I would go now
once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a Plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to basically understand how
Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically what you're going
to do you're going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so if you have a Google
analytics or Google login then all you
need to do is click on access demo
account and so what Google's going to do
is put this demo account into your
account and so it's going to look
something like this if I click on demo
account here it's going to add to my
Google analytics account so I'm going to
have then access to the demo account
from Google in Google analytics so I
would recommend going this route here if
you're not familiar you're not sure what
you're getting yourself into so think of
the demo account as kind of a test drive
you're test driving Google analytics
before you even add any code to your
website so again all you need is a
Google account and if you have a Google
account and you add the demo account to
your Google analytics account you're
going to be able to see how analytics
works okay and so that's what I would
also recommend so if you're not ready to
start adding code to your website then
what you can do is just simply add the
demo account and then once you add the
demo account you're free to peruse
around Google analy to see the different
types of reports it has to offer now
when you do actually set up a Google
analytics account you're going to have
some settings that you're going to want
to pay attention to so when you set up
the account you have the account name
and then you have a property so under
each property you have by default you're
going to have one View and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learn so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
Analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings in
future webinars for advanced Google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to Google analytics anything
from adding users to your Google Google
analytics account your Google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up Google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to Google
analytics but so know those settings are
there they're located right down here
and this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you could
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some Google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customize reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition Behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm an admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that
79% of my users are coming from desktop
18% 20% are coming from mobile and then
approximately 3% of coming from tablet
here I can see how they actually came to
the website so this is the refres
refering Source if they came from say
search or social I can see the source
there and I can see what pages they're
active on and then here I could see what
locations where they're located and so
if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I can see a majority of
my users are coming from the United
States okay where they coming from I'll
just click on traffic sources and here I
could see the different sources and
mediums medium is the means in which the
traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either paint search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what content
they're looking at on my website so I
can see currently have three active
users on the homepage two active users
on the Google's women's white te page so
forth and so on now most importantly if
you have a event tracking set up so so
if you taking a look at our Google tag
manager webinar you know that you could
set up event tracking in Google
analytics to measure engagement on your
website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
Commerce somebody clicking on the quick
view click some you a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I can
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now I could see I had one active user
who entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you can see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience if is just right underneath
real time I'm going to see a number of
different reports available to me under
audience and so let's click on the
audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessar have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information Etc however we
could still paint a nice picture on who
is coming to our website meaning what
country city or state did they come from
what language AG what device did they
get to our website from how old were
they okay were they male or female or
other what interest did they have what
browser did they use so we can paint a
nice picture based on all this
information that Google analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that's
represents 61% of the users and so
Google analytics does a great job of
giving me an overall percentage so if I
have a 100% of the users I could see 61%
of those users represented
English-speaking users from the United
States 7% represented English-speaking
users from Great Britain and so when it
comes to analytics we have users and
users are broken down into two
categories they're either returning or
they're new so when you add the Google
analytics tracking script to your
website what's going to happen is if a
user or when a user goes to your website
they're going to get cookied and if it's
the first time they've been to your
website what Google analytics is going
to do is store a cookie in the browser
so when that same user comes back
another day in the same brow browser
analytics is going to recognize that
that cookie is in the browser and so
then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking in analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here I can see
over 3/4 of my traffic over the past
week here I can see April 6th through
April 12th three over 3/4s are new users
to the website here I could see about 23
24% are returning users okay so I can
get a good breakdown of what type of
users are coming am I driving new
traffic am I driving traffic that's been
to my website before what language are
they speaking okay I can also paint a
bigger picture how old are they are they
what gender are they do they come from
mobile so let's take a look at some of
these different reports under audience
so if I skip down now to demographics I
can click on overview and when that
report loads I can see now under
demographics overview I can see the
breakout of age ranges and so here I can
see the majority of the traffic coming
to my site again over the past week now
if I want to to change this date range I
could simply do that I can change the
date range just by clicking on the date
range and then maybe going say the last
30 days and I can even compare it to the
previous period or the previous year I'm
going to choose the last 30 days I'm
going to click apply now I'm looking at
data over the last 30 days and again you
can change the date range to any range
you want you can only go back as far as
when you actually created the Google
analytics account you can't go prior to
that so here I'm looking at the last 30
days and I can see almost
47% of my users were in the age range of
25 to 34 now when it comes to gender I
can see
66% represent males so I can get a
breakout of gender and age as well as
interest and click on interest and look
at the overview there and see what the
interest is of the users who are coming
to my site based on in market segments
or Affinity I can also choose language
and location so if I want to know
exactly where my users are located when
they're coming to my website I can click
on location and here I can get a
breakout 43% of the users of the last 30
days were from the United States more
importantly I can align my audience with
goals and we'll talk about goals here in
a minute but here I can see if I have an
e-commerce website I can see of those
43% 29% of those converted or purchased
something and that equates to 94
transactions so I can get a good sense
of not only how many users are coming
from a specific country but are those
users converting if I click on mobile
and mobile to me is one of those reports
I tend to spend a bit of time on cuz I
want to know what what devices users are
coming to my website and so for my
website here or this is the Google demo
website I can see mobile represents
approximately
27% of the traffic so desktop still
represents a majority of the traffic so
for you you want to keep an eye on
mobile because mobile is definitely a
majority of what people use nowadays
that's how people start their day that's
how they transact a mobile whether
that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on Behavior so Google
analytics is telling me that yes I have
approximately 27% of my traffic of the
last 30 days came from mobile how are
they interacting with my website so if I
look across this report I'm going to be
able to see different metrics so if I'm
measuring specific metrics against my
dimension in this case the dimension is
what we're measuring and in this example
we're measuring mobile I can see that
the bounce rate is approximately 48% and
bounce rate means that if a user in this
case from mobile landed on a page they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so a bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48%
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
balance rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we can see 48%
Mobile in desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41% now if I look a little bit
further at engagement I can see how many
pages on average do mobile users look at
so versus desktop it's a little bit
lower you can see 3.8 6 on desktop it's
4.5 now if I look a little bit further
in engagement I want to be able to
measure how long somebody from mobile
stays on the website if they're bouncing
at 48% but they're also looking at 3.8
Pages 3.9 almost four pages per session
then that means in this report analytics
is telling me they're spending about 2
minutes on the site and interestingly
enough I can see that mobile over the
last 30 days had more transactions so 51
transactions versus 34 transactions from
desktop and interestingly enough the
eCommerce conversion rate is at 29%
that's higher than desktop at 07 it's
lower than tablet but it's higher than
desktop and mobile has the most
transactions and since they have the
most transactions they have the most
Revenue at
2,380 so yes the engagement isn't
exactly as great as it is as desktop but
we can see that people are still
purchasing with their mobile devices so
it's something to keep an eye on and
mobile is something I definitely look at
in fact since it's such an important
report one thing you can do in analytics
is if you actually like a report and you
think you're going to look at that
report multiple times then you can
simply just go ahead and click save at
the top here so if I click save I'm I'm
going to enter a name for this report
I'm just going to call it mobile report
and click okay and then what's going to
happen is it's going to be located under
save reports and save reports is located
under customization customization is
located above real time okay so if I
close that up you can see audience real
time customization if I click on
customization if I click on Save reports
I should be able to see my save report
here and I do so here I can see mobile
report if I click on it I can simply go
to the report I was looking at before I
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature in analytics cuz it allows you
to quickly access a report that you've
saved in the past so let's take a look
at one more report under audience and
let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we were setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt into
benchmarking and I recommended you do so
and so if you did actually opt into
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see how your site compares to
others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs and education and I choose
education all education as my industry
vertical I should be able to see
websites that are in the same particular
industry and how I compare with those
websites so I'm choosing all countries I
can narrow that down if I wanted to I
can just search for the United States I
can choose a specific State and then I
can choose a particular site size so
here I'm choosing sites by daily session
so these are sites that have an average
of 5,000 to almost 10,000 sessions a day
and so in this vertical education in the
United States sites that have 5,000 to
99,999 sessions per day that means that
there are approximately 310 web
properties contributing to this report
okay based on this criteria I chose now
if my site is similar meaning if I'm in
the United States if I'm in education
and I'm receiving 5,000 to
99,999 sessions per day then I'm able to
compare my site against 310 other
websites now Google's sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay so it's Shar
data anonymously in particular
Industries and verticals and so now I'm
looking at a channel report so if I want
to see how I compare to others in my
industry then I can go ahead and see by
Chanel Chanel for example am I driving
as much traffic as others in my industry
and you could see I'm not in fact I'm 76
77% worse in terms of the amount of
traffic being driven from organic surch
so anything in red is going to show as a
negative result a negative comparison
whereas something in green is a positive
comparison so if I look at engagement I
can see that I might not be driving as
much traffic
but I can see that the pages per session
are better than the site average or the
industry average I can see if I go over
again looking just at organic search I
can see the bounce rate is better than
the industry average so the channel
report under benchmarking allows you to
measure how you compare to others in
your industry and you could do so by
looking at location and devices so if
you opted into benchmarking when you set
up your account then you'll be able to
compare your website against others in
your industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how did these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview will be able to see an overview
of how users whether they're returning
or new came to our website and so what
analytics does by default is they have a
number of default channels and when we
say channels we mean analytics is
grouping different channels based on how
users got to your website meaning how
did users get to our website did they
come via organic search meaning did they
type something into Google and find you
in the organic listing analytics also
groups users based on whether they came
to your site directly meaning did they
type in the URL directly into the
browser or did they bookmark your
website and come back via the bookmark
so they're grouping users under direct
they also group users under referral
meaning do they come from another
website they group users by social do
they come from a social media platform
like Twitter or Facebook if you're
running run paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say Google
then do they come from Paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics Will Group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default Google analytics groups users
on how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I can see
how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number is about
56% so 56% of my traffic over the last
30 days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by channel so just like mobile we looked
at balance rate pages per session
average session duration we can do the
same thing here with our Channel report
more importantly in addition to behavior
we can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is .17
okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38,1
123 sessions and of those 38,1 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to17 which also equates to 3,000
in Revenue so I'm able to determine not
only how users are getting to my website
by looking at the channel report I can
actually see if they're engaging and if
they are converting and notice when you
look at a report in analytics you can
look at it by Channel you'll also get a
summary so here I can see a summary or a
total based on my date range so I can
see over the last 30 days I've had
54,000 users
49,000 of them were new okay that meant
that out those 54,000 users I had 70,000
sessions I can see my average bounce
rate was 43% the pages per session were
just over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about 2 minutes
and 55 seconds the average conversion
rate was .14 and at a total of 97
transactions totaling
$5,500 okay and that's all over the last
30 days so any report you look at in
analytics is going to have a summary and
note that any report you look at in
analytics is going to allow you to save
it so if it's a report you think you're
going to go back and look at at a future
date then you simply just have to click
on the save button conversely if you
don't want to save it you can simply
just export it so you can export it as a
PDF if I click on PDF it's going to
allow me to export that as a PDF now you
have other options available to you as
well you can do a Google sheet you can
export it as as an Excel or you can
export it as a common delimited file so
here you can see I can save it as a PDF
if I want to and if I click okay it's
going to save to my desktop or location
of my choosing and then I can go back
and look at it in that format at a later
time so that's the export feature
available to you in analytics again if
you you could save it as well or you can
export it okay some other reports under
acquisition if you're running Google ads
note that you can connect Google ads to
analytics and this is key because now I
can see how many people are coming from
Google ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with Google ads I'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here I'm
running a report based on campaign data
so I could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much I'm paying per
click and you can see on average I'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly I want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see I've
spent $810 over the last 30 days and
received
$858 in Revenue so you want to make sure
that you link up your Google ads account
to your Google analytics account for
this very reason you want to be able to
see how your Google ads campaigns
perform once the users get to your
website and so I want to see if they're
engaging and I want to see if they're
converting so there are all sorts of
reports under Google ads so you can look
at it by keywords by search queries by
hour of the day if you're running
display campaigns you can look at
display targeting so there all sorts of
reports under Google ads you just have
to link it up and you link it up under
the admin now there are other reports
that you can look at so if I go to
campaigns I can look at all campaign
aigns so if you're running all sorts of
different types of campaigns whether
that be on Facebook whether that be
email whether that be you know other
types of advertising let's just say
Twitter or Instagram you're going to be
able to see those campaigns here and
that's under all campaigns and again
you'll be able to see the campaign name
and you'll be able to see metrics
associated with those campaigns and more
importantly you'll be able to see your
e-commerce if you're running e-commerce
platform or if you have goals set up so
you'll be able to look at how your
campaigns are not one not only driving
traffic but two are they converting
let's go from acquisition reporting to
behavior so Behavior reports are going
to actually show you how users behaved
once they got to your website once they
landed on a page on your website how did
they behave so when we looked at
audience we got a sense of who is coming
with acquisition we get a sense of how
the traffic got to our website did they
come from organic direct social Etc the
behavior reports allow us to actually
measure how that traffic behaved once
they landed on a page on our website and
so if I go to overview under Behavior
now I'm looking at this graph here it's
showing me how many page views I've had
and a page view is simply once a page is
viewed it's counted as a page view so if
a user comes to my site they're
initiating a session and if they look at
a page then that page is going to have a
page view okay so a user can look at a
page multiple times in a session and
every time they look at that page it's
going to count as a page view so here I
can see in this graph how many page
views I've had again over the last 30
days and if I look further at my
overview report I can see the specific
pages and how many pages they've had and
I can also look at some other metrics
okay the average bounce rate the average
time on page I can look at the exit rate
which means how many people actually
exited or the percentage of people who
exited from that page so I can dig
deeper into my behavior reporting so if
I click on site content and I click on
all pages then I'm going to look at a
report by Page this is my Dimension this
is what I'm measuring my page and now I
can see how many page views each page
had over the last 30 days now note you
also have something called unique page
views so unique page views is equivalent
to one per session in other words if a
user came to my site and looked at the
homepage then the homepage is going to
have one unique page view and one page
view now if the user in that same
session looks at other Pages then every
page that user looks at is going to have
one unique page view however if the user
goes back back to to the same page in
the same session then it's still going
to be one unique page view but in this
case the homepage if they look at the
homepage a second time then the homepage
is going to have two page views if they
look at the homepage five times in one
session then the homepage is going to
have five total page views and one
unique page view okay so that's why
unique Pags is equivalent to one per
session where page views is a
accumulation of how many times the page
was viewed in the same session so in
other words you're always going to have
more page views than unique page views
okay so this gives me a sense of how my
page is performed so again I can look at
total page views and then engagement so
ideally what you want to do with a
report like this is if a user is not
engaging on the page then that should
tell you something about the page itself
if they're not engaging if the bounce
rate's high if the time on page is low
if the exit percentage of exit rate is
high then you probably want to do
something with that page now these are
all pages but if I jump down to landing
pages my landing page report is showing
me how many people actually landed on
that page and so here I can see under my
landing page report I can see the
homepage had
36,7 sessions in the last 30 days that's
how many people landed on the homepage
so here I can see 71% were new sessions
meaning that I had a lot of new users
who landed on the homepage in fact
25,000 or
52% of the people who landed on the
homepage were new I can see the balance
rates about 42% but of those who didn't
bounce they went on to look at about 4.5
pages per session and spent about 3
minutes on the site and the one thing I
like about the landing page report is I
can also see whether that particular
page in this case the homepage did it
help contribute to a goal or conversion
and in this case I can see of those
36,000 sessions I hit 22 transactions
totaling 1,200 in revenue and that's an
e-commerce conversion rate of
0.6% so the homepage over the last 30
days contributed to
.6% of the revenue so this gives you an
idea of when somebody lands on your
website and they land on a page is that
page helping to move that person along
meaning are they not bouncing and is
that page helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
case we're measuring transactions okay
so analytics also gives us some other
reports under Behavior including sight
speed so sight speed to to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me sight speed's
important because what Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page lad
time is about 4 seconds now ideally you
want to keep it as quick as possible I
would say even under 3 seconds okay now
there are other factors involved with
page load time the browser you're using
the country that you actually browsing
that page from mind how to have the best
infrastructure you may may not even be
on the best internet Network meaning
you're on a cell network or the Wi-Fi is
not that great or you can be on a page
that just has a lot of images or a lot
of code that may slow it down so there
are other factors involved and so what
Google Analytics does is show you what
those factors are so here I can see by
browser what the average lad time is if
I want to look at Country I can see what
country is contributing to the low time
now the great thing about the site speed
report is if I go to speed suggestions
okay what speed suggestions is going to
do is it's going to show me the page
load Time by Page and then it's actually
going to provide a link where I can
actually click on to to get suggestions
on increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop
bybrand yoube page line number five if I
look at line number five I can see the
average lad time of this page is 8
seconds almost 9 seconds okay that's an
eternity to some people now notice this
link next to it so Google's recommending
seven total suggestions so if I click on
seven total what it's actually going to
do it's going to open up a new window
and it's going to open up another Google
report called page speed insights and
Page speed insights is going to give me
some information about what I can do to
create corre correct the page load of
that particular page so look at the
sight speed report it's important
because there is a correlation between
site speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
Al correlation between page load time
and a page ranking organically on search
so page load time is very important it's
so important that I'm even going to save
it so I'm going to click save and click
on speed site speed suggestions as my
name and click okay and now that report
is going to be saved under customization
under save reports let's jump from
Behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in Google analytics because what
the conversions reporting allows us to
do is see how people are converting or
if they're not converting on our website
and so in Google analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals now you have
the opportunity to set up 20 goals in
your Google analytics View and so to set
up a goal okay so you're going to click
on admin and Under The View you're going
to see goals and so if you don't even
have goals the first step is to create
goals and so you have four different
goal types and analytics so you have
pages per session so how many pages per
session is so if your goal is set to say
three or two if somebody actually looked
at two or three pages per session it's
going to count as a goal okay so if I
look here I can see I have pages per
session set at 10 so that means that if
a user came to the site looked at more
than 10 pages per session then it's
going to count as a goal another goal
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it's going to count
as a goal and in this case I can see
here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's going to count as a goal now there
are two other goal types we can look at
one is duration so just like pages per
session in our previous example if
somebody looked at 10 pages per session
it's going to count as a goal with
duration it's based on time so in this
particular case if you set up a duration
goal and the duration is set to say one
minute and 30 seconds then that means if
a user comes to my website and they
spend at least 1 minute and 30 seconds
then it's going to count as a goal okay
and then the fourth type of goal in
Google analytics is is an event based
goal so when you set up event tracking
you could turn that event into a goal so
if somebody clicks on say the submit
button of a form you can turn that event
into a goal so here you could see the
category equals contact form so you can
always verify if a goal works just by
clicking on verify this goal and in this
case this event is turned into a goal so
anytime somebody fires this event it's
going to account as a goal so you have
four different goal types in Google
analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if I look at goals overview I can be
able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal two engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate of 10% meaning
that I had
7,000 of all the users who came to the
website 7,000 goal completions meaning
7,16 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be able to measure whether users
whereever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and then the great thing
about Google analytics here is that I
can actually see by segment so the
default segment and a segment is just
looking at a specific user set set so
the default segment is always all users
however I can choose a different segment
so if I want to choose instead of all
users if I want to choose Mobile Traffic
I can select Mobile Traffic hit apply so
I'm actually now looking at a subset of
data I'm looking at mobile traffic so of
all the mobile users who've came to my
site I can see
1400 engaged or looked at 10 pages or
more okay and that's a 7% conver version
rate so the great thing about Google
analytics is you have the opportunity to
set up four different goal types okay
based on those goal types you can go to
goals overview and look at the
conversion rate of each goal but you can
also change the segment of that
particular goal to see who exactly
converted okay another report I like
under conversions is the multi-channel
funnel report so if I click on multi-
channel funnel basically what this
allows me to do is see how different
channels work together to convert so
remember the channel reporting we looked
at under acquisition here I can see now
how different channels work together to
drive the conversion so if I look at
three channels direct organic and
referral I can see all three together
Drive 2% of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral 12 1 12% if I look
at direct and organic
12.24% so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion path as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times 2
meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first first time but
didn't convert but then they came back a
second time via direct and then
converted so that combination is my top
conversion combination of the last 30
days my second best conversion grouping
is organic search and direct meaning
that a user came to the website via
organic search first did not convert and
then came back via direct the second
time and converted so basically what
analytics does is give credit to the
last referral meaning if you came to the
website via referral a referring website
and converted then the referring
website's going to get the credit for
the conversion but analytics does a good
job of showing you how different
channels work together so a channel may
drive a lot of traffic like organic
search but that traffic may not convert
the first time around for number of
different reasons whether it could be
brand recognition Price shopping reading
content whatever the case analytics is
able to measure if that channel actually
did contribute at a later point and in
this case we could see organic search
drove traffic that didn't convert but
that traffic came back a second time via
direct and did convert so that's our
second best Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling report talk
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only had channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns and different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition beh Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance for this particular webinar
we're going to jump into Google
analytics directly and spend all of our
time there because it's about learning
practical application so goals are
important goals uh let me just say this
goals are in analytics something that
should be aligned with your business and
we call goals that are align with your
business kpis or key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in Google analytics because if
you're using Google analytics you want
to measure everything against a goal so
without further Ado let's jump right
into Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I log in okay what
I want to do is go down to admin click
on admin here and admin will take you to
basically a screen that looks like this
where you have a account column you have
your property column and then you have
your view column now the view column is
where you're going to go to setup goals
okay so every view in every property has
up to 20 goals okay so by default in
analytics you're going to have at least
one View for your property so if I have
a property I'm going to have at least
one view but if I happen to set up
multiple views like you see here then I
know for every view I set up I have 20
goals to work with so where are those
goals so Under The View I'm going to
click on goals and now I can see I have
20 at my disposal now you can see here
by clicking on the recording column I
can see I have in this particular
property this particular particular view
I have five goals that are active so you
can use up to 20 but you don't have to
have 20 active Okay you can have one
active two active my recommendation is
at least have one goal again when you
set up a goal you're going to measure
everything in analytics against that
goal okay so in this case we have five
particular goals we're measuring so we
have five active out of 20 total so if I
don't no longer want to use a goal I can
simply just turn it off if I want to
continue using it just turn it on okay
it's that simple you could turn on and
off goals so here I already have five
set up so if you want to set up a new
goal the one thing you need to know in
Google analytics is in order to set up a
new goal okay you need to have edit
access at least the view level I would
say at the property level so you want to
make sure whoever's in charge of Google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log into
Google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so I have
edit permissions I'm going to go to
goals and I want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal do you have an e-commerce site
is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99% of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free prefilled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
total control over how to set up your
goal so we already have in mind what
type of goal we want to set up so for
example if somebody goes to fill out a
form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so I'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15 that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available and analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so 1 through 5 6 through 10 11
through 15 16 through 20 into goal sets
so for example goal 16 through 20 is
part of goal set 4 and why does Google
analytics combine these goals into
different goal sets well because it's
easier to ma measure and look at data by
goal sets so for example if I jump into
any report here if I go to all traffic
channels and I want to measure how many
goals by Channel I can look at it by
goal set so if I have goal set one
selected then I know any goal I have
active in there between goal id1 through
goal ID 5 I'm going to be able to see
those goals and goal set one and and now
I'm going to be able to measure every
goal I have active in goal set one
against the channel so if I choose goal
set two whatever goals are active there
goal set 3 Etc notice I don't have any
goals 16 through 20 active that are in
goal set 4 therefore I don't have that
option available to me so back to admin
the bottom left navigation again goals
okay we want to measure somebody going
to the thank you page we have edit
access we're going to choose C custom as
our goal set up we're going to type in a
goal name I'm just going to say thank
you okay this is goal 15 now this is the
important part Google analytics has four
different goal types destination
duration pages per session or screens
per session so screens per session is
related to mobile because Google
analytics measures mobile app activity
and then you have an event so we're
going to cover all four of these but for
the sake of this simple example I'm
going to choose destination why because
if somebody goes to that thank you page
we're going to go ahead and put in the
thank you page as the goal the goal URL
so for example destination is my choice
I'm going to click continue now this is
where I'm going to put the URL so if my
URL is just simply thank you. HTML I can
just go ahead and put thank you. HTML or
if it's just thank you then I can just
do thank you depends on the website
depends on the URI structure so whatever
that URL is that's what you're going to
put in and when you're done you can
verify it so what Google analytics does
is actually will verify over the last s
days if anybody's actually gone to that
particular page so if we click verify we
can see 0% conversion rate so that tells
us that if this is the correct URL then
we had 0% people go to that page this is
just an example however if you didn't
see a conversion then you might want to
make sure you check the URL here that
you put in and if you do see a
conversion rate then you know it's
working so Google analytics actually has
options so we're saying thank you is
equal to so the destination URL is equal
to thank you or thank you. HTML or thank
you. ESP or whatever that thank you page
is okay you do have options so if you
have a long URL you could say begins
with and you could say begins with say
thank you so this is the logic we're
going to say hey if anybody goes to a
URL that begins with thank you then
count it as a goal or you could say
equals to so if anybody goes to a UR
that equals to thank you then count it
as a goal you have one more option Here
regular expression so Google analytics
understands the Lang language of regular
Expressions so regular expr expressions
are just special characters used to
communicate with Google analytics in
order to hone in on exactly what you're
trying to track so we can always say you
know starts with or ends with so we can
you know use characters like the dollar
sign ends with or begins with so we can
always do that so you can use regular
Expressions as well if you're familiar
with regular expressions if you're not
then you don't have to use them but
there are special characters where that
you can insert in that are used as
regular expression so if you're not
familiar with regular expression don't
choose that option you can choose the
other option of equals to or begins with
now note that on all three of these
options I didn't put the domain so if my
domain is-f foundation.org SL and then
thank you I don't need to put the domain
because analytics is already already
knows what domain we're tracking so you
don't have to put in the domain here
when you're entering in in this case the
go URL so you can omit the domain so
when you put in that URL know that you
have three options to work with and then
you always always want to verify that go
URL you always want to verify it because
if you see 0% conversion and in this
case of the last 7 days then that should
tell you something either your goal is
not set up correctly or you just don't
have any conversion either way you want
to double check that now when it comes
to the destination URL goal you do have
an option here for funnel so if I turn
on funnel then that means I have the
ability to track how people went through
my funnel so if I have a cart and I want
to be able to check how many people go
in and out of the cart
then I have the option of adding
specific Pages as part of the cart so we
could say you know step one which is
basically cart we could say step two is
billing information that could be SL
billing we could say step three is
shipping information SL shipping and
then step four could be you know confirm
and that could be SLC confirmation so
whatever your url structure is for your
cart and it doesn't necessarily have to
be a cart basically all I'm doing is
putting in a series of steps with your
rails as each step and why do I want to
do that because I can then track how
many people go through my funnel that
I've created okay so here I could see
this is my funnel that I've created for
this particular goal okay and the funnel
is only available for the destination
URL so the funnel is available if you
want to see track TR through the goal
okay and how people go through the
funnel and where they drop off now you
have an option here to make the first
step required so if you make that first
step required then that means you're
measuring the funnel through the first
step only now if I turn that off then
I'm measuring the funnel through each
step meaning that I can measure people
as they drop in and out of the funnel
where if it's required the first step
then I'm only measuring traffic because
it enters in the top of the funnel so
you have that option available to you
the funnel and then for all goals you do
have a value so if somebody did actually
convert Okay Google analytics is going
to count it as a conversion and you can
assign a value so if you're not an
e-commerce website then you may want to
think about assigning value if you are
an e-commerce website then analytics has
the ability to track ecommer mer revenue
for your website so you don't need data
value but in this case let's just say
your nonprofit organization and you're
collecting donations and on average over
the past year every donation that
somebody contributed was equal to $5
well you can just go ahead and put $5 in
there as the value for that goal so that
means that if somebody did go to in this
example slash than you and convert
convert analytics is going to count it
as a goal and then assign $5 value
alongside that goal so if you're non
eCommerce if you're say a nonprofit like
this organization or you're B2B and you
want to track some value then you have
that option there so with the
destination your Ro goal you have the
option of adding a funnel with all goal
types you have the option of adding a
value all goal types and we're going to
go through the rest of them you have the
opt option of verifying that goal so
that's the structure of setting up a
goal destination URL is just one goal
type we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in Google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of them with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel
information well you want to get out of
admen you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization So based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because I could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here I can see the first
step is the store front page so over
this particular period of time I had 84
sessions enter the storefront page so
out of those 84 I can see 21 left the
storefront page 63 went on to the next
step in the funnel which is the cart
page I can then see 24 people went on to
the cart page directly and five exited
the site all together okay so that gave
me 87 total and from 87 I saw that 82
went on to the next page with the next
step what analytics does is they give
you a percentage so in the first step we
had 63 move on to the car page out of 84
that's 75% so from the car page to the
create your account page we had 94% move
on so we didn't have anybody enter in
the create your account page we didn't
have anybody leave the create your
account page so we have 82% 82 create
your account and then we have 82 move on
to the payment page so that's 100% okay
we have one exit so we have 80 1 that
proceeded to beyond the payment page
which was purchase so 81 of 82 is
98% and we started with 84 so that gave
us plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so that gave us a 75% funnel
conversion rate so 75% of the people who
entered in the funnel went on to
purchase okay so don't be confused with
the overall e-commerce conversion rate
so 75% is the funnel conversion rate the
overall conversion rate for this
particular goal is
18.45% over this particular period of
time why because that takes into account
all sessions that have won to the
website so 18% of all traffic went on to
convert but those that did go into the
funnel 75% converted so that's a look at
the funnel so so if you set up a funnel
that's what it's going to look like you
have the option to measure everything
from step one and Beyond or measure as
traffic goes in and out of the funnel so
the purpose of this is we're going to be
able to see where traffic drops off how
effective our funnel is what pages we
need to address in that funnel okay so
that's the whole point of the funnel and
the funnel is available with the
destination URL goal so if I go back to
admin if I go back back to goals Under
The View I can actually see what that
funnel looks like so here we chose
regular expression so this is what the
URL is okay you can see our funnel in
each of the steps we have set up notice
we're using regular ex Expressions here
and then if we verify this goal we could
see over the past 7 Days 19% conversion
rate so that tells me something's
working in this particular with this
particular goal because we do have a
conversion rate okay so that's the
destination URL goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about is pages per session so if you're
not sure what type of goal to set up for
your website at the very least you
should try and set up either duration
related goal or pages per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session so B basically what
this goal is going to allow us to
measure is for example if we set the
goal to three pages per session then
we're going to be able to measure if how
many people went to the site and looked
at three pages per session so let's take
a look at that goal so if I open up the
goal here I can see three pages per
session is what we're naming it so
basically what we're asking analytics to
do is anything great G than two pages
which would be three and Beyond count as
a goal so if anybody comes to the site
looks at more than two pages three pages
or more then it's going to count as a
goal and so here we can verify it so if
we verify it over the last 7 days we
could see a
4.12% conversion rate and that tells me
that 4% of my traffic over the last s
days looked at at least three pages or
more so you're probably asking yourself
well what number should I put in for the
actual variable so in this case we see
two well what you want to do is you want
to look at on average let's just say
year to dat you want to make sure you
have statistical significance so you
want to look at a period of time so if
you go to analytics go to audience okay
and then if you go to overview and if I
change my date range to year to dat I
could see on average right now I have
1.21 pages per session so that's on
average so we don't want to make our
goal one page we don't want to make our
goal two pages we want to make it three
so we want to be able to basically
measure at a higher rate okay why do we
want to measure at a higher rate because
if 1.21 is the average then two pages
per session really isn't moving the
needle so what we really want to do is
get people to stay on the site longer
look at Pages more uh during their
session so look at more pages and so we
want to be able to see what segment of
the audience is looking at more pages
what channels driving traffic that's
looking at more pages what pages are
contributing to more pages per session
so the whole idea is you want to hone in
on what your goal is and see what's
working and and then see what's not
working so you can make adjustments the
whole idea behind Google analytics is to
improve website performance and so if
our average is
1.2 then if we change it to just two it
may not be good enough so in this case
you know we want to up the bar a little
bit so we're going to choose three now
you can choose four or five that's
perfectly fine just know if your average
is 1.2 I wouldn't choose one page per
session as my goal and I probably
wouldn't choose two so I'd set the bar a
little bit higher now the third goal
type available in Google analytics is
also engagement related and that's
duration so just like pages per session
we can measure how long somebody stays
on the website and we could set up a
goal for that so in this case I have a
goal set for 1 minute 30 seconds so my
goal type is duration so if I click
continue then basically I'm asking an
analytics in this case anybody who stays
more than 1 minute and 30 seconds on the
website count it as a goal and so before
you actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and 7even so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with 2 minutes so again the whole
point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here I can see over the last
seven days if I verify this particular
goal I can see 8% of my traffic over the
last 7 Days stayed on the site at least
1 minute and 301 seconds okay they
stayed greater than 1 minute 30 and so
the whole point is you can hone in
because this is a goal I can go in this
is goal okay this is a goal here and so
I could see that this is gold 13 so now
I can go to acquisition as an example I
can go to channels as an example since
this is a goal this is goal 13 so that
would be in goal set three so I can
actually see what channel is basically
driving that goal okay in other words
what channel is driving traffic that is
staying on the side at least 1 minute
and 30 seconds and so that's the whole
idea behind goals
so likewise for pages per session we can
go into channels and here I can see
we've have a over this period of time
year to date pages per session we have
3% conversion rate and here I Can See
For example organic search has a 133%
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a 10% so I can see that or
people coming from organic search are
staying on the site longer or they're
looking at more pages than any other
channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because it's engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic to the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal you
close custom click continue you have the
option to choose an event so an event is
something that you can measure on your
website that analytics can't measure by
default so if you want to measure PDF
downloads or clicks on buttons or clicks
on play buttons on a video
or click on a submit button or click on
an external link I mean you can measure
pretty much anything with an event then
you want to be able to turn that event
into a goal so let's quickly summarize
what an event is so again we want to be
able to measure a particular event that
happens on the website so in order to do
so we need to identify that event so if
I go to for example this particular
website here and I want to measure how
many times somebody clicks on the Donate
Now button well if I met I can measure
that as an event so when you set up an
event in analytics you have to actually
assign a category and an action for that
event so that's the first thing you need
to do when you identify an event related
goal first you need to set up the event
and in order to set up the event you
need to assign a category an action okay
so once you identify what you want to
track as an event on your website you're
actually going to go in a tag manager or
have your Web Master go to tag manager
and set up a tag and in that tag they're
going to assign that particular category
in action and so here you could see we
have this set up our category is named
donate now and our action is click and
that's what we want to do we want to
measure how many people click on that
donate Now button so anytime somebody
does that then the category donate now
is going to appear in analytics with the
action click so when you actually do set
up an event you can go into analytics
and you can test that event so if I go
to the website and I click donate now
Okay the reason why I have this as an
event is because I'm taking to a
third-party website to handle the
donations so here I can go into
analytics and now I can see a category
is being fired for header donate with
the action click so that's my category
and that's my action so that category
and action is what is firing after
somebody clicks on the Donate Now button
so if I want to turn this event into a
goal I can easily do that now that I've
set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal was
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name so has the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event call into
it and then that way when you're
identifying goals and you're reporting
you know it's an event so I'm going to
click continue and now that I've
actually have set up the event already
in Google tag manager I given it a
category I given it an action okay see
here you could see we have a regular
expression set up so anything with the
header donate or donate is going to fire
this goal so over the last s days I have
a 81% conversion rate okay I could have
easily put in equals two and put in
whatever the action what or the category
which is donate now or I could have put
action equals click I could have done
that as well so let me show you another
example here so if I do this custom
continue event donate now here's my goal
ID it's going to be an event so all I
need to do is put in the category and
action so donate now and then click so
that's all I have to do and that's
that's my goal so I can verify it okay
to see if anybody's fired it and
basically that's what I need to do to
turn that event into a goal okay so you
need to set up for an event first you
need to identify the event set it up in
Google tag manager which is another
platform and once you've done that then
you have your category in action once
you have your category an action you're
again going to go into analytics and
then simply put in that category action
into the appropriate fields to set up
your event related goal now all events
don't have to be turned into a goal if
you actually do set up an event and
you're not worthy of a goal meaning it's
not a kpi or doesn't align with your
business goals well don't fret you can
always just go to behavior okay you can
always go to events you can always go to
overview and measure your events that
way so so here you could see all of our
events that are fired now we do have
this one turned into a goal so if it's
important for our business then we want
to make sure we convert that particular
event into a goal okay if it's not
important for example somebody's just
clicking on a social button then you
don't necessarily have to turn that
event into a goal if you don't want to
know that it's sitting here under events
under Behavior so the point I'm trying
to make here if it's important to your
business business and you're already
tracking it as an event via Google tag
manager then feel free to turn it into a
goal all you need is that category all
you need is that action and so so one
final note on that event related goal
just like any other goal you can add a
value okay so if I have an event set up
I can choose to add a value here or in
Google tag manager if I've assigned a
value to that event so if I go back to
the actual event in Google tag manager
you can see I have a value set up for $1
then I can just go into analytics and
say you know what I already have the
value added so go ahead and use the
value added in Google tag manager okay
so I'm going to choose yes now if I
choose no I have the option to add the
value here just like I would with any
other goal so just keep that in mind you
can add a value to any goal type with an
event related goal you can add the value
right into the tag in Google tag manager
just as I've done here so remember when
you actually set up your goals whether
it's a destination pages per session
duration or an event you can just go
ahead and choose that goal set that it's
in and measure any Dimension against
that particular goal so here I can see e
newsletter signups by Channel I can go
in into another goal set here I can see
contact form submissions okay I can see
what particular channels driving contact
form submissions okay so just know that
you can align a goal against any
Dimension so if you have e-commerce you
don't have to set up a goal for that
that's separate but if you want to take
a look at your goals and analytics on
its own you can just go to conversions
goals overview here can actually get a
good sense of how my goals are
performing over a period of time so
again if I choose for example year to
date now I could see based on the goals
I've set up how many total goal
completions value which takes into
account the value we've added into these
goals okay the total conversion rate and
here I can see it broken down by the
goal I actually have set up and I could
see it by Page or I could see it by
source and media so I could see Google
organic is driving the most goal
completions then Google CPC direct and
then I could see some others in here as
well contributing to goals now I do want
to point your attention to another
report in Google analytics that does
take into account goals and that's
multi- Channel funneling so again under
conversion goals multi- Channel funnels
if I go to assisted conversions I can
actually see what channel in this
example is assisting with the
conversions I've set up and so what do
we mean by assisted conversions well
that means that if a channel let's just
say organic search drove traffic to the
website and that traffic didn't convert
when it arrived at the website and left
but it came back a week later via
another Channel let's just say email and
when they came back via email they did
convert during that session well what
analytics does is they give an assist to
organic search because they help Drive
the traffic to the website so it's
similar to the game of basketball if I
have the ball and I pass it to my
colleague and my colleague's the one who
scores cuz they had the ball last well
they get the credit for the point I.E
the conversion but I get an assist and
so analytics works the same way they're
always going to give credit to the last
click or direct conversion but they will
give credits to the channel in this case
that assisted with the conversion so
that's under ass cystic inversion and
that's based on the goals you have set
up you can highlight any particular goal
here if I want to hone in on say the
Donate clicks only then I'm going to be
able to see what contributed to that
particular goal so there's another
report in here top conversion pass that
I think is important so after you set up
your goals you can actually see what
channels in this particular example help
to drive conversions again this is year
to dat so I can see all the different
combinations of channels that work
together to contribute to a conversion
so again I can choose a specific goal or
I can choose all my goals so those two
reports are under multi- Channel funnel
there's also another report that I think
is good and that's time lag meaning how
long did it actually take somebody to
convert so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year to date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but I could see I did get some
conversions a day later two days later
Etc so you have time lack top conversion
passs assisted conversions they're all
under multi- Channel funneling and
they're all available after you set up
at least one goal and so if you're not
sure what goal to set up okay don't fret
you can always at least set up an
engagement related goal so that's
available to you duration pages per
session you also have destination and
event tracking and they're all available
to you you have 20 available per view
now if you're not quite sure exactly
what type of goal to set up there is an
option available in analytics and that's
the gallery so you can always import a
goal from the gallery so in other words
we could take a look at what other
people have set up in terms of goals so
you just have to click on the button
import from gallery and it'll take you
to the gallery and you'll be able to see
what are the goals others have set up
today we're going to talk about how to
set up event tracking in Google
analytics so let's get started so many
of you out there have a website similar
to the one I'm looking at now this is a
nonprofit that I work with I'm a
foundation and like this website and
probably like your website you probably
have some interactivity on there that
needs to be tracked for example buttons
uh if you have buttons like this one
that says donate or newsletter sign up
or there's a PDF download or a video
that needs to be you know tracked based
on the amount of people who click on the
play button so I mean all sorts of inter
activity on a website have you ever
wondered how to track that well there is
a way to track that because by default
Google analytics can't track
interactivity and engagement on your
website like you probably want to have
your website tracked so if you have
buttons and videos and things of that
nature that you want to have tracked
well you're going to need event tracking
and if you're in analytics and you're
always wandering around the data and you
have to find yourself under events well
if you want events on your website and
you want data to populate under Behavior
top events you're going to need to set
up event tracking so event tracking is a
two-part process and we're going to talk
about that two-part process the first
part of that is to identify what you
want to track okay so if we go back to
our example website here I'm a
foundation again we noted there's a lot
to track here we got a donate Now button
we got a newsletter sign up we have some
social icons okay we got a donate Now
button here we got a play button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says you know
purchase tickets for an upcoming event I
can go throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to to
track let me just say this there's no
shortage of what you can track on your
website with event tracking so event
tracking is just basically in layman's
term terms tracking engagement on your
site because Google analytics by default
is only going to track page view data
meaning how somebody got to your website
what page they looked at how long they
stayed on that page what page they left
from more or less they're timing how
long somebody stays on the website and
what pages they look at so there's more
to a website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the Dona Now button but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focused on the Donate Now
button then we'll come back and start
tracking these other things but this is
what we want to track to start out with
okay so step one identify what you want
to track now when it comes to tracking
events on a website you want to identify
those events so we did that by choosing
this donate Now button now once we
identify what we want to track we need
to assign two parameters for that event
so with event tracking you have three
parameters but one is actually optional
so you have two Mand mandatory
parameters that you have to assign to
everything you want to track on your
website and that's the category and then
the action so event label or label is
the third parameter but again that's
optional okay so basically when we
identify an event our website we want to
assign it a category and an action okay
so why do we we want to assign it a
category and in action because when we
are in analytics under Behavior under
events top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
Dimensions I'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters I've entered in
for previous events I'm tracking okay so
the whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to to you how you
organize your categories because
basically all you're doing is giving a
name to what you're trying to track and
the name is equivalent to a category so
in this case the Donate Now button is
very important I'm just going to call it
category header donate now I need to
give an action to each category and so
in this case I'm just going to say click
because that's what the action is doing
it's it's somebody's taking the action
of clicking now if it's a video and it's
a play button I can sign and action of
play it's up to you whatever you name
these parameters you just need to be
organized and methodical about what you
name it that's all and so in this case
header donate and then click okay and so
that's our category and action and so
that's clearly step two so step one
identify what you want to track step two
assign a category action and or label
but remember label is optional so if we
go back in Analytics here I can see some
categories and if I click on action I
can see some actions that I've named now
step three so we've identified in Step
One what we want to track we've assigned
a category and action so step three is
going into Google tag manager to set up
the event okay so if you're not familiar
with Google tag manager then you can
easily just you know do a Google search
for Google tag manager and basically
you'll have all sorts of information on
it there's a good video overview of tag
manager here that you can watch so tag
manager basically is what we want to use
to set up event tracking now tag
managers use for a lot of different
things but the main thing we're doing
here is setting up an event for our
website and so I'm logged into the same
email address I'm using for analytics
Okay so so now I'm in tag manager and I
want to set up my event for this donate
Now button so what do I need to do well
for every event I want to set up I need
to set up a tag okay so if I go to tags
I can see I already have some tags set
up and some of these are events and so
when you actually set up a tag I
recommend having a nameing convention so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it ga event D
whatever it is we're trying to set up
and so in this case we want to set up a
new tag for the Donate Now button on our
website so we're in Google tag manager
because tag manager is what's going to
fire that event so if I click on new
okay and I click on tag configuration
I'm going to choose Google analytics and
then I'm going to choose event as my
track type so we want the data to show
up in Google analytics and we're
tracking an event we're not tracking a
page we're tracking an event and so now
remember in step two you identified what
you want to call that category you
identify what you want to call that
action and you have some optional
parameters like label so first things
first header donates the name of our
category and our action is click and if
you want to add in a label and a value
so if you want to sign a value you can
if you want to add in a label you can
okay those are optional so you just need
to focus on category and action and then
the last setting here that's probably
worth mentioning is a non- interaction
hit okay so this is automatically set to
false and why is it set to false because
it's a non- interaction no that's false
we want this event if somebody clicks on
the header donate to be an interaction
so for example if I land on this page
here and I click on that donate Now
button that I'm tracking as an event and
and I actually leave the site because I
have my settings set to false I want
that click to be an interaction then
analytics is not going to count a bounce
if I change it to true so from false to
true then that means it is going to be a
non interaction if somebody lands on the
page and if somebody clicks on the
button so I don't want it to be a
balance I want it to be an interaction
so my advice is leave it set to false
we're going to choose Google analytics
as our setting here this is our variable
for Google analytics so in other words
that variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category and action Endor label Endor
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime time that
event fires in analytics it's going to
have a value of one okay and we have our
non- interactions set to fall so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
an interaction and therefore not count
as a bounce if somebody landed on that
page so that's more or less all you need
to do to set up the tag in Google tag
manager now if somebody else is setting
up the tag for you then again you want
to revert to step two you want to be
able to give that person the appropriate
category action and or label Andor value
why because you're the one that's going
to be going into Google analytics and
you're the one that's going to have to
go to behavior events top events and
look for the particular act category in
action Andor label so you need to be
able to communicate that information to
whomever is setting up the tag now if
it's you great you already know what it
is because you're entering that
information into tag manager so in this
case I'm going to go ahead and choose a
variable for my label parameter and why
do I want to do that because in tag
manager I have something at my disposal
called variables and variables allow you
to see specifically things that are
being tracked so in this case I chose
page path okay so page path is a URL and
why did I choose page path as as my
variable for the parameter label because
if somebody does click on the header
donate button and the header donate
button on our website is on every page
so if I go to the children's page I'm
still going to see that header donate
button and so for me I want to be able
to see what page somebody clicked on
that head or donate button and so this
allows me to actually see in Google
analytics what page somebody clicked on
on the header donate down button and so
now if I go back to GTM Google tag
manager I have a category I have an
action and I have a label which is a
variable okay so note that in Google tag
manager you have a lot of different
variables at your disposal and variables
are there to help you identify
specifically what is being tracked so
take a look at all the variables at your
disposal and tag manager in this example
I'm using page path so now once you set
up your tag pretty straightforward again
tag types Google analytics track type is
event you are assigning the category
action indoor label andoor value you're
changing or leaving the default in place
for non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for this particular event and so if I
click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is is a click on some links not
all links but some links I'm actually
saying Hey Google tag manager fire this
event when the click ID equals header
donate button now it just so happens
that if somebody did click on this
donate now button they're going to go to
another website in this case Network
forg good.com so in tag manager I could
have set the trigger to equal URL equal
instead of Click ID I could have said
URL equal Network forg good.com so that
could have been my Logic for my trigger
in this case I decided to go with the
click ID and so in this case that button
has an ID associated with it called
header donate button so if you wanted to
use click ID for your event for your
button you can simply just go to the
website you can rightclick on that
button and click inspect element and so
when I actually inspect the element I
can see now the button here you can see
it's highlighted in the the upper Pane
and in the lowerer pane I can see where
it's linking to it's linking to network
forg good.com but here you can see if I
hone in a little I could see ID equals
header Das donate-button so that's the
click ID notice there's also a class I
could have set the trigger to equal this
class or again I could have set the
trigger to equal the URL or the page
that this button is pointing to I could
have chosen any one of those but I
decided to go with the ID so this is the
ID I chose and that's the ID I have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to fire that event so if somebody clicks
on a button that equals header Das
donate Das button it's going to fire
that event which is going to equal
category head or donate action click and
then the label is going to be page path
so now that we've set up our event we
want to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event and the first way is through
Google analytics so if we go to Google
analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and go to and test this and go to
the website so if I go here for example
and I click on amagar alumni okay so if
I click on that you can see I'm under
our family and if I click on that button
then go back to analytics and look at
real time I should be able to see this
event fire so if I click on it I'm going
to go to network for good now if I go
back to analytics here in real time
under real time under events per second
I can see that event firing category
equals head or donate the action equals
click now if I click on the category
here I can see the label the label
remember was page path and here you
could see this event fired on the r
family page which was the page I was
just on so that's one way to test to see
if your event works and in this case
analytics recognized the event so it
works it fired and so therefore it's
going to show up under Behavior under
events you can go under overview or top
events okay and what am I going to look
for in this case I'm going to look for
header donate okay if I click on header
donate as my category I'm going to be
able to see my action and if I click on
action I'll be able to see my label in
this case homepage and then later on
when the data propagates in analytics
I'll be able to see under label the page
that I clicked on that head or donate
button which is SL our family okay the
second way in which you can test to see
if an event file
is if you preview so if I click on
preview in tag manager okay I'm going to
go into preview mode okay and preview
mode allows you to see in analytics in
tag manager and on the website what tags
are firing so here I can see I'm in
preview mode now so I'm going to go to
the website and I'm going to
refresh and in my browser same browser
I'm using for tag manager I I can see
the tags that are being fired on this
page already okay cuz I'm in preview
mode so here I can see remarketing I
could see page views I could see Google
optimize I could see some tags that are
already firing on this page now if I
click on this button here by holding
down my shift command and then click on
that button I'll be able to see that the
tag fired in preview mode there's my
event header donate and I can see it
fired so so now I can see it fired in
the preview mode so in addition to
Google analytics in preview mode I can
see that that tag is fired and I know
that it's working so there you have you
have two ways to test to see if the
event fires again you have real time and
analytics okay so in real time if you
just go up to real time all you need to
do is go down to events go to your
website click on the button if you see
it firing in real time then you you know
it works the second version or second
way to test your event is through the
preview mode okay if you see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's rehash our steps
first step is we want to be able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a Facebook it could be
anything we want to be able to track an
image a click on a CTA button whatever
we want to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in Google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so if you set up a tag and it's
an event name it g- event that way you
can see in your list of tags and tag
manager what event tracking you have
already set up so when you set up your
tag you set up your trigger your trigger
is based on logic that can be a URL it
can be a click ID it can be a class ID
whatever you want to use to fire that
event and then once you do that you want
to test it you could test it in GTM or
you could test it in Google analytics if
it doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing I would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website as a best practice what I
would recommend is set up a spreadsheet
and in that spreadsheet you know you
want to put a note what's firing what
are you doing to fire it could be in
this case when somebody clicks on the
Donate Now button and the header you
want to put the tag name in here the
type okay then you want to record your
category action and label and then the
great thing about events is you you
could turn those events into goals and
that's as simple as going back into
analytics okay so if I go in analytics
and I go to admin and I go to goals if
you set up a new goal okay all you need
to do is choose custom click continue
you're going to choose event as your
goal name and then from a naming
perspective in Google analytics for your
goal I would definitely put event first
and then click on header donate
okay so if I click now continue what is
my category it's equal to header donate
my action is click and so I can verify
to see if this is working and here I can
see in analytics that the goal would
have a 22% conversion rate so that tells
me that the goal is working and I can
turn this event into a goal and when you
turn something into a goal and analytics
then you can measure it across all
dimensions that's what I would recommend
if the event is equal to a kpi or
business goal or it's of importance it's
something you really want to measure
okay if it's just a click say on a
Facebook button I wouldn't recommend
setting that up as a goal okay so once
you've set up your event you recorded it
in your spreadsheet it's firing you want
to be able to then go back into Behavior
back into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if I choose my date range
here I can just go here to date so here
I can see my header donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now noticed in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same
session so if I go to the Yama
Foundation website okay I can click on
that donate Now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users May click on the button more than
once in the same session and so here I
can see total events unique events and
if I added a value to that event I
should be able to see it here so if I
added a dollar as an example to this
particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see 16
4 as my value but since I see Zero that
means that I did not assign value and so
average value basically is just giv me
how much average I have per event so
it's taking into account the number of
or the value the total value divided by
the total number of unique page views or
sessions and so because I don't have
value I'm not going to have average
value but here you could see because
value is opt here I can at least see how
many events or how many clicks I receive
for particular button again it could be
a video if I clicked on this video as an
example I can see how many people
actually started it I could see the
unique in the total events and if I
click on label if I have a label
assigned then I'll be able to see what
page triggered that event so if we go
back again to our header donate button
back to category if we click on label as
our primary Dimension here we can see
the homepage had the most unique events
been followed by the children's page the
contact form Etc so what you can do in
analytics you can also look at the pages
that have driven events so here I can
see the homepage has accumulated the
most total events followed by the
contact us so that's how you would look
at the data in Google analytics under
Behavior under events and then under top
events or overview is where you can
start analyzing your event tracking so
first you need to do identify it assign
a category action and or label set up
that tag and Trigger once you do that
once you test that it's working this is
where you're going to go to analyze the
data I have been doing content writing
for about 5 years now and trust me it's
not an easy as it looks as a Content
writer there are lot of challenges from
start to finish you have got to really
know who you are writing for and make
sure your content is right for them your
writing should be short clear and in
good order and don't forget to keep your
writing style friendly and the same
throughout but it's not just about
writing as a Content writer you also
need to make sure your content works
well on search engines check and fix
mistakes a lot and keeps it unique and
you have got to listen to what the
client says to make it better it's
tiring making great content that really
helps client takes a lot of time
sometimes you run out of time and the
quality of your work might not be as
good making you less productive but here
is the good news today I am sharing a
quick trick for Content writers that
saves times boost creativity and
productivity and keeps the quality
topnotch I am introducing top five EI
tools for content right writing in 2024
before we move ahead with top five AI
tools for Content writing consider
subscribing to Simply learn and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
us so let's begin with top five AI tools
for Content writing on number five on
the list we have is wrer wrer is an AI
powered sentence completion tool that
enables you to create high quality
original content within minutes its
smart features includes language autod
detection so you can create cont content
in multiple languages its AI is powered
by gp3 that will help you to create
content that compete with professionals
with this smart editor you can write it
in clear tones that will immediately
connect with your target audience right
here exist in both free and paid
versions you can use up to 10,000 tokens
in free version while the paid version
starts from doll9 per
month just go to wrer doio log to your
account find the settings where you need
to choose whether you are a single
writer or you work with a team or what
is the main motive of yours to uh use
this tool once you are done you can see
this screen so this editor provides the
feature of either sentence completion or
you can also create the complete data or
the article or anything whatever you
want to try so right now let's as we are
already talking about the content
writing let's take a
small introduction of what is content
writing with using the
[Music]
writer. let's start by knowing what is
content writing and once you click on
the completion you'll get the small
intro about content
writing yeah there you go so we have got
a small introduction about what is
content writing like this you can create
whatever ad copies of or you you need to
create an article or blogs or whatever
kind of content you want and from the
right side you can see there are certain
settings where you can choose the
languages a language for your writing it
may be UK English or us English then
grammarly you can use it the tone can be
formal or informal and the creativity
and everything the length of the content
moving to number four on the list which
is copy. a copy. a stands out as a
versatile tool that enables content
teams to boost their output by 10 times
without compromising quality with an
array of 90 plus tools and templates it
guides user through the creation of
diverse content including blog post
landing pages payer click PPC ad copy
social media post and much more copy. a
is available in both free and paid
versions you can create content for free
up to 2,000 words per month however with
the paid versions there is no word limit
and it will come at $149 per month so
just log to copy. a web app and where
you will get an option of chat so we are
already here I have logged in and I have
got certain again I've have got certain
uh options to choose whether I'm a just
I'm working as a single content writer
or just choose whatever option is for
you and just click on the chat so here
we can get all the requirements uh it is
again the generative AI kind of stuff
which we are getting with the
copy. so let's take an example to write
a copy for a social media post for a
perfume r so here I'll
WR write a social media post for
a for
a brand
name super
perfs let's see
let's try if we can get another more
options from
this let
provide two other
versions and let me tell you this what
I'm using is completely free of cost so
yeah you got a number of versions
here and from this even if you have
certain points to be included you can
just make those changes in this um chat
section and you can get the change
version of above
versions the next tool on the list is
Right Sonic right Sonic is gaining
popularity in the list of AI tools from
past few months a perfect place to
create long form and short form content
so get content ready write the best blog
post SEO descriptions product
descriptions or any web content needed
with right Sonic it includes multiple
features like it carry out plagarism
checks maintain brand voice that makes
it onstop solution for Content writers
right Sonic is available in both free
and paid plans free plan includes 10,000
words per month however the paid version
starts from $113 and go as high as $1500
per month log to the right Sonic account
using your Google or any email ID once
you log to right Sonic you get a number
of things like library history get
number of
other right Sonic apps like audio Sonic
and Jack Sonic and you can create
content using those also they also
provide uh image generations and text to
speech uh even the generative AI using
chat Sonic you can write an article or
create your own document let's try to
use the chat B on the chat Sonic and
write
s cre
article on what is content
writing let's
see what is working to create an article
and what is content
trting you can see that within few
seconds we got a article of very good
words
length and what I can see from this was
it looks completely SEO optimized with
the keyword content writing and it
covers almost all the possibilities of
content writing like purpose of content
writing we get the types of content
writing like blog writing website
content we are getting social media
content copy writing technical writing
and definitely they are not just
providing about the content writing but
skills required to become a Content
writer or skills required for Content
writing the next tool or number two in
the list is writer writer the another
widely used content writing platform
famous for its short form content
features if you are looking to create
content for social media product
descriptions emails for marketing and
sales SEO meta title website copies and
much more then yes writer is your
perfect companion writer is available in
free and paid versions free version
provides 10,000 words per month while
paid version starts from $19 per month
to use this web app you just need to log
to the writer account and you will get
option to create a copy to create an
image and to create a chat so let's use
a
chat so let's try to create content for
the very first Pur we have
used write the
homepage content for the perfume
brand also writer also provides the
facility to add or edit the already
created document you can do it from the
new document feature here so here we can
see we got a very good length of content
which shows and uh describes in detail
about a perfume brand you can
additionally add any of your points to
cover if anything is missing or if it is
required by a client or any changes any
addition any
donation here I'm using the free version
of Writer
app at number one we have chat GPT Chad
GPT can assist in content creation by
generating ideas expanding drafts
providing editing suggestions and
answering queries aiding in creative
writing suggesting language enhancement
and offering basic translation services
it is available in free and paid
versions chat GPT 3.5 is available for
free version whereas gp4 is available in
paid
versions as we know chat is the widely
used tool and I'm here using chat 3.5
which is completely the free version for
chat G uh gp4 is the paid version as we
discussed earlier first we try to write
the Facebook ad copy for the per
so
write Facebook
ad
copy
for perfume
brand perum
name super
super within few seconds we got almost
everything for a super perfumes brand
they are covering the website link they
adding the hashtags and
[Music]
everything
is completely ad
optimized so here we wrap up top five AI
tools for Content writing covering the
best free tools used by content experts
do give it a try and let us know your
thoughts in the comment section below
recent data indicates that to thrive as
a successful marketer integrating social
media marketing into your strategy is
essential staying informed about the
newest technology for social media
management is very crucial the objective
is to distinguish yourself from
competitors however given the multitude
of social media tools it can be pretty
challenging to determine the best
starting point in this video we will
furnish you with an extensive
compilation of the most highly regarded
social media tools for overseeing your
marketing campaigns we will delve into
the features and advantages enabling you
to make well-informed decisions about
the tool that will most effectively
enhance your social media marketing
strategy in
2024 now let us discuss our today's
agenda we going to start our session
with lead generation tools moving ahead
we will discuss about buyer Persona
tools then we will Deep dive into
security tools moving ahead we will also
discuss about analytical tools and at
the end we're going to conclude our
session with the content creation tools
but before we start our session I
request you guys that do not forget to
hit the Subscribe button and click the
Bell icon for further updates in this
video we have made it simple for you by
listing the best social media media
management tool for businesses we have
picked up tools from various categories
such as lead generation tools buyer
Persona tools security tools analytical
tools and content creation tools
depending on your business size you
might consider using more than one so
let's start with the lead generation
tools which Drive traffic to your
website and help convert visitors into
loyal customer so one standout tool is
opt-in Monster it lets you engage at the
perfect Moment by creating attractive on
the site marketing campaigns with
templates and campaign Builder precisely
by targeting an easy integration into
websites if I talk about his clients its
clients are Harvard University then Pine
interest then we have Trip Advisor let's
talk about the pricing it is $9 per
month for basic plan and $19 per month
for the plus version then you have $29
per month for the pro and $49 per month
if you want to grow grow if I talk about
the rating guys I would like to give it
four out of five ratings now let's move
on and discuss the next digital
marketing tool meet here raffle press a
WordPress giveaway plugin that comes up
with an easy to ouse drag and drop
giveaway Builder and they are ready to
use templates it's designed to help
businesses expand their email list and
boost website traffic one standout
feature is the verified bonus actions
rewarding users with additional contest
entries for actions like following you
on social media and sharing your
giveaway its client are single grain
marketing school and blogging wizard if
I talk about its pricing guys raffle
press offers a plus version for $49 per
year a pro version for $99 per year a
growth version for
$199 per year or a lifetime version for
$449 per year now let us discuss its
rating if I talk about its rating guys I
want to give it 4 .1 out of five now let
us discuss the next lead generation tool
that is smash balloon smash balloon is a
handy social media tool that lets you
seamlessly embed social media feeds
directly onto your WordPress site this
Nifty feature assist in turning your
website visitors into loyal social media
followers if I talk about its Clans guys
its Clans are Coca-Cola Clorox and if I
talk about its pricing guys smash
balloon provides five distin plugins
with options like $98 per year for
professional version $198 per year for
business version and
$398 per year for the smash version if I
want to give a rating for this digital
marketing tool I would give four out of
five now let us discuss our next lead
generation tool that is TW TW your go
too tool for boosting your Twitter
followers it identifies users interested
in your topic and engages them actively
to grow your following it offers the
silver plan at $12.99 per month and
platinum plan at
$24.99 per month now if I want to give
it a rating I would give it 3.9 out of
five now let's move on and discuss about
the buyer Persona tools which are
crucial for understanding your ideal
customer one standout tool is soo which
identifies social media users matching
your buyer Persona it tracks social
Behavior to categorize users and even
allows you to segment them for more
targeted
approaches if I talk about this clients
guys its clients are extreme networks
and Microsoft now let us discuss its
pricing if I talk about say pricing guys
it's recommended to reach out to soo
directly now let us discuss its rating
its rating is 3.6 out of five now let us
discuss the next tool that is social
Bakers social Bakers is a tool that aids
business into monetizing campaigns by
assessing competitive performance and
leveraging follower data for informed
business decision its client base are
National Geographic hinin and Sony if I
talk about his pricing guys social
Bakers offers the essential package at
$200 per month for 10 profiles or $400
per month for 20 profile and if I want
to give it a rating I want to give it
3.6 out five now let us discuss our next
tool which comes into the security
domain when it comes to securing your
business against threats like hackers
and scammer consider using zero Fox this
tool collaborates with social media
platforms to dedu and Safeguard
businesses from potential hackers
additionally it actively removes
offensive content shielding your
followers from scammers and help
preserve your business repetition if I
talk about is client guide guys it is
trusted by Phoenix Suns and First
Command let us discuss its pricing for
pricing tailor to your business get in
touch with zero Fox directly that is
recommended very much now guys if I want
to give it a rating I would give it 3.5
out of five now let us discuss our next
tool that is last pass which is a
password protection tool designed to
assist businesses in managing social
media passwords it not only AIDS in
creating robust passwords but also
securely stores your existing passwords
in a world if I talk about say clients
it is trusted by the New York Times Fox
Business and The Economist now guys let
us discuss its pricing last pass
provides a free version a premium
version for $3 per month a team version
for $4 per month and a business version
for $6 per month I hope so guys you
would have got a brief idea that how
this tool can be useful mostly in the
media industry it would be very good now
guys let us discuss about its rating its
rating is 3.6 out of five now let us
discuss another analytical tool which is
Twitter analytics if I talk about guys
Twitter analytics it sounds very
synonymous with Twitter actually it is a
valuable social media tool for
businesses and the best part it it's
free for anyone with a Twitter account
this tool enables you to analyze and
measure your camping's performance
by examining engagement understanding
how users interact with your account and
facilitating adjustments to your
marketing efforts now guys if I discuss
about its client its clients are Fujitsu
and Panasonic let us discuss its pricing
as I have already told earlier that it
is free and if I want to give it a
rating I would give four out of five
it's a very amazing tool and I would
recommend it to you to integrate it with
your business now let us discuss the the
next tool this tool is also a very
versatile social media tool designed for
crafting Instagram and Pinterest content
Tailwind empowers you to create visually
appealing social media post schedule
them effortlessly using their Auto
publishing system and optimize for
Maximum Impact if I talk about its
client guys its clients are allora and
also meridith let us discuss its pricing
tailin community of one lakh members are
for free or elevate your experience with
the pro version just at $9.9 per month
the advanced version is
$99.99 per month and you can go for the
max version which is
$39.99 per month if I want to discuss
about its rating I would like to give it
3.9 out of five now guys let us discuss
the next tool this is also a very
amazing tool and it stand outs as a
distinctive content creation plug-in
which allows you to repost previous
content across various social media
platforms it automatically incorporates
relevant hashtags by analyzing old tags
and categories this tool is beneficial
for businesses offering the chance for
your audience to ReDiscover and engage
with older content while also
maintaining an active social media
presence if we talk about its client
guys it is trusted by HubSpot and also
buffer if I talk about its pricing guys
you can choose the plans like $75 per
year for the personal version
or $149 per year for the business
version and you can also choose $299 per
year for the marketer now guys when the
time comes to give it a rating I want to
give it 4.2 out of five it's a very
amazing tool so Guys these were the top
digital marketing tools to grow business
or learn in 2024 greetings everyone this
is Rob Sanders with simply learn thank
you for joining and today we're going to
cover digital marketing inter interview
questions and answers so thanks for
joining again and here's how it's going
to work so we broke out a few questions
and answers uh in different categories a
lot of you are going to be interviewing
for some jobs out there in some of the
jobs maybe an SEO manager or search
engine marketing manager or email
marketing manager or content marketing
manager or social media manager so we
broke up those questions into those
areas and so that's what we're going to
do we're going to start with SEO we're
going to go through some questions and
I'm going to explain the answers to
those questions so if you have any
questions to these questions or answers
feel free to just comment right below
this video and we'll get back to as soon
as possible so let's get started we're
going to start with SEO search engine
optimization we're going to go through a
series of questions and I'm going to
answer those questions for you okay so
the first question question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you taken or listen
to my SEO courses on YouTube for SEO we
we talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put I mean do
follows or just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to site B we're
going to basically tell Google Bing and
these other search engines hey go ahead
and follow that link now a no follow is
just the opposite so no follow link
doesn't allow the search engine crawlers
to follow it so if we have a link on our
site s site a pointing to site B we can
put a no follow tag in there and what
that's going to do it's going to signal
to the Crawlers hey don't follow this
link so in the end if the Crawlers don't
follow the link then there's not going
to be any link juice passed and so
Google is not going to give you credit
or give that site credit for having a
link pointing to it or pointing to
another site or from another site and so
it's all about linking so we can control
if there's links on our site whether we
want the Crawlers to recognize those or
not simply with no follow Texs so just a
reminder link ju is the reputation or
Equity pass from one website to another
so if you have a link on another website
and that website is of high quality
meaning their page Authority their
domain Authority is high they have a lot
of content you know they're not spammy
they're really rich and they're relevant
then you may want to make sure that the
link pointing from that site to your
site is a no follow so that way that
Google can recognize the link from that
site to your site and basically that
reputation is going to be passed on to
you okay so that's a do follow versus a
no follow and why would we do a no
follow well it just depends
it really depends a lot of social media
platforms like Facebook have no follows
if you have a lot of content you may not
want to be pushing out a lot of do
follows it could actually look bad from
an external linking standpoint and so a
lot of sites are really particular about
who they want to pass link juice on to
and give credit for the link so it's a
business decision at the end of the day
there's really no hard fast rule here
except from an SEO perspective if I have
a site and I have a lot of external
links pointing outward to other sites
I'm going to be particular about who I
allow the search engine to follow and
what links I allow not to follow okay so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the hre
notice the no follow has the the tag
appended to it the hre tag with a no
follow so if the search engine's
crawling your site and they see that no
follow there they're not going to follow
that link and vice versa if there's a
link on another site point 20 to yours
and there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
aren't going to pick up that link okay
so question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so 301 redirects tell users in the
search engine specifically that an
original page has been moved and this is
the key word here permanently so
permanently moved we're going to explain
that in a minute so it's just moved from
one page to another and so if we don't
have a page any more we have a new page
let's just say you built a new website
with new URLs you want to make sure the
old page is pointing to the new page
with a 301 redirect so if a 301 redirect
is permanent then a 302 is temporary so
we want the search engines to recognize
that we have 301 permanent redirects in
place why because if we have temporary
then it might alert Google to not keep
keep that page in its search engine
rankings because it's temporary so why
would Google want to keep a temporary
page or even a page that is pointing to
another page on a temporary basis so
they REM May remove both pages from its
index okay but if we have something
permanent in place Google may say okay
this page is permanently linking to
another page or redirecting to another
page therefore it's stable it's
permanent we're going to keep that new
page in the index and eventually remove
the old page so really something
permanent is more stable in the eyes of
the search engine something temporary
may not be a stable in the eyes of say
Google and if they don't see it as
stable then they may remove both pages
from the index okay so the idea is we
want to be found in Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect hey so question three
why are backlinks important in SEO well
we kind of hinted on that a bit with the
no follow because if we have a link from
another website pointing to ours and
that link from that other website is
really relevant and and it has a high
page and domain Authority then it's
going to benefit us and so backlinks are
important because if we have backlinks
from high quality sites it's going to
improve the credibility of our site
especially if it's a do follow tag so
the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have high domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get more of a Lon share of the
traffic for certain keywords that our
pages are found for and if our pages are
found and getting traffic then because
we have increased rankings we're likely
going to have increased traffic and then
it's just a snowball effect so more
traffic leads to more engagement and
conversion so the whole idea for SEO is
remember you have an onpage strategy and
an off-page strategy building external
links is part of an off-page SEO
strategy and we want to make sure that
you know we are relevant in the form of
a link or in the form of content on
other high quality sites being on a high
quality site only benefits us because
again increases your D domain Authority
Google sees this is more relevant
therefore pages are going to benefit by
ranking higher and therefore when we
rank higher we get more traffic so it's
a snowball effect so having backlinks is
important because it snowballs all the
way through to conversions okay so what
are the best practices to rank your
videos on YouTube this is a great
question really great question given the
importance of videos especially with SEO
CU videos are found YouTube in itself is
a search engine so if we have a video
how are we going to get it to rank on
YouTube well first things first you
never want to put a video out there and
want it to rank if it's not engaging or
informative so make sure you go ahead
and follow the best practices of having
engaging in informative content in your
video now once you have that video in
place you you want to optimize it and
then some of the key factors for
optimizing the video are you want to
choose a title that has high search
volume and low difficulty just as you
would keyword for example for a web page
you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty I.E low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of a title they're going to want to
probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter or Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
going to grab somebody's attention and
then again we set it similar to the
video tags we want to use relevant
hashtags again just as you would with
Twitter and Facebook go ahead and throw
some hashtags in there that people could
see because people search via
hashtagging and then this goes about
saying you did all the work created a
really great video it's engaging it's
informative you optimized it feel free
to promote your video on other social
media platforms okay don't just stick
with YouTube per se so the benefit here
is if you post it on Facebook or
LinkedIn or whatever platform of your
choice
and it gets engagement people click on
the link go to YouTube they're going to
like it and then other people are going
to see that engagement they're going to
see how many people liked it or how many
subscribers you have so promote your
videos to help you with the ranking of
the video on YouTube so that does play
into it so go ahead and promote it so
other people can watch it like it
comment Etc and that's going to engage
other people to want to do the same so
what is mobile first index ing this is a
really important and timely question
mobile first indexing means Google's
just using mobile friendly content for
indexing and ranking websites so in
other words Google for example has two
Bots they have the traditional desktop
bot and they have a smartphone bot and
eventually everybody that has a website
is going to be migrated over to the
smartphone bot and so if that smartphone
bot goes to your website and starts
crawling what do you think they're
looking for their smartphone bought
they're looking for mobile friendly
content if it's not mobile friendly
meaning the page isn't design for a
smartphone browser or let's just say the
images are way too large or you have to
expand the text just to read it you know
a lot of these these issues that
somebody would have just simply trying
to read something on a web page on their
mobile device Google's not going to grab
that content so you want to make sure
it's mobile friendly so it gets indexed
and so if your website has a responsive
design Google will rank your website
based on its performance on mobile
devices okay so you want to make sure
that your website is mobile friendly and
if you're in an interview and somebody
asked this question you could even take
it a step further and say look I'm going
to measure how friendly my my website is
for mobile devices in Google search
console because Google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but I
could tell you if I'm Google and I'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
Bob and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly I'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that report in Google search
console to see what pages are mobile
friendly so that's a little bonus for
you to really impress the interviewer
who asked you this question because how
you going to know if one of your pages
is mobile friendly or not if you don't
look at a report so keep an eye on
Google search consoles mo mobile
usability report okay number six list
down the most important local SEO
ranking factors okay so organic local
ranking is just as important as anything
else in organic search because if you
have a local business you want to use
the likes of say Google my business to
show up when somebody types in you know
looking for flist or you're looking for
a coffee shop so what you want to do is
you want to create a web page for every
product and service okay you also want
to opt for your business listings on
Google my business and and there are
plenty of other local business
directories out there like Yelp for
example or Bing even has one so go ahead
and also make sure you have a business
listing as well but since Google in the
United States has a huge market share
you want to start with Google first you
want to up update your nap citations on
your website maintain consistency of
your nap okay so nap is name address
phone number so you want to make sure
that that's current and consistent so if
you have a number on your website make
sure it's the same number on Google my
business okay you can embed a Google map
on your website you could certainly
optimize the metatags and content not
only on your web pages but within your
Google my business directory so you can
add your business to other local
directories like I mentioned Yelp and
then also just as important op for
reviews and ratings okay so the more
reviews that H you have the better off
you are okay so I always say this with
or with local search three of the main
factors in showing up for local search
on say Google is obviously the keyword
the second is the proximity of where
that person is and then third is the
reviews so you can't really control the
proximity but you can control the
keyword and you can control the reviews
to some degree so work hard at getting
reviews for your business but at the
same time you can certainly work in some
keywords let's just say for your product
and service pages on your website but
also you can translate that over to
Google my business okay so working in
those keywords making sure your your
number your address your name they're
all consistent and really just spreading
your the the business out on other
directories that's really all these are
really key factors for local SEO okay so
question number seven how to avoid
duplicate content getting penalized for
duplicate content so for example if you
have two different versions of a web
page you may result in a duplicate
content issue so it's just SEO 101 you
never want to have two two or more pages
with the same content so what do we do
well we can avoid this and having Google
penalize us by again setting up a 301
redirect remember 301s are permanent we
can also use what they call a canonical
tag and a canonical tag basically alerts
the search engines as to which page is
the original okay so if we have an
original page we want to point to that
page with our canonical tag and then the
third option is opt for preferred domain
in Google search console okay so if you
have multiple domains make sure you set
up a prime primary one and search
console so those are ways to work around
it of this three I would always go with
the canonical tags because that's just a
tag that's going to sit on the page it's
going to alert Google as to what the
original is just in case they get their
hands on the duplicate so all the pages
that have the same content are going to
have the same canonical tag pointing to
one page so again three ones are
permanent you can simply just redirect
one to the other if you end up having
duplication or you could just tell the
search engines hey this is the original
page or you can go through search
console okay number eight what are the
tactics to increase a web page speed
okay so what are some of the tactics
well when you build a site especially
for mobile you want to keep it as simple
as possible what I mean by simple as
possible really I mean hey use a simple
website design don't get overly creative
if you will most websites all websites
have images you're not going to be able
to get around that but just make sure
you optimize your images in other words
don't have such a large image size if
you don't need something very large
don't have it okay you want to improve
server response time and what do we mean
by that well your site's sitting on a
server somewhere you can own that server
or you can be renting it out from say
Amazon web services or let's just say
GoDaddy as your register they also have
web hosting well if you have it on say
God daddy server you may be sharing that
server with other businesses and and at
certain times of the day other
businesses may get a lot of traffic and
suck up a lot of bandwidth what is that
going to do that's going to reduce the
server response time for your site and
so you want to make sure you have a an
idea of you know what server your web
page your website is on and you want to
be able to can have some control over
that because if your server response is
slow that's going to slow down
everything else in terms of loading in
the browser and that's not going to be
good for SEO okay optimize your code we
mean by optim minifying when we say
minifying we mean get rid of some of the
Redundant code if you have CSS you know
get rid of chop some of the get rid of
the JavaScript you're not using so
that's what we mean by optimizing code
reduce redirects okay ideally you just
want to have one redirect in place you
don't want to create a daisy chain so to
speak of redirecting and redirecting
after that that's never going to bode
well and it's going to slow things down
as well enable browser C caching so if
you enable browser caching basically if
somebody comes back to the page they've
been on say two days ago they're
probably going to see a cash version of
that page and then op for the content
delivery Network as well so these are
some of the ways to reduce page speed
now if you're curious about the page
speed of your website you can always go
to Google's page speed insights tool and
all you have to do is just Google page
speed insights or even just something
generic like Google page speed and
you're going to get this tool page speed
insights and all you need to do is just
plug in a URL when you plug in the URL
Google is going to analyze the URL for
both mobile and desktop and so here we
could see Google gives the score so we
could see the score for mobile and we
could see the score for desktop just by
clicking on desktop and so here I could
see some of the issues that the site may
be having in terms of page low time for
their desktop if I flip over to mobile
you know here I could see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with officient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specifics here
and or you can just always Google it as
well uh here you got the reduce the
impact of third party code okay so
that's another thing uh reduce
JavaScript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
made about coding okay so sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should will tend to slow down
the site okay so you can use page spe
insights you can always get a glimpse of
how pages are loading simply by also
going to for example Google analytics
under Behavior okay you can go to site
speed and if you click on overview okay
Google what Google does is they do a
sampling of pages over time and and this
in this case based on 89 Page views they
have an average page load time and so
you can get a sense of how quick
specific Pages load your site overall
simply by looking at the site speed
overview report in Google analytics to
get a sense of how quick your pages are
loading now there's certain factors that
do affect load time so obviously the way
the page is built with the code the
images Etc but also the browser each
browser loads differently okay so you
want to take a look at it by browser
also by country every country has a
different network you can be in the
United States and have worse network
service than you do say in you know co
uh I Coast in Africa okay so it really
depends on the network you're on so and
also the page every page is built
differently so you want to get a sense
of what pages are loading quicker and
which pages are not you can simply just
go to page timings in Google analytics
and you get a sense of what pages do not
load fast which ones do and maybe hone
in on the pages that aren't loading fast
and address those pages first okay so
you have two tools at your disposal one
Google analytics and one page speed
insights okay so let's look at question
number nine here so when should an
individual Target short tail and
longtail keywords okay so remember short
tail are usually one to two keywords
very Broad in nature longtail keywords
maybe three four keywords in a query or
maybe an entire sentence those are
considered longtail keywords so usually
short tail keywords have higher volume
but also higher competition longer tail
keyword usually have lower uh volume but
also lower competition but the great
thing about longtail keywords the
conversion rate will tend to be a little
bit higher than say a short tail because
it's less vague and more specific so you
can use short tail keywords if you're
trying to drive a lot of visitors
because those keywords are going to be
vague or Broad in nature longtail
keywords are used for targeted Pages
such as product pages and articles so if
you have a specific product with a long
name you can certainly optimize that
page for that product name again the
product name may have low volume but if
somebody types in exactly that product
name you show up the chance of them
converting are going to be very high so
you don't have to always be that
specific with the product name but try
and be as specific as you possibly can
in order to get somebody to click on
your link in the search engine results
and get them over to your site to
convert okay so those are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may may not be as high
as something say longtail where hey
maybe you're just toned in on a few set
number of products and you're not care
you don't care of a lot about the
traffic you just care about getting the
relevant traffic to your site to convert
okay number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of SEO
okay so if somebody ask me this question
in an interview what am I going to focus
on When developing a website well the
the answers are right here yes we talked
about mobile mobile is so important
because a lot of websites are going to
be indexed with Google smartphone bod so
mobile usability is very important so we
need to make sure our website is
responsive for mobile just some basic
practices when it comes to site
architecture navigation we want to have
a simple URL structure okay no overly
cumbersome the navigation should simply
be clean and need okay if you have five
products okay maybe you have uh in your
navigation you have something called
products with all five listed or you
have all five products in the main
navigation the key is you just want to
make it clean and neat easy for somebody
to find the the rule of thumb is if it's
good for the end user probably going to
be good for Google but if complicated
for the end User it's probably going to
be complicated for Google you always
want to create a Sit map now what is
that sitemap a sitemap is simply just a
formatted file with to that's includes
all your URLs and assets your images and
your video
they're going to be sitting on your
server as well so you want Google or
these these Bots to be able to find your
pages in assets and by the way you want
to take it a step further and make sure
you upload that site map which is
sitting in the root directory meaning
domain.com sitemap.xml okay you want to
take that sitemap and make sure you
input that sitemap location in Google
search console that way Google search
console has a oneway ticket to grab the
elements in the sitemap another
important element to focus on while
developing a WIP side is having a
robot's text file and all A robot's text
file is it's like a lock I always say to
a house so if you lock a door in your
house nobody's going to be able to get
in that door so it's all what robots
text file is you're telling Google and
these other Bots that are coming ACR
your site what's locked and what's not
locked meaning what they have access to
what they don't have access to so you
want to be a ble to make sure you have a
robots text file if you're trying to not
index specific pages of your website
because if you tell Google don't crawl
these Pages or this directory they're
not going to get crawled if they don't
get crawled they're not going to get
indexed so robots text file is an
important element to focus on while
you're developing your website and while
you're developing your website it could
be on a you know in a directory just
called new website so you probably want
to have new website as the directory in
the robotx text file and just to let
Google know don't go into this directory
cuz it's my new website I'm not ready to
go live yet so you don't want it indexed
so there are a lot of reasons to have
robots text files that's the main reason
sitemap you want Google to get these
pages and assets quickly okay you want
to make sure that your side architecture
navigation is in order you want to make
sure your site is mobile friendly and
you also want to make sure you have
content on your website that's the key
CU that's what's going to keep people on
the website and engaged and when I say
content I don't necessarily just mean
words I also mean videos I also mean
images you know something interactive
okay you want to keep people engaged
that's the key behind it trust me if if
an end user finds your side engaging
Google is likely going to find your side
engaging okay so those are good brownie
points to bring up if somebody asks you
this question in an interview so so just
a recap here it's important to have a
better site structure so that Bots can
easily access and mix content okay with
a responsive design helps to make your
website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your sites ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine Bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages there are on your website and
where they located along with the videos
and images okay and then the robots text
just just instructs the search engine
crawlers to understand what pages should
not be indexed okay this is simply just
a text file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house
think of it that
way staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link l
in the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here